bonjour à tous bienvenue à tous ceux qui
nous rejoignent en direct sur le Figaro
live nous sommes ensemble pendant une
bonne partie de l'après-midi pour vous
faire vivre ce quatrième acte de
mobilisation contre-la réforme des
retraites tout au long de la journée
nous allons alterner entre le terrain où
je me trouve avec Julien Leclerc et puis
les studios du Figaro ou Vincent roux
nous attend avec tous ces invités vous
le voyez je me trouve pour le moment sur
cette place de la République à Paris
beaucoup de monde autour de moi
évidemment le cortège qui s'était lancé
il y a quelques dizaines de minutes
depuis cette place de la République en
direction du boulevard Voltaire et de
cette place de la Nation après trois
appels à manifester et en semaine les 19
et 31 janvier puis le 7 février cette
quatrième journée de mobilisation et
bien c'est la première fois de piller le
début du mouvement qu'une journée de
mobilisation se tient un week-end les
opposants à la réforme des retraites
répondront-ils à l'appel des 13
organisations syndicales c'est la grande
question de cette journée avec une
baisse significative de la mobilisation
mardi dernier en tout cas aujourd'hui
près de 240 manifestations sont
organisées partout en France d'après les
syndicats l'épaisseur des cortèges sera
scruté de très près par le gouvernement
mardi dernier
757000 personnes avaient manifesté
partout en France d'après la place Bovo
contre 1,27 millions le 31 janvier
aujourd'hui les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur nous disent qu'entre 650 000
et 850 000 personnes pourraient venir
battre le pavé et à Paris il pourrait
être entre 90000 et 120 000 l'une des
inconnus de la journée c'était également
cette question du potentiel durcissement
du mouvement l'intersyndical seddiprète
ce matin à mettre la France à l'arrêt le
7 mars prochain du côté du ministère de
l'intérieur on craint évidemment une
radicalisation du mouvement et c'est
pourquoi et bien 10 000 policiers et
gendarmes se mobilisés aujourd'hui
partout en France ils sont 4500 rien que
dans la capitale un dispositif similaire
à celui qui a été déployé mardi dernier
et enfin et bien pour ce qui est du
parcours que va emprunter ce cortège je
vous le disais le cortège qui est parti
il y a une dizaine des minutes depuis
cette place de la République il est
parti en direction de la place de la
Nation ou les manifestants sont attendus
aux alentours de 19h et pour le moment
et bien la tête de cortège se trouve au
niveau du boulevard Voltaire
voilà et c'est au niveau du boulevard
Voltaire que va se passer l'essentiel de
cette manifestation et c'est sur ce
boulevard Voltaire se célèbre boulevard
Voltaire que on va vous retrouver
Timothée deslem et avec vous Julien
Leclerc bonjour à tous bienvenue
également ici dans le studio du Figaro
c'est de là aussi qu'on va suivre cette
nouvelle mobilisation cette nouvelle
manifestation
parisienne notamment mais également vous
pouvez suivre sur le site du Figaro 1
dans le live qui est juste en dessous de
ce player les infos qui nous viennent
des autres régions des autres grandes
villes vous pouvez voir que notamment
que que le collet le cortège vient de
s'élancer à Nantes et également que la
place de la Bourse à Bordeaux la
magnifique place de la Bourse à Bordeaux
et noir demande nous rapporte
jean-citone qui est l'un de nos
correspondants à au Figaro Bordeaux
bonjour à tous
j'attends vos réactions en étant directe
à la fois sur YouTube on est allé en
direct également sur le site du Figaro
vos commentaires vos questions on va
retourner dans un instant place de la
République retrouvée Timothée délai dès
que la caméra de Julien sera rallumé en
attendant je vous donne un petit peu le
programme de l'après-midi le programme
on va rester environ 4 heures ensemble
au moins 4 heures pendant lesquelles on
va retrouver les correspondants du
Figaro dans une dans quelques secondes
maintenant Thomas Engrand journaliste au
Figaro économie il était présent ce
matin à la conférence de l'Inter
syndical il va nous dire quels ont été
les infos on les connaît avec une menace
d'un blocage total du pays le 7 mars
prochain c'est ce qui a annoncé en tous
les cas le coordinateur de l'Inter
syndical Frédéric Souillot le patron de
FO à la mi-journée vous avez vous pouvez
le retrouver dans le dans le live texte
également du figa et puis vous avez
également les on aura avec Thomas on
espère du moins un point sur l'ambiance
qu'elle est l'état d'esprit à quel
niveau de mobilisation
l'interdicale considère RA que cette
journée est un succès qu'elle est
l'ambiance également en coulisse entre
les tenants d'une mobilisation pacifique
et comme les notamment la CFDT qui est
en vraiment en tête de cortège
aujourd'hui et même qui est au cœur du
cortège aujourd'hui ou bien les
partisans de la radicalisation notamment
du côté de Sud solidaire peut-être de la
CGT on verra ça tout à l'heure dans un
instant Florent maillet du Figaro voyage
sera également à 15h avec nous pour nous
faire un point justement sur les
blocages et également cette information
qui nous est parvenue en milieu de
matinée d'abord sur Twitter et ensuite
par les agences 50% des vols qui ont été
annulés à pourquoi pourquoi et bien à
cause d'une grève surprise des
contrôleurs aériens qui ne sont pas
pourtant concernés par la réforme on va
faire le point justement sur l'impact de
ces grèves l'impact des de la crainte de
ces mobilisations sur les départs en
vacances et les départs en voyage donc
Florent Mayet 15h 15h30 Arthur bijouta
du fil data sera avec nous il nous
donnera également le pou de la
mobilisation non seulement à Paris les
tendances qu'on attend mais également ce
qui se passe en région on l'a dit tout à
l'heure non de Bordeaux avec la place de
la Bourse noire de monde mais également
ce qu'on appelle les villes moyennes ce
qui en réalité sont les préfectures et
également un phénomène qui monte en ce
moment la mobilisation dans des
sous-préfectures ou dans des communes
qui sont de taille encore plus
restreintes on parlait de 800 personnes
qui ont manifesté dans la très jolie
ville de Brioude en Haute-Loire tout à
l'heure c'est du jamais vu et ce sera
une occasion effectivement de faire le
point sur cette mobilisation ce qu'elle
révèle également on y reviendra
également avec nous nos autres invités
un leader syndical sera à côté de nous
tout à l'heure c'est Cyril Chabanier le
président de la CFTC 16h
à partir de 16h30
Cyril Chabanier c'est le patron de la
CFTC jamais le ça faisait longtemps que
le syndicat ne s'était pas autant
manifester et mobiliser contre cette
réforme alors on va lui dire pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ensuite
qu'est-ce qu'il propose et qu'elle est
la situation en tous les cas quel est
l'ambiance est-ce que c'est une ambiance
si froide dans le dialogue avec le
gouvernement que le rapporte un certain
nombre de confrères notamment
l'excellent Wally Bordas du Figaro ce
matin dans un portrait notamment qu'il
fait excellent portrait de Laurent
Berger le leader de la CFDT 16h05
auparavant Raphaël rousselo économiste
et banquier d'affaires mais qui vient
d'É un livre extrêmement intéressant qui
s'appelle demain à la fin de
l'insouciance et qui nous dira ce qu'il
pense de cette réforme des retraites et
puis on fera le point sur la
mobilisation sur les réseaux sociaux
comment il
sont utilisés par les organisateurs de
cette
mobilisation mais également est-ce qu'il
y a une mobilisation sur les réseaux
sociaux et comment réagissent les
partisans de la réforme a commencé par
les le gouvernements et les
sympathisants de la majorité des groupes
qui constituent la majorité et on
conclura cet après-midi en tous les cas
ici en studio avec le politologue Arnaud
Benedetti auteur d'un livre de référence
absolument à lire comment meurent les
politiques c'est aux éditions du Cerf
Arnaud Benedetti grand observateur de la
vie politique grand observateur
également de la vie sociale viendra
également nous dire si cette
mobilisation est réussie ou non on va
retrouver Timothée
il est sur la place de la République
avec un journaliste du Figaro c'est
Thomas Engrand Timothée Thomas je vous
laisse la parole
oui Vincent avec Thomas grand
journaliste au Figaro en charge des
partenaires sociaux vous avez assisté ce
matin à cette réunion de l'interdicale à
11h45 avec les 13 organisations
syndicales qui étaient réunis à ce
moment-là quelles ont été les annonces
qu'est-ce que vous avez appris ce matin
alors plusieurs choses ont été soulevées
le premier point c'est que les
différents leaders se rendront à Albi
pour la prochaine journée de
mobilisation qui est le 16 février en
échangeant avec eux alors déjà le
premier point c'était de vouloir mettre
en avant la mobilisation dans les villes
moyennes qui est assez exceptionnelle
depuis le début de la contestation en
échangeant avec eux pourquoi Albi alors
plusieurs raisons il fallait donc que ce
soit une petite ville avec un bon
dessert mais surtout le point important
c'est qu'il fallait une zone qu'il ne
soit pas encore en vacances ce qui était
le cas de l'Occitanie d'où le fait
qu'ils aient choisi cette ville d'Albi
deuxième point important c'est la
confirmation de la date du 7 mars après
c'est la journée du 16 février qui avait
fuite et dans la presse qui a bien été
confirmé
particularité il s'agira pas d'une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation comme
on peut être les précédentes dont celle
d'aujourd'hui là il s'agit vraiment
d'une journée dont le but est de mettre
la France à l'arrêt c'est les mots qui
ont été utilisés voilà donc on sent que
effectivement on passe dans une nouvelle
étape
du conflit à noter que la journée du 7
mars est suivie donc de la journée des
droits de la femme le 8 et si les
syndicats ont pas encore détaillé ce qui
comptait faire ils ont d'ores et déjà
prévu de profiter de cette journée aussi
pour pour marquer la contestation ça
veut dire quoi est-ce que ça veut dire
que l'on se dirige vers un fameux
durcissement du mouvement selon vous
très clairement c'était étendu et on
s'en doutait on ne savait pas encore à
quel point mais effectivement en
échangeant avec le leader Force Ouvrière
qui a lu le texte pour l'Inter syndical
il a très clairement pointé qu'il avait
voulu donner la même solennité la même
importance que lors de l'annonce du 10
janvier celle qui avait lancé la
contestation de l'intersyndicale là il
s'agit vraiment de marquer que voilà la
première phase du conflit est fini celle
des grandes mobilisations des grandes
journées de mobilisation comme celle
d'aujourd'hui celle du 19 du 31 et du 7
voilà les résultats ne sont pas là le
gouvernement n'a pas reculé sur l'âge
des 64 ans comme le demande les
syndicats et donc comme annoncé
effectivement un durcissement du conflit
7 journées
France à l'arrêt comme le vol les
syndicats à noter quand même une chose
importante on sent que il passe la
seconde mais pas encore la troisième la
question des grèves reconductibles qui
avait plusieurs fois été soulevé par
certains certains syndicats notamment le
plus radicaux n'est pas encore sur la
table aujourd'hui mais en échange avec
eux très clairement si la parler du 7
noeud fait ne permet toujours pas
d'obtenir les gains voulu il n'est pas
exclu que
cette option le mouvement se durcisse
encore une fois Thomas dans quel
atmosphère s'est tenu cette réunion de
l'intersyndicale est-ce que cette
question du durcissement du mouvement
s'accompagne d'une forme de tension dans
l'air qu'est-ce que vous avez qu'est-ce
que vous avez senti à ce moment-là bah
très clairement le mot d'ordre comme
souvent c'est détermination on lâchera
rien des des choses qui sont assez
connues voilà toujours cette volonté de
montrer qu'il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un
doute deuxième point important toujours
cette volonté de cette volonté de
montrer que les syndicats sont plus
uniques jamais que rien ne vient gripper
cette machine voilà y compris le
durcissement des choses comme ça et
effectivement on sent aussi mais depuis
plusieurs jours et on l'a très bien
senti lors de cette inter syndicale que
il y a une sorte de de de frustration
d'énervement grandissant effectivement
entre le gouvernement qui n'entend pas
malgré la répétition des mouvements
voilà de la part des différents leaders
voilà la tension durcit aussi vis-à-vis
du gouvernement ça c'est pour ce qui est
des leaders syndicaux pour ce qui est du
terrain ici vous avez plus d'une heure
que vous êtes sur cette base de la
République vous avez rencontré certains
manifestants vous avez vous êtes venu
voilà regarder un petit peu ce qui se
passait quelle ambiance qu'elle
atmosphère avez-vous avez-vous retenu
sur ce début de manifestation bah cette
journée est exceptionnelle dans le sens
où est c'est la première j'en ai une
mobilisation qui a lieu un week-end
c'était une demande de longue date
notamment de la CFDT qui voulait ramener
un public différent des familles des
gens qui ne peuvent pas forcément
prendre des jours de de grève enfin se
perdre une journée de salaire puisque
c'est ça dont il s'agit donc en me
baladant le voilà le pari allait réussir
on voit effectivement pas mal de
familles des enfants donc là dessus
c'est un point plutôt marqué par la sfdt
la question à la fin sera forcément
celle de l'affluence du nombre de
personnes alors pour le moment on n'a
pas forcément tous les chiffres de ce
que disent les leaders quand on les
interroge avec leur premier retour de
terrain bon c'est les chiffres des
leaders ça ne tient qu'à eux mais c'est
que la contestation serait au moins
équivalente à la journée du 31 janvier
qui a été pour le moment la plus grosse
journée de mobilisation donc si cela
était confirmé par les chiffres du
ministère de l'Intérieur il s'agirait
effectivement d'un succès pour pour
cette journée de du 31 pour cette idée
de faire des journées de mobilisation
week-end en tous les cas comme la CFDT
de l'appeler effectivement de ses vœux
par la voie notamment et bien de son
secrétaire général Laurent Berger vous
confirmez que vous avez vu des enfants
des familles avec peut-être donc un
changement peut-être de personnes que
l'on voit ici aujourd'hui par rapport
aux manifestants que l'on a pu croiser
mardi dernier par exemple non tout à
fait il y a effectivement la location
c'était effectivement de voir des
familles c'est le cas il y a des enfants
très jeunes nombreux il y a des
poussettes il y a voilà effectivement on
sent qu'on sort du public habituel des
le temps des syndicalistes qui sont là à
toutes les à toutes les manifestations
effectivement là le public est plus
large il est différent effectivement les
syndicats disent depuis le début qu'il
faut voir la journée de mardi et celle
d'aujourd'hui comme un tout ils vont
essayer de dire qu'il faut additionner
les deux affluences pour avoir un œil
une idée générale de la mobilisation ce
qui ferait effectivement énormément
grossir les chiffres donc donc voilà des
publics très variés merci beaucoup
Thomas grand voilà journaliste aux
Figaro on cherche des des syndicats nous
allons maintenant et bien rejoindre
cette tête de cortège qui se trouve sur
le boulevard Voltaire
[Musique]
devant notamment une enseigne McDonald's
c'est effectivement un des risques
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est ce qui est
redouté par les
le gouvernement et par les responsables
qu'il y ait une radicalisation du
mouvement en tous les cas un petit peu
plus de tension dans le cortège en
particulier dans le cortège parisien
images en ce moment qui sont vous le
voyez envoyer par la société de presse
il y a d'autres cortèges en région il y
a un cortège à Marseille où se trouve
actuellement Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a
également un cortège à Lyon qui vient
également de partir c'est cortège donc
constitue quelques-uns des 240
manifestations qui sont organisées
aujourd'hui à Paris on va retrouver
Timothée délai d'un instant tal à
l'autre qui va nous dire un petit peu
quelle est l'ambiance la place de
République où il se trouve et ben voilà
je vois je vois Timothée Timothée on
voit quelques quelques images un peu de
tension en tous les cas des informations
qui ne sont pas revenues est-ce que ça
se passe près de chez vous et quel est
l'ambiance qu'elle est l'atmosphère sur
place
peut-être que c'est une illusion
d'optique mais j'ai quand même
l'impression que c'est c'est moins
massif derrière vous que on a pu le voir
lors de précédentes mobilisation
alors oui je vous confirme Vincent c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup moins de monde
là sur la place de la République au
moment où on se parle en même temps il
faut dire que le cortège est parti
maintenant il y a il y a de longues
minutes en direction et bien de cette
place de la Nation par le boulevard
Voltaire le cortège pour l'instant et on
va peut-être demander à Julien de vous
montrer ce cortège qui est en train de
défiler les derniers manifestants sont
en train de quitter cette place de la
République on le voit en cortège pour
l'instant qui qui se déroule de manière
tout à fait classique j'allais dire
voilà vous le voyez d'ailleurs sur ces
sur ces images il y a là-bas un petit un
petit orchestre beaucoup de drapeaux
beaucoup également de de ballons de de
syndicat en voilà de du syndicat FSU que
vous voyez à l'écran juste maintenant
juste derrière ce sont et bien les
ballons bleus que vous voyez ça c'est
l'une ça avec aussi et bien de très
nombreux le drapeau pour l'instant vous
me demandiez Vincent si je constatais
des tensions
sur la place de la République très
sincèrement nous n'en n'avons pas nous
n'en n'avons pas constaté pour l'instant
voilà les manifestants sont en train de
se lancer pour ceux qui sont encore sur
cette place de la République de se
lancer dans cette manifestation et pour
l'instant c'est une manifestation tout à
fait classique j'allais dire avec voilà
c'est drapeau c'est slogans c'est
banderoles et voilà il est manifestants
qui qui sont partis pour pour battre le
pavé toute l'après-midi
[Musique]
pour mettre le pavé pendant toute
l'après-midi et ben on va vous y laisser
aller retrouver quelques-uns de ces
manifestants nous dire pourquoi ils sont
là pourquoi ils manifestent ce qu'il
craignent pour leur retraite est-ce que
il refuse ce qu'il refuse c'est de
partir après
à 64 ans est-ce que c'est la crainte de
ne pas avoir une retraite par exemple
une retraite à taux plat est-ce que
c'est une notamment le cas pour
certaines femmes est-ce que
il craignent pour leurs enfants est-ce
qu'ils craignent que pour certains de
devoir travailler et avoir des retraites
de misère du fait de la situation
démographique voilà ce sont toutes des
questions également que on se pose et
peut-être que certains manifestants
pourront le donner vous pouvez avoir
d'ailleurs des réponses qui sont données
sur ces sur ces à ces questions là dans
le live texte actuellement du Figaro qui
est animé par les excellents
journalistes mobilisés autour du non
moins excellent Gilles Boutin le
rédacteur en chef du figaro.fr pour le
week-end
on a une déclaration d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure de Jean-Luc Mélenchon Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est à Marseille
et qui se dit persuadé que il se passe
quelque chose de très profond dans les
mentalités c'est ce qu'a déclaré juste
au début de du corps de la manifestation
le leader insoumis monsieur Macron s'il
compte sur l'usure se trompe de pays
affirme également l'ancien député des
Bouches-du-Rhône et anciens candidat à
l'élection
présidentielle
des informations également sur la
situation dans les la tension dans les
cortèges quelques jets de projectiles
dans la manifestation parisienne nous
vivent la lumière garçin
Berson rue exemple à Paris c'est ce qui
correspondait tout à l'heure aux images
également qui nous étaient
parvenu et que nous donne assez cette
presse et c'est exactement les images
que qui sont alors là vous les voyez pas
elles sont à gauche de mon écran mais
vous les verrez d'un instant à l'autre
en tous les cas vous vous voyez la
locortège lui a commencé à démarrer
depuis un peu plus d'une heure environ
je vous rappelle que le l'un des leaders
de cette intercer syndical le président
de la CFTC Cyril Chabanier sera tout à
l'heure notre invité ici même sur dans
les studios du Figaro je manifeste pour
mon avenir de ma fille autant à son
avenir autant que pour moi c'est ce qui
a déclaré une mère de famille qui est
présente dans le cortège parisien et qui
a rencontré Elisabeth Pierson qui
l'autre une autre de nos journalistes
sur place autre info qui nous a été
donné tout à l'heure cette fois-ci par
Cohen journaliste alors là c'est pas du
tout ce qui se passe ce que c'est un
des caméras de l'AFPL continue d'avancer
pour l'instant pas d'information sur
cette chute qu'on a eu est-ce que
c'était une chute inopinée à malaise
autre chose on ne le sait pas encore
et dès qu'on le saura on vous le on vous
le dira il n'y a pas mal de monde il y a
des gens de tous les milieux des
étudiants des collégiens des salariés
c'est ce que constate en tout cas
Sarah qui est une autre manifestante qui
regarde
en regardant tout autour d'elle alors
c'est vrai que c'est une mobilisation
exceptionnelle
à laquelle s'attendent en tout cas ce
qui espère plusieurs syndicats commencé
par la CFDT qui a été et qui a nous
disait tout à l'heure Thomas Engrand
militait pour que cette journée
de mobilisation et lieu un week-end et
lieu un samedi même si c'est un samedi
de départ en vacances et tout à l'heure
justement on verra quel impact
euh le fait que ça se tienne un jour de
départ en vacances on va voir ça avec
Florent maillet du Figaro voyage qui
sera dans ce studio d'ici une dizaine de
minutes maintenant d'autres informations
d'autres éléments d'ambiance vous le
voyez donc quand même un cortège assez
fourni les deux les deux images sont à
Paris celles que vous voyez à l'instant
et puis également des une place de la
Bourse
noire de monde nous dit jean-sitton à
Bordeaux et également
une première estimation qui vient d'être
donné on va en discuter d'ailleurs dans
un peu moins d'une heure avec
Arthur bijouta du fil data 321 milles
manifestants en France
à 14h30 c'est en tout cas
un chiffre qui vient des données qui
sont collectées par le par Le Figaro
donc c'est notre estimation
321.000 manifestants actuellement et
c'est effectivement beaucoup plus en
tous les cas que
mardi dernier lors de la précédente
mobilisation où l'on comptabilisé 272
000 manifestants à la même heure vous
avez d'ailleurs une carte qui vous
permet de suivre ces évolutions de voir
si les évolutions sont plus fortes dans
certaines communes moins fortes ou si
elles restent stable carte établie par
l'équipe du fil data autour de Stéphane
Saunier et en particulier en première
ligne Arthur bijouta qui sera avec nous
dans un instant
quelques jeux de projectiles je vous le
disais tout à l'heure dans la
manifestation parisienne
pour autant et ça c'est une c'est un
article de Christophe Cornavin qui est
responsable et qui suit et qui couvre
notamment la question de sécurité avec
Jean-Marc Leclerc et
au service société du Figaro
sur la méthode nunaise qui consiste à
maintenir à faire le à maintenir l'ordre
à la méthode pour maintenir l'ordre
pardon en France à Paris je vois que
Timothée délaime est avec un manifestant
va essayer de on va essayer de le
retrouver
Timothée je vous vois et apparemment
vous avez rencontré un premier manifeste
un premier manifestant
et bien je vous laisse la parole et je
vous laisse interroger
oui Vincent un premier manifestant qui
n'est pas venu tout seul ils sont venus
en famille en fait et vous le voyez ce
monsieur qui est kiné et qui est en qui
est libéral qui est venu avec son fils
de 13 ans bonjour monsieur pourquoi
êtes-vous venu aujourd'hui manifester
je suis venu aujourd'hui c'était plus
simple que ce soit le samedi déjà pour
la vie de famille mais on a activé
professionnel après d'un point de vue
idéologique
ouais je pense qu'il y a un ras-le-bol
un bol collectif
ouais voilà je suis à mon compte c'est
vrai que je suis mon propre patron je
passe à l'arrière mais
on demande toujours plus on voit que les
actionnaires bah eux ils se font plus
d'argent
ben voilà quoi alors à vous écouter
c'est pas tant sur cette réforme des
retraites précisément que vous êtes
venus mais c'est plus un ras-le-bol
général ouais ça rabole général alors
après sur la forme des retraites je suis
pas contre par rapport à moi parce que
bon moi je pense que ça va mais il y a
des gens ils peuvent pas ils peuvent pas
bosser plus il y a des métiers ils
peuvent pas c'est pas possible qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui qui vous énerve le
plus dans cette réforme vous avez vous
vous avez c'est l'âge de l'âge de départ
à la retraite qui vous qui vous embête
c'est le fait de pas pouvoir toucher une
retraite à taux plein question les
points de cristallisation pour vous
ouais c'est tout ça ouais ouais c'est
tout ça c'est des retraites qui sont qui
sont pas assez valorisés
puis comme je vous disais on peut pas on
peut pas partir il y a il y a des
métiers c'est pas possible de partir
aussi tard à la retraite et des vraiment
des métiers qui sont très difficiles je
pense pas en faire partie réellement je
le fais pas pour moi je le fais pour mes
enfants aussi moi je pense que ça va
mais
ouais on peut pas on peut pas toujours
demander aux gens de faire plus alors
que d'un autre côté
ça je sais pas total il paye pas les
impôts enfin je sais pas alors qu'ils
font des des ils font des bénéfices de
ouf comme on dit on peut pas toujours
demander aux gens de voilà de faire un
effort tout on doit faire un effort
et voilà quoi moi je demande
je demande juste est-ce que tout le
monde puisse vivre décemment avec un
revenu décent et puis bah ouais puis
partir à la retraite quand les gens qui
ont bosser toute leur vie les gens qui
ont bossé qu'on commençait très très tôt
ou des gens qui ont commencé très tard
ou des femmes qui ont dû garder les
enfants et c'est tout un ras-le-bol
c'est un peu général
en ce qui me concerne alors vous parliez
de vos enfants je me tourne précisément
vers votre fils bonjour vous avez 13 ans
c'est la première fois que vous
manifestez
oui je crois non quand j'étais petit je
me je me rappelle mon père m'avait
emmené à une manif aussi mais je me
rappelle pas très bien pourquoi parce
que j'étais petit quoi il y a d'autres
d'autres camarades peut-être certains de
vos amis ou bien dans votre salle de
classe qui qui viennent aussi mettre le
pavé aujourd'hui
il y a ma sœur
mais sinon non pas trop
non mais mes copains j'étais pas trop au
courant
alors pour vous la retraite évidemment
c'est dans c'est dans très longtemps
vous êtes encore bien jeune pourtant
vous avez tenu à venir ici aujourd'hui
pour quelle raison vous accompagnez vos
parents mais vous êtes vous aussi opposé
à cette réforme des retraites bah parce
que
parce que leur retraite c'est pas c'est
pas tout de suite non plus pour moi mais
bon après ça passe vite et puis aussi
pas trop envie de travailler super vieux
quoi enfin faut travailler mais
travailler je suis super vieux enfin
super vieux
enfin voilà enfin
voilà
Vincent pour ces manifestants qui sont
venus en famille avec donc et bien ce
père de famille son fils mais également
le reste de la famille qui se trouve un
petit peu plus devant au niveau du
cortège merci beaucoup Timothée vous
demanderez peut-être à notre jeune
interlocuteur à quel âge on commence à
être super vieux parce que là
effectivement c'est là où il peut y
avoir un débat en tous les cas sur le
report de l'âge de la retraite merci
beaucoup en tout cas Timothée pour ce
premier témoignage j'accueille plusieurs
personnes dans ce studio et dans ce live
d'abord un excellent Florent Mayenne
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS du Figaro
voyage et puis nos internautes Albert
Claudus Requiem For rodrim et qui sont
déjà en train de débattre de réagir bah
vous faites comme eux et également vous
nous dites un petit peu quel est votre
point de vue quels sont vos réactions
quels sont vos commentaires par rapport
à ces premières images et après cette
première manifestation Albert vous
disiez c'est très clairsemé par contre
et bien Requiem nous dit que c'est une
manifestation monstre dans le pays et
également un témoignage ça serait
intéressant d'ailleurs on va en discuter
avec Arthur bijouta dans une demi-heure
Claudius nouveau record de participation
dans le Nord je rappelle dans tous les
cas selon nos premières estimations plus
de 320
000 manifestants actuellement contre 260
000 à la même heure mardi dernier ce
sont les estimations du Figaro Albert
nous dit malgré tout la réforme sera
votée au parlement nous sommes en
démocratie la nos commandes pas et bien
c'est toute une question c'est une
question une très bonne question en tout
cas qui qui est soulevé par Albert on en
parlera sans doute avec Cyril Chabanier
de la CFTC tout à l'heure et puis on en
parlera également avec Véronique
reissoult de backbone consulting et
Arnaud Benedetti le polytologue bonjour
mon cher Florent maillet quel plaisir de
vous retrouver
et bien une première info elle est
tombée en milieu de matinée
c'est la pagaille en ce moment à Orly
c'est une pagaille pourquoi parce qu'il
y a grève et une greffe qui n'était pas
prévue
c'est une grève surprise effectivement
et si elle perdit Clarine ne commande
pas il y a certaines catégories peuvent
commander la poste de la grève surprise
a été déclenchée et effectivement ça
n'était pas prévu puisqu'il n'y avait
pas d'appeler spécifique à la grève à
Orly par les contrôleurs les contrôleurs
du ciel qu'est-ce qui se passe ce ne
sont pas concernés d'ailleurs par la
réforme de la retraite
50% des vols la moitié des vols annulés
ce samedi c'est pas une très bonne
nouvelle pourquoi parce qu'il ne se
rappelle échapper qu'aujourd'hui c'est
le démarrage des vacances dans la zone B
c'est également la deuxième zone de la
deuxième semaine par jour de vacances de
la zone A et c'est un jour de départ
Orly c'est l'aéroport qui dessert
notamment les destinations plutôt
touristique du sud de l'Europe et les
destinations plutôt soleil ça veut dire
que il risque d'y avoir des centaines
des milliers de personnes je pense qui
seront
en vacances ou en week-end alors ça
c'est le premier impact qu'il y a pour
c'est le début des vacances donc vous le
lisiez pour la zone B milieu des
vacances pour la zone A la zone C la
zone de Paris elle commencera la semaine
prochaine est-ce que d'autres est-ce que
hormis cette grève à Orly les mouvements
en général impactent et impacter les
départs en vacances alors assez peu pour
le moment et c'est une surprise parce
que justement il y a un relatif
consensus jusqu'à présent pour ne pas
s'aligner en quelque sorte le
les Français qui qui partent en vacances
l'intérêt des syndicats pour le moment
de l'intersyndicat c'est de fédérer le
maximum de français et du coup cette
grève elle est surprise parce qu'on
s'attendait pas notamment dans l'avion
puisqu'on a un problème de micro on fait
ça en live on va parler comme ça
donc l'intérêt la terre syndical c'était
évidemment de pas empêcher les gens de
partir en vacances pourquoi pour ne pas
les braquer contre le mouvement donc
jusqu'à présent la SNCF a épargné les
Français qui partaient en vacances
notamment ces dernières ces dernières
semaines et pour ce quatrième jour le
consensus était plutôt celui-ci
qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour les
prochaines semaines a priori il n'y a
pas d'autre appel à la grève et à
empêcher les gens à partir en vacances
la mobilisation elle est plutôt prévue à
partir du mardi 7 mars
on va revenir on reprend le micro c'est
comme ça on est en live
on va on va essayer de corriger ça bien
sûr
la la mobilisation donc est l'impact est
prévu le 7 mars parce qu'il y a une
menace de blocage du pays on demandera
tout à l'heure à Chabanier en quoi ça
consiste
et également
dans un de vos papiers quand même vous
nous dites que
c'était pas en vacances angoissent une
partie des Français et que certains
pourraient renoncer à partir en vacances
est-ce que ça a été vraiment le cas
alors il y a une angoisse
latente des Français
angoisse dû à plusieurs phénomènes on va
pas tous les énumérer mais la
conjoncture sociale évidemment toutes
les préoccupations environnementales
évidemment la situation économique c'est
pas du tout ce qu'on constate les gens
qui ont les moyens globalement vont
plutôt avoir tendance à partir ça va
leur coûter plus cher voire beaucoup
plus cher mais les gens qui peuvent va
vous permettre continuer à partir et du
coup on a des espèces de chiffres en
trompe l'oeil qui vont plutôt traduire
des paniers moyens en hausse qui
reposent essentiellement sur l'inflation
mais moins de gens qui partent en volume
en revanche beaucoup de Français vont
devoir effectivement et de plus en plus
se priver de partir alors c'est ça qui
est très intéressant dans ce que vous
dites et
assez inédit
alors inédit j'ai pas assez d'ancienneté
je n'ai pas vécu les grandes périodes
d'inflation pour vous le dire ce qui est
assez inédit c'est le inédit depuis un
certain nombre d'années qu'il y a autant
de Français qui justement renoncent à
partir en vacances à cause justement
de ces situations là et de l'inflation
qui est en train d'exploser alors on
pourrait vous rejoindre mais je vais
essayer d'affiner un petit peu ce que
vous dites oui c'est relativement ce qui
est plutôt inédit c'est que les gens ont
envie de partir j'ai envie de dire à
tout prix sans mauvais jeu de mots à
tout prix c'est au prix de certaines
concessions on peut imaginer par exemple
que les gens qui vont au ski qui sont
des vacances plutôt onéreuses c'est pas
moins de 500 euros par adulte au bas mot
c'est plutôt des gens qui vont chercher
à partir
à des moments où les prix sont moins
chers je pense notamment à la location
qui est le premier budget location de
d'hébergement et peut-être des gens
également qui vont beaucoup moins aller
au restaurant et qui renoncent aussi et
ça c'est nouveau effectivement à des
dépenses alimentaires puisque vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui l'alimentaire c'est une
des catégories les plus inf pour
préserver sauvegarder leurs vacances et
ça répond à un besoin très fort d'une
société de loisirs dans laquelle on vit
mais aussi un besoin un besoin et un
désir de partir depuis le covid alors
c'est très intéressant que vous
soulignez ce point parce que justement
tout à l'heure à l'instant on entendait
Timothée donc on va retrouver d'un
instant tal à l'autre
plus exactement dans quelques minutes
qui nous qui interrogeait se manifestant
qui disait je veux vivre
de manière décente avec un travail
décent et un salaire descend et
effectivement ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'à travers cette thématique de
voyage où on est semble-t-il assez loin
des problématiques sociales et bien on
les touche du doigt en réalité
complètement puisqu'on ça répond à une
société de loisirs dans laquelle on vit
aujourd'hui le sociologue Jean Viard
doit être des chiffres assez édifiants
sur le nombre d'or non travaillées qu'on
passe désormais et je pense que de
manière un peu sous-jacente les Français
qui vous parlent de leurs droits à vivre
les loisirs en font partie complètement
parce qu'on vit aujourd'hui complètement
dans une société de loisirs on veut
partir en week-end on veut partir en
vacances et puis on est frappé on est
concerné par cette inflation généralisée
aujourd'hui qui touche à peu près tous
les postes de dépenses qui s'agissent du
carburant pour le véhicule qui s'agisse
du train avec la SNCF qui a re OCC
tarifs en moyenne de 5 % à la mi-janvier
et avec des billets d'avion et ça on le
sait depuis la depuis quelques jours qui
ont augmenté en moyenne de 20,6% l'année
dernière donc on sait maintenant on
arrive à peu près à quantifier
l'inflation sur les billets d'avion
alors sur les billets d'avion peut-être
une question avant d'aller place de
boulevard Voltaire retrouvé Timothée
délène 50% lisait tout à l'heure de vol
annulés à Orly à cause d'une grève
inopinée des contrôleurs aériens est-ce
que les personnes qui ont leur vu leur
vol annulés vont pouvoir en prendre un
autre ou bien est-ce que tout le moins
elles pourront être remboursées alors il
y a deux obligations il y a deux
obligations elles ont le droit d'être
rem oui sous sept jours la compagnie
aérienne doit la rembourser
effectivement la totalité du prix du
billet la variante c'est que le jour du
départ la compagnie aérienne peut leur
proposer le même trajet dans les mêmes
dans des conditions équivalentes le seul
problème c'est quand vous avez la moitié
des vols annulés vous imaginez bien vous
allez pas pouvoir reporter la totalité
du trafic vers d'autres avions qui par
définition vont pas pouvoir décoller
dans leur totalité donc la meilleure
solution c'est de se faire rembourser
c'est de se faire rembourser la mauvaise
nouvelle en revanche et qu'il y aura pas
de droit à compensation puisque cette
annulation n'est pas du fait de la
compagnie aérienne mais de la grève des
des contrôleurs je vais pas dire des
tisses et des contrôleurs voilà des
contrôleurs aériens donc vous serez
remboursé des billets mais vous n'aurez
pas droit à une compensation alors
est-ce que vous avez été justement
affecté peut-être par cette cette grève
est-ce que vous avez eu des témoignages
autour de vous vous nous le dites vous
le dites en direct sur le chat du Figaro
vous continuez de nous suivre sur
Youtube on est content de vous retrouver
également sur place je vous propose
justement d'aller à Paris
boulevard Voltaire retrouvez Timothée
délai je sais même pas si vous êtes
boulevard Voltaire mais ça ressemble à
un boulevard et comme ça doit passer par
le boulevard Voltaire j'en ai déduit que
c'était ça mais vous allez me le
confirmer Timothée
[Musique]
et ben justement non justement pas
Vincent je vous confirme le passe là
puisque nous sommes en fait au niveau du
boulevard du Temple et c'est peut-être
l'un des premiers enseignements de la
journée c'est que à l'image de la toute
première journée de mobilisation le 19
janvier dernier et bien un deuxième
itinéraire a été ouvert aujourd'hui pour
faire face à la forte influence juste
ici vous le voyez c'est le boulevard du
Temple qui part de cette place de la
République avec ici même et bien le
cortège de l'USA vous le reconnaissez
avec ces ballons bleus et c'est nombreux
drapeau un petit peu devant vous avez et
bien
FSU et puis la CFDT qui va se trouver
encore des dizaines de mètres devant
vous les voyez ici la manifestants avec
des pancartes les pancars j'allais dire
habituels
voilà augmenter les salaires pas les
retraites voilà ce genre de ce genre de
de slogan que nous avons maintenant
l'habitude de croiser dans ces
manifestations là nous nous trouvons au
niveau de la rue Jean-Pierre Timbaud on
va s'avancer un petit peu pour vous
montrer et bien le deuxième cortège ou
en tous les cas le cortège principal
celui qui était initialement prévu et
que vous voyez probablement au bout de
la rue voilà le boulevard Voltaire qui
se trouve juste là-bas avec ce cortège
principal que nous allons maintenant
rejoindre voilà donc c'est vrai qu'on
vous disait tout à l'heure qu'il y avait
pas beaucoup de monde au niveau de la
place de la République mais
maintenant qu'on s'approche dans le
cortège on constate qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup plus de monde
difficile à dire pour l'instant combien
il y a de personnes exactement on sait
qu'au niveau du ministère de l'intérieur
on parle de 90 à 120 000 personnes dans
les rues de la capitale aujourd'hui
évidemment on n'est pas en mesure de de
confirmer ces chiffres mais en tous les
cas c'est vrai qu'il y a quand même une
assez forte influence aujourd'hui
difficile de dire qu'il y a peu de monde
nous dit Kris Kross en tous les cas ce
qui est vrai c'est que tous les signaux
indiquent un surcroît de mobilisation ce
samedi d'abord les estimations du Figaro
un 321000 à 14h30 contre 260000 à la
même heure mardi dernier les prévisions
également des renseignements
territoriaux qui prévoyaient également
un regain de mobilisation aujourd'hui et
puis une mobilisation en tous les cas
signalée importante en région ou d'où
sont partis un certain nombre de cortège
alors justement au regard de cette
situation cher Florent à l'heure où on
se parle est-ce que la situation sur les
routes dans les gares et plus occupés ou
nombre d'habitudes et plus occupé que
l'an dernier à la même époque pas de
points vigilance de vigilance
particulier pardon sofa une zone sur une
zone pardon Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
pourquoi et bien parce que c'est les
stations
les stations des Alpes et du Massif
Central puisqu'effectivement c'est
logique pourquoi parce qu'on regarde en
ce moment en direct sur les télésièges
parce que cette année encore et bien les
stations de ski rencontrent un grand
grand succès auprès des Français les
polémiques sur l'absence de neige en
début de saison sur la neige de culture
sur le prix des vacances au ski qui sont
effectivement en inflation et bien n'ont
pas suffi à décourager les gens d'aller
en montagne d'abord puisque la plupart
des gens avaient réservé au moment où il
y avait les problèmes d'enneigement
montagne mais ces réservations ont été
conservées et aujourd'hui et bien elle
s'effectue ce qui fait qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui en Auvergne Rhône-Alpes on
est en rouge pour les départs et en
orange jaune pour les retours est-ce que
les remontées mécaniques puisque on en
parle et c'était évoqué dans vos
articles sont touchés par les grèves
les remontées mécaniques à ma
connaissance en tout cas ne seront
touchés si elles sont touchées par des
graines ne le seront qu’épisodiquement
il y a effectivement un appel à la grève
illimitée qui inquiétait beaucoup les
gestionnaires de stations les syndicats
de même on fait valeur que ce préavis
était posé pour pouvoir manifester dans
les conditions qui leur semblaient
pertinentes par rapport à leur
revendication pour leurs droits dont
celui à la retraite à ce jour il y a
plutôt un consensus pour dire voilà le
modèle économique des stations reste
quand même relativement fragile après
deux années sans remonter mécanique
hormis l'an dernier évidemment donc pour
le moment plutôt épargné et puis en ce
moment quand on parle de ski on voit
évidemment la France briller en
mondovision puisque vous savez que c'est
les championnats du monde dans les trois
vallées effectivement et on peut les
suivre bien sûr en direct sur la page
sport du Figaro qui retransmet également
direct en dessous de ce player donc il
faut à la fois mettre ce live sur votre
téléphone et regarder les infos
justement sur le match Irlande - France
sur
votre sur votre sur votre ordinateur
puisqu'il vient de démarrer et également
c'est en live et retransmis pour le sur
le Figaro on signale à l'instant que
également la mobilisation et c'est
encore une prévision du fil data on va y
revenir
en haut dans un certain nombre de
grandes villes
françaises notamment
en tous les cas c'est une question qui
qui est posée 30
000 manifestants aujourd'hui ont
manifesté à Toulouse par exemple contre
000 mardi dernier alors effectivement
est-ce que c'est un effet d'optique
est-ce que c'est pas à ça qu'on
s'attendait en disant que mardi dernier
c'était une mobilisation moins forte
avant la mobilisation du week-end on
posera toutes ces questions là bien
entendu à nos différents interlocuteurs
qui vont se succéder après Florent
maillet avec qui on a toujours le
plaisir d'être il y a un début de
cortège également boulevard Beaumarchais
à Paris là encore c'est un autre un
autre itinéraire qui est pris donc c'est
pas simplement le boulevard Voltaire pas
seulement
boulevard du Temple comme le signalé
tout à l'heure Timothée délai mais
également donc boulevard Beaumarchais
qui sont un certain nombre de boulevards
qui part de la place de la République et
pour aller à Nation également tête de
cortège il y a des gilets jaunes et des
Black Blocs c'est ce que n'indique aussi
certains gens issues Figaro qui sont sur
place est-ce que le phénomène des
inflations dont on parlait d'inflation
tout à l'heure qui impactait quand même
grandement la consommation et en
particulier la consommation en termes de
voyage de loisirs des des Français
touchent et concerne un secteur qui a vu
quand même les prix sacrément grimpés
ces dernières années ces dernières
décennies c'est celui des remontées
mécaniques justement
alors les remontées mécaniques le sujet
est assez vaste puisque derrière la
question c'est qu'à l'avenir pour le
tourisme de montagne par rapport à votre
question sur l'économie des remontées
mécaniques elle reste fragile
cette année il y a des augmentations qui
sont relativement sensibles en moyenne
on parle de 7 % d'augmentation du prix
des forfaits qui financent en partie les
remontées mécaniques pas seulement
également notamment le plus gros poste
c'est les salaires du personnel des
remontées mécaniques donc pour le moment
ils arrivent à compenser entre
guillemets et à réaliser une année
plutôt plutôt correcte avec cette hausse
des prix qui absorbe des prix de
l'énergie qui étaient en
dans une spirale qu'on peut qualifier
d'infernal parce qu'il y a des stations
qui se retrouvaient dans des situations
complètement impossibles et sujet n'est
pas encore résolu le point central pour
ces prochains mois ce sera les prix de
l'énergie et quelle visibilité vont
avoir là-dessus pour l'activité du ski
en général qui suppose d'avoir ces
remontées mécaniques année après année
le débat revient année après année on
voit quand même un attachement des
Français pour la montagne qui non
seulement ne se dément pas mais qui en
plus semble s'accroître c'est un
phénomène qui est probablement
probablement lié au covid la montagne
est associée à tout un tas de vertus
l'air pur etc et on voit de plus en plus
les citadins notamment fréquenter les
massifs en toute saison alors fréquenter
les massifs c'est une chose dépenser de
l'argent dans les massifs en est une
autre hormis le ski qui pèse pour près
de 90% des revenus dans les stations
dans les communes qui
qui détiennent ces stations et bien il
n'y a pas encore de moteur économique
qui puisse alimenter ce secteur du
tourisme en cas de saison c'est
l'objectif d'un des plans qui est sur la
table qui s'appelle le plan montagne qui
est en discussion actuellement
est-ce que malgré cette tendance et
cette volonté effectivement des Français
d'aller de plus en plus à la montagne
est-ce que de façon plus générale le
secteur du tourisme qui est quand même
des branches du voyage en France
ne veut pas être ne va pas être la
victime de des mouvements en tout cas du
combo du duo grève inflation c'est
exactement ce qui était attendu et c'est
exactement ce qui pour le moment ne se
produit pas encore d'abord c'est un
secteur qui a été massivement aidé pour
le gouvernement et qui est donc
aujourd'hui même s'il y a d'immenses
problèmes de recrutement globalement en
ordre de marche ensuite c'est toujours
le la problématique à laquelle les mêmes
les professionnels ne savent pas
répondre on attend
systématiquement à ce que la prochaine
fois les Français ne partent pas or
vacances après vacances pont après pont
les gens continuent de partir donc
est-ce que c'est le bas de laine qui est
plus profond que ce qu'on pensait c'est
possible est-ce que il y a des
sacrifices et des arbitrages qui se
réaliser c'est encore plus probable donc
il y a ce désir en disait tout de suite
on a pas encore d'indications sur ça on
n'a pas on n'a pas de certitude alors là
le chiffre le plus intéressant que j'ai
relevé ces derniers jours c'est c'est
l'Observatoire des vacances des Français
qui est réalisé par entreprise des
voyages qui réunit l'ensemble des tours
opérateurs donc là c'est quand vous
partez généralement à l'étranger que
nous disent baromètre qui porte sur la
période du 4 février au 6 mars et bien
le nombre de Français qui partent en
vacances d'hiver en passant par un
opérateur de voyage progresse de 13% par
rapport à l'an dernier c'est encore moi
qu'en 2019 mais voilà plus de gens
sollicitent des agences de voyage pour
partir à l'étranger puisqu'on note la
reprise des longs courriers des longs
courriers c'est en général vers d'autres
continents notamment l'Asie qui rep très
fort et un panier moyen tenez vous bien
qui est en hausse de 44% par rapport à
2019 22% par rapport à l'an dernier
pourquoi car ce qui est intéressant avec
ce que vous dites c'est enfin oui c'est
la question mais comme vous le faites
vous avez posé admirablement la question
je vous laisse non moins admirablement
répondre et bien c'est ce qu'on vous
disait tout à l'heure quand je répondais
à votre question préliminaire les gens
dépensent beaucoup plus pour partir
quitte également à partir plus longtemps
pour avoir le sentiment d'amortir
notamment un prix du billet qui lui
aussi est en inflation et est-ce que il
y a aussi un phénomène qui est lié aux
années covid et d'argent qu'on n'a pas
pu dépenser parce que qu'on n'a pas
dépensé parce que justement on a dû
renoncer à certains voyages vous allez
m'obliger à faire un anglicisme ou
parler de Revenge travel le tourisme de
revanche en bon français oui évidemment
alors c'est ce que tout le monde appelle
aujourd'hui tourisme de revanche ça fait
trois ans maintenant qu'on dit tourisme
de revanche tourisme de revanche donc
encore une fois quand on interroge les
Français c'est compliqué le bas de laine
a-t-il un fond en tout cas il semble pas
atteint chez les gens qui encore une
fois on les moyens l'inflation entre
temps et de retour en France on n'avait
pas ça depuis 30 40 ans et les gens
continuent encore une fois à consacrer
des dépenses aux loisirs 15 heures du 17
sur le site du Figaro sur Figaro Live
vous suivez en direct avec nous la
mobilisation contre la réforme de
retraite la manifestation parisienne on
fait un point justement sur les
conséquences que ça peut avoir et sur ce
qui le contexte autour de cette
manifestation bien sûr il y a deux zones
qui sont en vacances la zone A et la
zone B qui commence d'ailleurs cette
vacance aujourd'hui et il y a eu deux
événements donc qui ont marqué une grève
surprise des contrôleurs à Orly est-ce
qu'elle est légale c'est ce que nous
demande s'impervira
on s'organise pour prendre son vol et
hop surprise vous êtes bloqué
la légalité je sais pas si vous pouvez
répondre à cette question en tous les
cas c'est une question qui qui se pose
et qui revient souvent c'est une
question très légitime on va pas
raconter de bêtises à votre internaute
en revanche on a l'habitude dans la
rubrique touriste de répondre aux
questions des internautes donc je prends
sa question et je lui promets une
réponse dans la semaine voilà et Requiem
nous dit seul une minorité va au ski
c'est juste tout le défi c'est
d'expliquer ce qu'on entend parmi
notoriété on attend alors il y a des
chiffres qui sont avancés 45% des
Français tir au ski alors dans une
logique extensive ici on considère les
gens qui peuvent aller à la neige une
fois pourquoi pas la réalité c'est qu'il
y a beaucoup moins de Français qui
skient effectivement des Français qui
partent en vacances au ski serait de
l'ordre de 2 à 4 millions suivant les
années complété par deux à trois
millions d’étrangers voilà
une population de 60 plus de 60 millions
on s'effectivement ça reste minorité
alors ça reste minoritaire effectivement
et c'est oublier également les gens qui
partent en week-end au ski donc ils
partent pas en vacances de manière
continue et qui pose des jours
spécifiques pour aller pour aller au ski
et là on va parler soit des gens qui
habitent à proximité d'une station et je
rappelle qu'en France il y a six massifs
dans la Corse où on peut skier faut pas
oublier nos amis nos amis corses quand
vous habitez à Toulouse quand vous
habitez à Bordeaux vous pouvez tout à
fait aller à la journée au ski quand
vous habitez à Clermont-Ferrand aussi à
Strasbourg à Mulhouse tout ça c'est
possible à la journée donc beaucoup de
gens
alors on va on va se faire réprimander
sur les réseaux sociaux mais
malheureusement non puisque aujourd'hui
il y a des vols directs en tout cas en
saison qui permettent de d'atterrir par
exemple à Lourdes si vous voulez aller
dans les Pyrénées et de monter ensuite
pouvoir skier alors à la journée
peut-être pas mais en tout cas pour le
pour le weekend
vous atterrissez à Lourdes ou à Pau dans
ces cas là vous pouvez vous avez le
choix entre le Béarn ou la Bigorre et
dans les deux cas c'est magnifique
justement à Toulouse vous en parliez
tout à l'heure et bien la manifestation
il y avait plus de manifestants 30 000
aujourd'hui contre 24
visiblement quelques tensions dans le
cortège parisien c'est ce que nous
montre c'est images filmées par nos
confrères d'associés de presse de plus
en plus quelques gilets jaunes également
que l'on voit dans les dans ces dans ces
manifestations
ça part en manif sauvage nous dit
d'ailleurs un des
dans la liste sur sur place
rue de Charonne notamment célèbre rue de
Charonne autour de la place de la
Bastille
il y a un certain nombre d’ailleurs de
[Musique]
réactions à l'étranger autour de la de
ces manifestations
je remercie Philippe 2008 qui nous donne
la la
une du final
parents de sa retraite à 62 ans les
Français ont absolument raison
d'irré en tous les cas le célèbre
quotidien anglo-saxon libéral et
selon le même site 2008
le quotidien allemand taxe iTunes dit
retraite non les Français n'exagère pas
et ben
justement c'est une question
qui nous est
qui est posé vous voyez quelques
tensions en ce moment dans le cortège
parisien avec des jeux de gaz
lacrymogène
c'est une ambiance qui rappelle
effectivement le combo backbloc
gilet jaune on va continuer à suivre et
avoir les les réactions il y a plusieurs
cortèges c'est ce qu'on a appris depuis
le début de la manifestation plusieurs
cortèges avec un cortège principal qui
est boulevard Voltaire et à cortège bis
qui a été lancé cette fois-ci boulevard
du Temple et un autre cortège également
boulevard boulevard Beaumarchais et puis
d'après les infos de nos confrères qui
sont sur place du Figaro quelques
cortège cheval en tout cas manif sauvage
cette fois-ci rue de Charonne c'est dans
ce quartier là mais ce n'était pas
effectivement ce qui était prévu et on
voit ces personnes qui étaient sur place
sortie à des foulards et des
se masquer le visage piqué par les gaz
lacrymogène quand vous être tirés devant
cette
[Musique]
alors quand des manifestants qui sont
sur place on essaiera dans un savoir un
petit peu plus avec les infos qui nous
parviennent et je remercie Claudius qui
est en train de nous donner
le résultat en direct du score entre la
France et l'Irlande avec cette même
nouvelle 3-0 pour la France et bien on
espère que ça va continuer comme ça pour
les Bleus précisément avec ce genre
d'image avec ce genre de et ce genre
d'événement il y a une question qui
vient naturellement à l'esprit et on
sait que c'est une spécialité que dont
nous affûle les pays étrangers les
grèves les manifestations est-ce que
Paris bâtit de ce genre de mouvement en
termes de tourisme
les chiffres t'ont plutôt à montrer une
forme de retour à la normale avec
notamment le retour de la clientèle
anglo-saxonne et on pense notamment aux
Américains qui sont des gros gros
pourvoyeur de cote de touristes et
peut-être bientôt les touristes chinois
sachant qu'en ce moment ils sont encore
à ce sujet tiens à un certain nombre de
contrôle pour ce qui est du visitera
étranger
Paris à vocation à rester une place
mondiale ça veut pas dire pour autant
que les gens apprécient leur expérience
à Paris ce qui peut se passer dans les
rues la saleté évoquée l'insécurité qui
augmente l'insécurité augmente ne vous
rappelez c'est une polémique de longue
date vous rappeler ce fameux journal
américain qui avait parlé de zones de
conflit ou zone de guerre en région
parisienne ça n'a jamais vraiment
découragé les touristes notamment
américains puisque là on parlait d'un
média américain même médias américains
aujourd'hui a même publié un ranking des
un classement pardon des villes
américaines les plus dangereuses donc
vous voyez dans n'importe quel pays
aujourd'hui vous pouvez être
soumis à ce genre de à ce genre de
danger donc les clientèles étrangères
sont plutôt de retour et les clientèle
françaises dans les recherches en tout
cas de vol de billets Paris ressort
régulièrement en tête et j'ai envie de
vous dire comme avant le covid est-ce
que
regarde des chiffres que vous vous
donniez justement sur les départs en
vacances qui est un mouvement en tous
les cas qui
ne recule pas pour l'instant est-ce
qu'on peut s'attendre justement
puisqu'il y a d'autres manifestations
qui sont prévues
notamment une le 16 février donc
cette semaine je dis est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à un recul des mobilisations
du fait les vacances à cause des
vacances il faudrait refaire
l'historique et chaque mouvement social
à sa à sa particularité ce qui est sûr
c'est que le mouvement quand on vous
écoute on voit les chiffres qui sont
visiblement important pour les pour les
manifestations encore une fois les gens
ont l'air de mobiliser on a l'impression
d'avoir deux France un petit peu la
France dite de loisirs et il faut pas
forcément les opposer et la France qui
manifeste et visiblement en tout cas
pour le moment ça se passe en tout cas
pas trop mal alors on va avoir
d'ailleurs dans un instant Timothée
délai qui est sur place
une question peut-être encore
alors j'arrête de parler de donner le
score pour la France - Islande parce que
justement l'Irlandais ont mis un essai
et donc Claudius me reproche de porter
la poisse donc on va s'arrêter là on va
plus en parler on va s'intéresser donc
aux manifestations images donc des
tensions là ici à Paris on a d'autres
images qui nous parviennent ou ça a
l'air beaucoup plus calme dans là où ça
se là où ça se passe on va retrouver
dans un instant Timothée d'Hélène
qui est en train effectivement de
changer encore de cortège je le vois
avec on le voit vous voyez juste au
dessus de nous avec Julien Leclerc que
vous ne voyez pas c'est lui qui filme
allez le débat donc continue sur le chat
concernant le match mais nous on est ici
en studio en direct pour parler et
couvrir ces manifestations est-ce que le
spectre d'une grève à répétition fait
peur au secteur
évidemment c'est un secteur qui n'aime
pas les aléas comme beaucoup de secteurs
le problème des grèves à répétition
c'est que ça peut empêcher les gens par
exemple de réserver des billets de train
ou d'avion quand bien même les
conditions de remboursement sont
relativement claires et relativement
fluides si jamais agréable de devoir
reporter son voyage en revanche c'est en
assiste dans ce cas-là systématiquement
un phénomène ça report sur la route
c'est-à-dire que les gens ils préfèrent
prendre leur voiture en se disant je
passerai peut-être 10 heures dans les
embouteillages mais au moins je suis sûr
d'arriver à bon port donc c'est ce qu'on
ce à quoi on assiste pardon en général
dans ces cas de figure alors apparemment
là pour l'instant ils ont ceux qui ont
fait ce choix ont eu plutôt raison parce
que Army vous nous disiez la région
Rhône-Alpes et Auvergne l'état des
trafic pour l'instant fluide c'est
relativement bien réparti sur le
territoire ce qu'on a noté pour ses
vacances alors évidemment c'est les
vacances d'hiver donc c'est un peu le le
Zénith pour les pour les vacances pour
les vacances à la montagne ce ne sont
pas les seules zones vers lesquelles se
déplacent les Français cet hiver on peut
citer la Bretagne toujours populaire les
littoraux en général avec notamment la
Côte d'Azur comme Paris qui fait son
grand retour dans les tops des
préférences des Français le seul secteur
qui sont un petit peu en recul c'est la
campagne voilà campagne qui avait gagné
beaucoup de points de popularité juste
après le covid est plutôt en recul et au
profit des blockbusters touristiques
j'ai envie de vous dire les littoraux
les régions forte appréciées comme la
Bretagne et évidemment puisqu'on est en
hiver les stations sportives et c'est là
aussi augmente beaucoup l'immobilier ça
sera peut-être une autre question qu'on
abordera ensemble un grand merci Florent
d'avoir interrompu votre repos bien
mérité du samedi pour venir dans les
studio du Figaro nous donner un petit
peu les tendances et nous expliquer ces
liens entre justement deux phénomènes
sociologiques quand même importants qui
sont les grèves et les vacances et puis
très intéressant de vous avez entendu
aussi parler de cette de cette
de cette attachement aux Français
justement cette société des loisirs
phénomène sociologique qui est
extrêmement
analysé qui est extrêmement abordé
souvent abordé pardon et analyser mais
c'est toujours intéressant d'avoir vous
reviendrez dans le studio et on fera les
plans last minute.com promis et on prend
plaisir aux internautes du Figaro en
attendant le Figaro voyage ce sont les
meilleures infos les meilleurs plans et
les meilleurs conseils vous voyez ces
images de tension pendant ce temps-là
place
dans Paris alors c'est sur un des trois
celui-là des boulevards qui sont aux
alentours de la place de la République
une tension une tension qui était
crainte par le par le gouvernement on
voit et on va demander ce sera vraiment
de nous montrer d'autres images celles
que nous avons de nos confrères de l'AFP
où on voit des images beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus
calme en tout cas de cortège il n'images
aérienne vous les voyez
qui nous parviennent également donc euh
deux endroits deux ambiances toutes les
deux autour de Paris je pense pas que ce
soit autour de l'Assemblée nationale
l'autre l'autre cortège mais que c'est
bien à Paris les deux les deux sont à
Paris
actuellement des charges et des jeux de
projectiles c'est ce que nous signale en
ce moment nos journalistes du Figaro sur
place on va essayer de retrouver
Timothée délai Timothée ce que vous
m'entendez comment ça se passe autour de
vous
très bien malgré le grand bruit que
qu'il y a ici vous le voyez ici une sono
celle du syndicat SUD solidaire avec des
manifestants et bien qui mettent
l'ambiance et qui scandent leur slogan
haut et fort ce que je peux vous dire
alors là Vincent nous sommes avec Julien
déplacé sur le cortège principal celui
du boulevard Voltaire l'itinéraire qui
était prévu au début de cette
manifestation et vous le voyez ici
beaucoup de monde je vous cache pas
qu'on a pas le piétiner avant d'arriver
on essaye en fait de remonter le cortège
avec avec Julien mais c'est vrai qu'il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de monde et donc
voilà ça qui était pas mal une grosse
ambiance une grosse ambiance ici une
grosse influence je vous entends parler
des tensions Vincent nous nous n'avons
pas constaté avec Julien c'est vrai que
il semble qu'il y ait des tensions qui
étaient éclaté au niveau du début du
cortège on est en train de remonter le
cortège donc on va aller vérifier cela
ici en tous les cas pour l'instant pas
de tension manifestation ça me coûte
assez classique on a vu tout à l'heure
un feu de Bengale c'est pour ça que vous
voyez d'ailleurs peut-être derrière moi
une grande fumée rassurez-vous il ne
s'agit pas de de gaz lacrymogène pas de
tension en tous les cas à ce niveau là
de la manifestation c'est voilà un feu
de Bengale rouge qui est qui a été
allumé par par des manifestants et ce
qui est frappant c'est qu'il y a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de banderoles
et vous le voyez ici et des banderoles
qui
ne touche pas simplement à cette
question des retraites et c'est vrai que
c'est ce que nous disent beaucoup de
manifestants que l'on interroge dans ce
dans ce cortège c'est vrai que cet âge
de départ à la retraite c'est vraiment
ce qui cristallise l'erreur d'éducation
et vous le voyez par exemple ici des
banderoles qui voilà ça parle de de
lycée sur les fermetures de lycée sur
les conditions de des enseignants voilà
c'est vrai que on sent qu'il y a une en
fait il y a une cristallisation de des
tensions autour d'un cercle de
nombreuses revendications sociales ce
qui explique peut-être en tout cas la
porte d'influence qu'il y a dans les
rues de Paris aujourd'hui sur ce
boulevard Voltaire alors que je vous le
rappelle un deuxième cortège a été mis
en place au niveau du boulevard du temps
du coup Timothée merci pour ce point sur
l'ambiance c'est effectivement
intéressant d'avoir votre témoignage
parce que effectivement on reçoit un
certain d'image et d'avoir les
sous-titres nous permet d'avoir une
meilleure compréhension du phénomène ce
qui nous va nous permettre également
d'avoir une meilleure compréhension du
phénomène c'est d'avoir un point sur les
chiffres savoir un point sur les
tendances et c'est l'excellent travail
qui est fait par le fil data et
notamment Arthur bijouta qui en est un
des journalistes l'un des plus récents
mais la valeur on vient d'apprendre avec
lui n'attend pas le nombre des années
alors
on va faire un point sur la mobilisation
il y a quand même un certain nombre de
chiffres qui nous parviennent que vous
avez donné on va les donner mais d'abord
peut-être on va rappeler Arthur les
enjeux
Laurent Berger
qui est un petit peu l'homme de la
journée
A10 ce matin dépasser le million de
manifestants ce serait un beau succès
Laurent Berger a raison Laurent Berger
voit très bien son intérêt et son sa
manière de mener le combat contre cette
réforme des retraites effectivement
après la baisse légère mais quand même
assez importante de du mardi 7 février
où il n'y avait que je le rappelle 757
000 manifestants selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur contre 1,27 millions une
dizaine de jours la semaine précédente
et 1,12 millions pour la première
mobilisation donc Laurent Berger sait
qu'une seconde baisse consécutive une
seconde journée consécutive avec moins
de monde dans la rue ne signerait
peut-être pas l'arrêt de mort de ce
mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites mais en tout cas l'impacterait
fortement donc Laurent Berger se dit si
on fait un million là les mobilisations
repartent on redonne une dynamique à
notre à notre unité syndicale à notre
mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites quand on parle d'un million 5
millions sur toute la France c'est un
million sur toute la France et je je
pense que Laurent Berger connaît les
chiffres syndicaux mais quand ils
parlent du million il parle d'un million
selon le comptage des autorités alors
selon pour l'instant la
les informations en tous les cas les
chiffres qui sur qui circulent les
projections
étaient plutôt attendues par les
autorités alors on verra si justement ce
chiffre et dépassé notamment grâce aux
excellentes informations qui se trouvent
sur le le
pardon le live texte du Figaro liftex
qui se trouve un petit peu en dessous de
ce splendeur je vous donne des
informations donc là effectivement les
informations plutôt d'ordre de maintien
de l'ordre de la sécurité les forces de
l'ordre qui interviennent au niveau de
la rue de Sharon c'est ce qu'on se
disait tout à l'heure avec les
informations qui nous parvenaient d'un
certain nombre de journalistes qui
étaient sur place vous voyez toutes les
images que l'on peut avoir des un flux
qui nous parviennent ainsi que celle de
nos envahies spéciaux Timothée délai et
Julien Leclerc
un premier une première estimation donc
tout à l'heure à 14h30 un peu plus de
300000 manifestants c'est ça on vient
d'actualiser d'ailleurs j'ai les
derniers chiffres avant de descendre en
studio on a aujourd'hui 372
000 manifestants selon les autorités
contre 316 000 mardi 7 ça alors on se
parle alors on se parle pour les villes
où la préfecture de police ou les
autorités les renseignements généraux
ont donné des chiffres donc on prend les
mêmes villes le mardi 7 les villes
aujourd'hui et on compare et aujourd'hui
on a 372 000 manifestants contre 316 000
dans ces mêmes localités combien de
localités vous comptabilisez aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de petits rassemblements
donc on sera autour je pense entre 260
et 280
280 rassemblements un peu plus que les
205 240 annoncés par les syndicats un
petit peu plus que les 240 annoncés par
les syndicats et nous là pour l'instant
je pense qu'on a bien entre 100 et 150
chiffres entre 100 et 150 rassemblements
qui ont été comptabilisés alors à
l'heure on se parle Arthur donc selon
les différents indicateurs cette
mobilisation elle est plus importante
qu'elle ne l'était
mardi dernier donc en à l'heure où on se
parle en ce moment Laurent Berger est
plutôt en train de gagner son Paris
alors on se parle Laurent Berger plutôt
en train de gagner son pari même si je
me permets encore d'émettre quelques
doutes sur le fait que la mobilisation
atteigne le million de manifestants tout
va dépendre des grandes villes dont la
plupart des défilés ont lieu en ce
moment même à Paris c'est parti à 13h à
Marseille c'est parti à 14h je crois que
dans les grandes villes il n'y a que
Toulouse Nice et Strasbourg qui
manifestait ce matin donc on a encore
une grande grande partie des des
métropoles qui n'ont pas encore commencé
à défiler dont on n'a pas encore les
chiffres intéressantes mais Toulouse en
tous les cas je sais pas ce qu'il en est
à Nice et Strasbourg vous allez
peut-être nous le dire mais Toulouse
vous avez plus de manifestants que lundi
effectivement ils étaient 24 000 mardi
là ils sont entre 25000 et 30000 selon
les autorités à Nice et à Strasbourg en
revanche le chiffre est légèrement
baisse à Nice on est à 5600 contre 6800
et à Strasbourg 5900 contre 7000 mais
j'aimerais bien mettre ces chiffres en
perspective avec le nombre de
rassemblements dans le département et à
Strasbourg par exemple donc dans le
Haut-Rhin vous n'aviez habituellement
qu'un seul rassemblement à Strasbourg
tout le monde se réunissait il y avait
des bus qui venaient des
sous-préfectures et des villes des
villages allant alentours aujourd'hui
vous avez également une manifestation à
Sélestat et également une manifestation
à Haguenau pour ceux qui connaissent
l'Alsace savent que c'est les deux
autres grandes villes du Haut-Rhin très
belle ville très belle ville donc vous
avez d'autres manifestations donc le
chiffre de Strasbourg est certes un peu
moindre mais peut-être si vous
l'additionnez ce soir avec les
rassemblements d'agnaux et de Sélestat
vous aurez peut-être plus de qui a
décidé dans le Haut-Rhin au final donc
toujours mettre en perspective par
rapport à au nombre de rassemblements
qui aujourd'hui très important allez
15h39 sur le site du Figaro on a les
images de Paris mais également on salue
effectivement tous les internautes
alsaciens du bas comme du Haut-Rhin et
effectivement donc deux Strasbourg à
Mulhouse en passant par Sélestat
Haguenau et également Colmar et puis au
Saint Louis et également on salue les
internautes de Nice ou les internautes
de la région niçoise également on
n'oublie pas grâce et mentons et ou bien
Cannes et on n'oublie pas non plus les
internautes de la région toulousaine oui
effectivement les manifestations étaient
un petit peu plus importantes que
la semaine dernière en tout cas qu'en
début de semaine paris brûle-t-il nous
demande Vincent alors effectivement vous
voyez ces images de barricades
effectivement cette voiture qui vient
d'être retournée sur un des cortèges
pour l'instant nous disait Timothée
délai qui est l'un de nous envoyer
spéciaux
cette tension que l'on peut observer que
l'on peut voir on vous la montre
d'ailleurs
n'est pas forcément perceptible ailleurs
et on a d'autres images peut-être que
Ronan va pouvoir nous les montrer les
images de cortège plutôt aériennes vous
les voyez là juste au dessus de nous on
va aller voir peut-être en un peu plus
grand qui montre le cortège sur sa son
trajet principal et qui montre une
ambiance tout à fait là beaucoup plus
calme
Macron et borne joue le pourrissement
très bonne question Claudius et bien je
vous invite à rester ici en la posera
cette question tout à l'heure à aux
politologues qui seront sur place
d'abord Véronique reissoult et puis
ensuite surtout Arnaud bdetti Claudius
merci Claudius je vous dis j'ai un
profond respect pour les journalistes
qui suivent les manifs de Paris est-ce
qu'ils ont des gardes du corps point
d'interrogation alors ce c'est que
effectivement la sécurité de nos
journalistes est une de nos
préoccupations il y a 15 jours
effectivement un d'entre eux des gens
Figaro live a été agressé et
la portée plainte et nous associons à
cette plainte parce que effectivement
il y a
le tenons à pouvoir rendre compte de
tout et de dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont et nous ne laisserons pas
impressionner Claudius également qui
nous dit enfin un journaliste qui fait
une analyse fine sur le nombre des
manifestants ça c'est vous Arthur et
effectivement c'est la raison de votre
présence ici alors il y a un autre
phénomène
que j'aimerais bien justement voir avec
vous avant de voir
quelle est la sociologie de cette de ces
manifestations on l'aborde à chaque live
et notamment avec Thibault Gauthier
mais d'abord la géographie de ces
mobilisations
on avait noté vous disiez lors d'un
précédent papier de mobilisation plus
forte à l'ouest moins dans le nord-est
est-ce que c'est pareil aujourd'hui tout
à l'heure un internaute je crois que
c'est Claude justement qui nous disait
ça tout à l'heure qu'il y avait une
mobilisation monstre dans le Nord
effectivement pour ce jour entre
guillemets ce samedi 11 février et
quelque peu particulier il sort un peu
de l'ordinaire puisque vous l'aurez
remarqué nous sommes samedi et ce n'est
pas une mobilisation en semaine avec
grève et mobilisation
interprofessionnelle donc c'est assez
différent et on ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui on avait noté les
mobilisations importantes dans les
villes moyennes la surmobilisation de
l'ouest du Sud-Ouest comparé à la faible
mobilisation du Nord-Est aujourd'hui ce
qu'on constate plutôt c'est une
multiplication des petits cortèges dans
les toutes petites villes c'est très
très intéressant c'est ça qui est assez
impressionnant aujourd'hui je vous
parlais de l'exemple de célestat de
Haguenau
tout à l'heure je vous ai un petit peu
brillé l'info mais enfin vous pouvez le
redonner on parle salut tous nos
internautes auvergnières c'est vrai on a
on peut parler de Brioude où il y avait
quand même 800 personnes Brioude c'est
pour ceux qui ne savent pas c'est en
Haute-Loire c'est une toute petite
commune qui fait à peine 7000 habitants
vous avez 800 personnes qui défilent le
samedi matin donc on a pris 10% de la
population c'est quand même assez
important on parlait tout à l'heure du
Nord-Est on constate une mobilisation à
Metz 4300 personnes largement en baisse
etc etc comment on l'explique parce
qu'il y a des petits défilés en Moselle
à Sarreguemines à Saint-Avold qui
réunissent 800 850
000 personnes donc c'est des personnes
qui allaient à Metz sur les trois
précédentes journées de mobilisation qui
n'y vont plus donc tous les chiffres que
vous allez voir sur les grandes villes
sont parfois à remettre en contexte au
niveau départemental et on fera le bilan
à la fin de la journée mais si ça se
trouve vous allez avoir les mêmes
mobilisations en Moselle que le 19 que
le 31 supérieur à celle du 16 février
mais pas foncer un Mans supérieur dans
la grande ville dans la préfecture de ce
département c'est ça qui est très
intéressant aujourd'hui
une autre question qui se pose c'est
justement sur la la les villes moyennes
est-ce que ces villes moyennes qui se
sont sous préfectures qui sont beaucoup
mobilisés on rappelle que le prochain
rassemblement ça sera à Albi
et avant même que je vous pose la
question peut-être un commentaire sur le
fait que ça vienne à Albi c'est quand
même la marque de fabrique de cette de
cette séquence et de cette du début de
ces mobilisation c'est vrai le
le réveil de ce que Christophe ghis-lui
les séistes et géographe appelaient la
France périphérique effectivement je dis
16 janvier à la fois Laurent Berger pour
la CFDT et Philippe Martinez pour la CGD
défilerons à Albi si ma mémoire album
Albi c'est dans le
garage dans le Tarn dans le Tarn plutôt
et c'est bon dans le Tarn-et-Garonne
effectivement on a la référence des
Tontons Flingueurs dans le Tarn à Albi
donc il défileront loin de Paris pour
une fois c'est assez rare quand même que
les deux leaders des deux principales
centrales syndicales de France manifeste
hors de Paris et ça montre bien cette
ancrage territoriale de cette
mobilisation contre contre la réforme
des retraites c'est très intéressant
d'ailleurs dans le figata de voir que
notamment dans cette région du nord de
l'Occitanie du nord de l'ancienne région
Midi-Pyrénées
dans un département qui est un petit peu
plus à l'est que le Tarn-et-Garonne dans
l'Aveyron
les régions en tous les cas les villes
qui se sont mobilisées également étaient
des villes l'ancienne villeminéaire
notamment d'occasion
vous dites dans un de papier justement
les ouvriers et c'est je crois que c'est
plutôt
les ouvriers restent la catégorie
socio-professionnelle la plus opposée à
l’allongement de la durée de cotisation
et à l'augmentation de l'âge légal
est-ce que on observe justement
sur les cartes
une mobilisation qui est
comparable à celle des présences
ouvrières et de ce qu'il en reste plus
exactement l'exemple le plus frappant
pour moi il est en Bretagne en Bretagne
vous connaissez l'importance de
l'agriculture bretonne dans
l'agriculture française il y a
énormément d'usines agroalimentaires
d'abattoirs
d'usine de transformation et de
production et dans des petites villes
bretonnes Lannion dans les Côtes-d'Armor
Quimperlé dans le Finistère je reprenais
d'avoir corriger la nuit d'enlever les
Côtes d'Armor parce que dans une
première version c'est dans le Finistère
on s'était fait aligné par les je ne
vois pas les parler je ne vois pas de
quoi vous voulez parler votre era tout
vous honore mais à Lannion dans les
Côtes-d'Armor vous aviez encore 5000
manifestants Lannion c'est pas très
grand Quimperlé vous aviez aujourd'hui
6000 manifestants et c'est des villes
qui sont proches de ces grandes usines
agroalimentaires donc on peut en déduire
sans trop de de de comment dire sans
trop sans s'avancer mais
manière assez assez certaine que ces
ouvriers sont venus grossir les cortèges
syndicaux parce que c'est la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle la plus touchée par
l'allongement de cette réforme quand
vous êtes cadre quand vous avez fait des
études qui ont duré 5 6 7 8 9 10 ans
peut-être vous savez que vous entrez
dans le marché du travail à 23 24 ans
pour vous devez cotiser 43 ans 23 et 43
ça fait 66 pour vous lallongement de la
de l'âge légal à 64 ans on a strictement
aucun impact donc il y a quand même si
ça n'a pas d'impact sur vous vous avez
quand même tendance à moins vous
mobiliser donc donc voilà
dans les zones les plus mobilisées vous
dites ouvriez et employés représente
souvent la majorité de la population
active et c'est là où on voit
effectivement un surprendre mobilisation
est-ce que cette tendance se confirme
ces dernières heures cette tendance se
confirme on fera évidemment un retour
sur expérience à partir à partir des
données de ce samedi qui est quand même
une journée je le disais assez
particulière donc on va peut-être voir
quelques différences quelques
surmobilisations dans des villes on s'y
attendait pas peut-être des sous
mobilisations dans des villes on
s'attendait au contraire à une plus
forte présence je pense qu'il faudra
analyser avec finesse ces chiffres et
également attendre la mobilisation de
jeudi prochain jeudi 16 février et là on
pourra reprendre très de manière assez
linéaire des analyses sur les ouvriers
les employés etc etc aujourd'hui c'est
un petit peu différent Claudius nous dit
record de manifestants encore une fois
adoué alors peut-être que si vous avez
des informations si on vous a donné des
chiffres peut-être que vous le
partagerez bien sûr ce sera votre
estimation voilà confronté avec une
estimation un petit peu plus officielle
mais ce sera intéressant en tous les cas
de dire sur quoi justement ce fonde
cette le caractère exceptionnel de cette
manifestation en tout cas et ça c'est
une info qui vient de tomber qui nous
est donnée par un autre correspondant
celui de
Julien Chaillou dans la cité des Ducs de
Bretagne donc le cortège est également
scindé en deux donc là aussi on est dans
l'ouest on est dans une région qui se
mobilise plus traditionnellement et
apparemment c'est le site quand même qui
a une forte mobilisation là-bas c'est
vrai on voit aussi un cortège scindé en
deux à Paris un cortège scindé en deux à
Nantes Nantes Rennes ont été des parmi
les grandes villes les grandes villes
les plus mobilisées
toujours cette tendance de l'Ouest à
être extrêmement extrêmement mobilisé
dans dans ces manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites est-ce que c'est
aussi des vies des régions on est plus
fortement syndiqués aussi des régions
oui on est plus fortement syndiqués je
pense également qu'il y a beaucoup
d'étudiants à Rennes à Nantes ce sont
des grandes villes étudiantes avec un
fort ancrage à gauche Rennes est dirigé
par Nathalie a Perry qui est appartient
Parti socialiste Johanna Rolland et mer
de Nantes qui appartient également à
partie socialiste donc il y a un fort
ancrage une forte syndicalisation et
c'est ce qui peut expliquer ces grandes
ces grands défilé par rapport à d'autres
villes un peu un peu plus un peu plus à
l'est par exemple merci beaucoup
arthurby je tape c'est précisions ces
informations on va retrouver Timothée
d'Hélène qui est lui dans le cortège à
Paris Timothée
est dans un instant Cyril Chabanais du
président de la CFTC pardon qui va nous
rejoindre à l'état est plutôt ben on va
le prendre plutôt justement pour
discuter un petit peu et voir un petit
peu quel est l'état quel est l'humeur
dans cette vieille et prestigieuse
centrale syndicale
Timothée quel est l'ambiance où vous
trouvez
on n'entend pas Timothée délène
alors il y a un petit problème de
batterie effectivement donc on voit
qu'il y a un petit souci et est-ce que
vous m'entendez bien sûr on vous entend
parfaitement bien donc vous pouvez
reprendre mes faut reprendre à zéro
oui
alors reprenons à zéro Vincent je vous
disais que l'ambiance ici est assez
confuse vous le voyez d'ailleurs je me
trouve au niveau de la rue de Charonne
c'est-à-dire à peu près à mi parcours
entre la Place de la République et la
place de la Nation vous le voyez ici ce
sont des sapeurs-pompiers de Paris qui
viennent d'arriver sur place juste
derrière moi un véhicule de
sapeur-pompiers de Paris ils sont
peut-être 5 ou 6 ils sont vraiment tenus
d'intervention avec notamment les
casques pour quelle raison est bien
parce que vous l'avez vu sur les images
c'est un véhicule qui a été incendié par
certains manifestants on est en train de
se rapprocher des lieux ici des débris
de verre au sol et ici en fait le
cortège a été arrêté par les forces de
l'ordre qui tentent et bien de remettre
de l'ordre précisément parce qu'il y a
eu un moment de grande confusion nous
avons vu des jeux de bouteilles
notamment et vous le voyez on va
s'approcher avec Judas Leclerc parce que
c'est assez impressionnant on va
continuer la prochaine cortège qui est
qui est à l'arrêt à présent et vous le
voyez de plus en plus là-bas et bien
cette fumée épaisse noire qui remonte
qui s'envole vers le ciel voilà c'est la
fumée d'un d'un véhicule qui a été qui a
été incendié donc une situation assez
assez confuse vous l'imaginez une odeur
une forte odeur là de de brûler qui est
bien qui se fait ressentir nous avons
remonté la rue de Charonne à l'instant
avec Julien et il y avait des dizaines
et des dizaines de personnes en flux
continu de personne qui et bien qui
était sur cette rue de Sharon qui était
en train de quitter le bourrin Voltaire
alors sont-ils en train de quitter la
manifestation sont-ils entre un
simplement de rejoindre l'autre cortège
qui se trouve sur le boulevard du temps
boulevard du temps qui qui est donc une
avenue parallèle à celle sur laquelle
nous nous trouvons pour l'instant voilà
on sait pas vraiment ce que font ces
gens en tous les cas là il y a du monde
qui est en train d'évacuer les lieux
faut que le cortège comme je vous le
disais et totalement arrêté à présent
par les forces de l'ordre et les
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris qui sont en
train d'intervenir donc après que ce
véhicule ait été brûlé par les
manifestants
Timothée et bien vous restez d'abord
vous prenez soin de vous vous faites
attention pas de risque inutile et vous
nous dites un petit peu quelle est la
vous nous tenez au courant sur la
situation tout au long de cette
manifestation et au sein du cortège
merci beaucoup pour ces dernières
informations pour ces précisions bonjour
Cyril Chabanier bonjour merci de vous
être exclustrer de ce cortège pour venir
dans les studios du Figaro vous êtes le
président de la CFTC la Confédération
française des travailleurs chrétiens
plus anciens l'un des plus anciens
syndicats français et plus encore que la
CGT non non la CGT était antérieure
était antérieure un petit peu avant nous
et d'ailleurs l'accepter c'est créer un
petit peu voilà pour contrer la CGT pour
avoir un syndicat réformiste par rapport
à un syndicat qu'on appelait plutôt
révolutionnaire d'où effectivement bon
des images comme ça qui nous viennent
alors bien entendu on en a d'autres où
on voit et on les montre en alternance
c'est beaucoup plus calme mais on n'est
pas trop dans l'ambiance familiale que
vous espériez quand même il y avait une
grande ambiance familiale dans le
cortège syndical et ça c'est à noter
avec beaucoup de personnes qui sont
venues avec leurs enfants en famille
parce que le cortège syndical lui est
sécurisé par des corps de par des
services de sécurité qu'on a mis en
place avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales mais évidemment tout ce qui
est hors cortège syndical c'est toujours
compliqué à maîtriser et il y avait
beaucoup plus de monde que d'habitude
sur ce qui est hors cortège syndical et
on se doutait un petit peu d'ailleurs
c'était un risque moi je l'avais évoqué
depuis plusieurs jours d'avoir peut-être
l'envie de personnes qui souhaitaient en
découdre le samedi on sait que
généralement c'est une journée où il y a
plus de Black Blocs où il y a plus de
personnes qui veulent qui veulent en
découdre et donc c'était un peu
prévisible malheureusement
on n'a jamais vu autant de militants
CFTC mobilisés
pourquoi vous êtes vous pourquoi
êtes-vous vent debout contre cette
réforme on est vend debout contre cette
réforme parce que à la CFTC nous avons
jamais renié le fait qu'il fallait que
notre régime soit équilibré on a même
pas discuté ce qu'on aurait pu
longuement discuter sur les chiffres du
corps on n'est pas rentré dans dans ce
débat au chiffre du Comité d'Orientation
des Retraites oui il serait un petit peu
discutable pour nous
c'est pas le sujet ok il manque il
manque 12 milliards pour équilibrer les
comptes pour 2025 ça ira jusqu'à
peut-être 15 18 milliards un petit peu
plus tard ce qui est très compliqué dans
cette réforme c'est que on a absolument
pas pu discuter sur le financement de la
réforme des retraites or nous vous avez
reçu du travail nous avons été reçus
si nous avons été reçus je vous rappelle
que d'abord ça devait passer en force
dans le bel effet SS au mois de
septembre
social voilà le loi de le projet de loi
de la sécurité sociale on s'était
manifesté fortement le gouvernement
avait donc ouvert des concertations nous
avait même écouté sur les trois phases
que j'avais demandé de la concertation
c'est à dire une phase d'abord sur
l'emploi des seniors et sur les
conditions de travail enfin tous les cas
les syndicats réformistes alors je sais
que c'est assez VGT qui a plus porter ça
mais enfin sur l'emploi des seniors a
plutôt été entendu pour le gouvernement
non très honnêtement non on a été on a
été entendu sur le fait que ce soit un
sujet majeur mais sur les mesures pour
l'index senior en fait il y a juste une
contrainte de le publier et vous avez
une pénalité financière si vous le
publiez pas mais publié un index les
entreprises elles ont publié 18 par jour
il y a pas de problème c'est il fallait
aller plus loin que ça c'est-à-dire que
il faut pas simplement être pénalisé
parce qu'on n'a pas publié l'index il
faut être pénalisé parce que son index
est mauvais voilà donc et c'est là où le
gouvernement n'est pas allé jusqu'au
bout de dire si l'emploi des Sen dans
l'entreprise n'est pas avec un bon taux
vous êtes pénalisé financièrement là on
pénalise le fait de ne pas le publier
vous inquiétez pas ils vont tous le
publier même si les mauvais ne risque
rien donc ils vont tous le publier mais
s'il risque finalement non il risque une
amende s'ils ne le publie pas c'est vrai
une grève surprise ce matin des
contrôleurs à Orly Cyril Chabanier une
grosse pagaille 50% des vols annulés un
vol sur deux est-ce que ça donne pas
raison à Emmanuel Macron et à sa petite
phrase qui vous avez fait tant réagir
des centrales syndicales quand il vous
appelle à ne pas bloquer la vie du reste
du pays
mais nous je crois qu'on a montré qu'on
ne souhaitait pas bloquer la vie du
reste du pays on a on s'est mis d'accord
à 8 organisations et on sait qu'on n'est
pas toujours d'accord surtout et
certains veulent des mouvements plus
durs d'autres un petit peu moins et
depuis le 19 janvier nous faisons des
mouvements de manifestation on bloque
pas le pays on n'a pas empêché nos
concitoyens
dans les transports
je suis en live tous les matins de grève
comme ça on a quand même des témoignages
de grève et en plus de grève inopinées
parfois alors parfois ça peut arriver
parce qu'évidemment on contrôle pas tous
les secteurs et tous nos adhérents mais
très honnêtement on nous reconnaît un
qu'on a fait que des manifestations deux
qu'on a pas empêché un peu les vous les
départs en vacances pas de grève SNCF
donc je crois qu'on est on peut pas dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a bloqué le pays le
problème qu'il y a c'est que nous sommes
à notre 4e manifestation ça fait quatre
fois qu'on met plus d'un million de
personnes dans la rue c'est du jamais vu
quasiment et que le gouvernement fait
complètement de la source d'oreille en
de suite plus d'un million de personnes
c'est quand même très très fort et le
gouvernement fait complètement la sourde
oreille la seule chose qui nous dit
c'est bravo vous faites des belles
manifestations ça se passe calmement
vous savez bien faire vous savez bien
organisé mais on est absolument pas
entendu et vous avez vu que ce matin
l’inter syndicale s'est réuni et appelle
à monter d'un cran et faire certains
blocages alors précisément est-ce que ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les durs
la CGT solidaire l'emporter sur la CFDT
la CFTC sur les réformistes non pas du
tout parce que depuis le départ on s'est
mis d'accord pour dire on fait des
simplement des manifestations et donc on
ne durcit pas le mouvement et on avait
dit si on n'est pas entendu on était
tous d'accord dès le départ pour
progressivement monter d'un cran et donc
le monter d'un cran arrive aujourd'hui
après après plus de femmes presque un
mois un mois après et donc et vous avez
remarqué que ce matin inter syndical n'a
pas appelé à des grèves reconductibles
comme on pouvait s'attendre dans dans la
presse ça fait quelques jours qu'on
entendait ça on a appelé à une journée
très forte alors d'abord il y a la grève
de jeudi une nouvelle manifestation pour
faire pression sur les dépôt des grèves
il y aura sûrement des grèves mais avant
tout c'est des manifestations pour faire
pression sur les députés puisque ça sera
le les derniers jours du texte à
l'Assemblée nationale et puis ce 7 mars
qui va être une journée ou l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales appellent à
arrêter l'activité donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'on demande à tous les
salariés de tous les secteurs fonctions
publiques du privé de se mettre en grève
de bloquer l'activité qui que le pays se
trouve à l'arrêt cette journée du 7 mars
pour montrer vraiment
ceux qui veulent travailler ce jour-là
ils pourront pas ça va être très
compliqué si c'est bien suivi il faut
toujours attendre ça sera compliqué
d'aller travailler ce jour-là est-ce que
ses responsables
je crois que ce qui est responsable
c'est alors d'abord ce qui n'est pas
responsable c'est l'attitude du
gouvernement quand il veut devant une
telle pression populaire avec vous me
disiez l'inverse non mais mais quand
même quand on a 80 je veux dire quand on
a 93 % des salariés qui sont contre
cette réforme 70% de l'opinion publique
et vous remarquez que chaque fois que le
gouvernement dit on fait de la pédagogie
on prend deux points de plus dans les
gens qui nous soutiennent pour la
première fois et c'est un chiffre qui
doit marquer on a 60% des Français qui
sont même prêts à prouver des blocages
au niveau des blocages on n'a jamais une
majorité de Français qui les approuvent
donc l'irresponsabilité ne vient pas de
nous je crois qu'on a été très
responsable d'ailleurs y compris le
gouvernement et la presse ne cesse de
louer depuis trois semaines un mois le
fait qu'on bloque
si vous faites ça non parce que encore
une fois on n'est pas dans une logique
de blocage dur avec des grèves
reconductibles avec les raffineries qui
sont bloqués pendant plusieurs jours et
le fait qu'il y ait pas d'essence 0,3
non peut-être que certains la souhaitent
à la CFTC on n'est pas dans cette
logique là et on ne la souhaite pas donc
nous on n'ira pas dans la grève
reconductible mais par contre vraiment
un coup très fort un coup de poing ce
mardi 7 mars je crois que ça reste dans
le raisonnable tout en montant d'un
grand mais vous savez trouver le bon
compromis trouver les trouver la bonne
ligne de crête entre monter d'un cran
sans tomber dans le blocage total c'est
c'est compliqué à trouver surtout à huit
et je crois que là on a fait un
compromis qui est qui est très
intéressant tous ces manifestants ne
sont pas juste contre la réforme des
retraites mais aussi pour tout le reste
électricité santé mesure diverses c'est
ça aussi cette mobilisation c'est
d'autres d'autres causes qui s'agrègent
à cette à cette cause de la réforme des
retrait oui on le l'opposition à la
réforme de retraite oui on le sent bien
alors évidemment la réforme des
retraites est souvent une thématique qui
mobilise davantage mais on sent bien
dans les discussions qu'on peut avoir
avec les militants et les concitoyens
qu'on voit dans le dans les
manifestations que c'est une est une
globalité et je crois même que c'est
l'une des raisons des fortes affluences
qu'on a dans les régions dans les je
sais que après c'est beaucoup surprise
de de la mobilisation dans des petites
villes ou des villes moyennes ou parfois
il y a plus de moi de personnes
mobilisées que d'habitants dans la dans
la commune parce que peut-être que
encore plus que dans les grandes villes
encore plus qu'à Paris les thématiques
qui sont autour de la retraite font font
vraiment font en sorte que cette
mobilisation marche beaucoup c'est pour
ça que vous allez aller à Albi le 7 mars
prochain oui c'est l'une des raisons la
première raison c'est qu'on voit que la
mobilisation en province est extrêmement
importante et qu'on veut rendre hommage
à ces personnes qui se mobilisent en
province parce que souvent on est un peu
habitué à des manifestations très
importantes dans les grandes villes et
quasiment inexistante dans les petites
villes donc on veut rendre hommage à ces
personnes qui se mobilisent on a choisi
l'Occitanie parce que ça a été la région
dans lequel n'ont pas y avait forcément
le plus de monde mais le plus de points
de mobilisation et donc c'était
important de voir que les numéros 1
pouvaient sortir des grandes villes
sortir de Paris il y a rendre hommage à
ces personnes qui manifestent être à
leur côté et donc on a nous avons choisi
collégalement Albi la sève d'été la CGT
revendique une augmentation du nombre
d'adhérents depuis le début du mouvement
je crois que c'est le cas également chez
FO est-ce que c'est votre cas aussi oui
on voit alors c'est j'ai l'honnêteté de
dire que c'est toujours compliqué à
déterminer de manière précise parce que
quand on écoute d'ailleurs mes collègues
ils disent souvent que il y a beaucoup
plus de rentrée de cotisations au mois
de janvier de 2 à 3 fois plus que les
années que les autres années on a aussi
toute une série de personnes qui payent
beaucoup plus tôt que que les autres
années parce que cette mobilisation les
incite à s'investir plus directement
mais nous avons aussi beaucoup de
demandes de de nouveaux adhérents donc
évidemment ce type de mobilisation
crée un dynamisme pour les syndicats et
ce qui est assez surprenant c'est que
les personnes nous reconnaissent ils
louent le fait que l'on soit en inter
syndical et donc cette inter syndicale
personne tire en fait la couverture à
soi et profite à l'ensemble des
syndicale même le très modéré Cyril
Chabanier de la CFTC chrétienne et
contre cette réforme et même la CFE CGC
des CAD c'est dire nous dit Chris cross
précisément
vous dites que vous ne contestez pas
l'analyse du Comité d'Orientation des
Retraites donc il prévoit un déficit des
caisses de ces caisses de retraite
par répartition bien sûr donc
est-ce qu'il faut pas un moment poser la
question de restaurer de poser le
problème démographique et donc puisque
vous êtes de la CFTC je pose la question
de restaurer une politique nataliste et
une politique familiale
c'est c'est évident je reviens juste
j'ai pas vraiment dit que je ne comptais
pas les chiffres du corps je dis que
j'ai pas envie de rentrer dans ce débat
certains chiffres me trouvent enfin je
trouve qu'ils sont exagérés mais dans
tact voilà j'ai dit on passe à autre
chose il est évident la nuance c'est la
marque de fabrique de ce média voilà
mais il est il est évident que la
politique familiale a été mise à mal
depuis depuis des décennies et une forte
politique basée sur la natalité des
aides mais d'ailleurs on l'avait fait y
compris des propositions dans cette
réforme des retraites par exemple plutôt
que de donner un bonus à partir du
troisième enfant à peu près 300 euros on
pourrait très bien dire on donne 100
euros dès le premier enfant et 100 euros
à chaque enfant ça revenait quasiment
quasiment au même donc on a des proposés
alors c'est un certain coût mais qu'on
financer on a des proposés d'avoir ces
mesures incitatives y compris pour la
retraite que les personnes soient
reconnues dès le premier enfant avec une
aide qui était apportée et
proportionnelle évidemment au nombre
d'enfants mais la politique
journalistes et forcément et forcément
un sujet un sujet majeur quand on voit
qu'on arrive avec quasiment un retraité
pour 1,7 actif donc c'est c'est vraiment
un sujet qui est très important pour
nous mais encore une fois c'est pas le
seul sujet c'est comment enfin je crois
que la seule question que le
gouvernement doit s'opposer c'est
comment on trouve 12 milliards est-ce
qu'on peut trouver 12 milliards sans
repousser l'âge légal on peut les
trouver vous savez que moi je comprends
pas pourquoi vous êtes autant arc-bouté
sur l'âge légal parce que ce report de
l'âge légal est injuste à 65 ans
certes mais sauf qu'il y a pas beaucoup
d'efforts qui sont faits sur les
critères de pénibilité il y a des tas de
métiers aujourd'hui on tape quasiment de
la même façon sur des métiers qui sont
très différents et en particulier
l'immense majorité des personnes qui
sont travailleurs de ce qu'on a pu
appeler durant le confinement les
secondes lignes qui ont souvent des
métiers pénibles toutes ces personnes là
vont prendre deux ans de plus sans
quasiment que les critères de pénibilité
étaient aménagé pour elle c'est vraiment
un vrai sujet et
alors il y a quelques efforts qui ont
été faits sur la pénibilité vous savez
qu'il y a eu un grand débat sur ce qu'on
appelle les critères
ergonomiques c'est-à-dire les charges
lourdes et les postures difficiles qui
avaient été retirées par ce gouvernement
enfin en tout cas sous la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron du comte de pénibilité
et qui ne sont pas réintégrés aux
comptes de pénibilité mais qui vont
permettre de en tout cas on pourra en
tenir compte avec un avis médical pour
pouvoir soit avoir un congé de
reconversion soit partir plus tôt mais
en fait pour obtenir ça il faudra avoir
l'accord de la médecine du travail et
toutes les mesures de pénibilité
reposent sur la médecine du travail dans
ce projet qui est dans un état dans
notre pays catastrophique demandée aux
salariés
on peut s'engager sur la pénibilité mais
tant qu'on n'aura pas revu justement les
les logistique autour de cette
reconnaissance de la pénibilité en
particulier la médecine du travail on
pourra pas mais nous on souhaite nous on
souhaitait que ce soit remis dans les
dans les dans les contes de pénibilité
je vais vous dire une chose la seule
chose est là je sais que je me
différencie de mes collègues en tout cas
nombre d'entre eux mais la seule chose
qui doit compter pour partir plus tôt
c'est la pénibilité c'est pas le statut
donc avant que vous me posiez la
question la CFTC et toujours pour un
régime universel donc elle est opposée
au régime spéciaux mais on pouvait mais
on pouvait par contre le faire de
manière légèrement progressive je trouve
que très honnêtement et le privé aussi
il y en a un peu marre que l'application
de cette mesure se fasse
comme le nôtre où on a 42 systèmes de
retraite en faire plus qu'un ça prend un
petit peu de temps mais c'est ça la
bonne solution
vous voulez vraiment augmenter les
cotisations salariale les cotisations
patronales on a fait plusieurs
propositions d'abord jouer sur l'emploi
des seniors encore une fois si 15% de
seniors travaillaient en plus c'est 10
milliards qui rentrent justement
ça le gouvernement est d'accord avec
vous sur ce point-là
de départ à la retraite ce qui va
inciter les entreprises mécaniquement ce
qu'on a vu déjà avec le report à 70 ans
a gardé plus longtemps les seniors oui
mais alors franchement quel manque de
courage il y a alors c'est vrai je le
conteste pas mécaniquement quand vous
repoussez l'âge légal
on est plus vieux plus tard c'est
presque une loi mathématique de base si
vous dites que la retraite est à 70 ans
à 65 ans vous êtes encore jeune si vous
dites que la retraite est à 50 vous êtes
encore vous êtes jeune à 50 voilà donc
il va y avoir un petit effet du fait de
la mais qu'elle a vu de faiblesse
franchement le gouvernement parce qu'il
y a eu la pression du patronat n'a pas
voulu prendre des mesures fortes pour
que les entreprises arrêtent de se
débarrasser des seigneurs moi je passe
mon temps y compris avec les
organisations patronales qui nous font
des discours de une demi-heure sur le
fait qu'un seigneur c'est super
important qu'il a une expérience
incroyable que pour le tutorat c'est
juste génial que c'est une force vive
voilà et à 58 59 ans vous avez les
chiffres y compris se montrer par le
ministre qui montre qu'il y a une mise
dehors de ces personnes seniors qui est
juste incroyable on a des courbes qui
explosent à 58 59 ans pourquoi parce
qu'avec les trois ans de chômage vous
arrivez jusqu'au 62 donc il fallait
faire une politique forte sur ça ensuite
nous avons demandé de revoir les aides
financières accordé aux entreprises
toutes les exonérations il y en a qui
sont utiles j'ai pas démagogie avec ça
il y en a plein qui sont complètement
inutiles je reviens pas sur le cuce vous
rappelez avec des milliards dont le la
Cour des comptes a démontré que ça ne
servait à rien il y a des milliards à
récupérer ça fait des ça fait quasiment
trois ans
patronales mais alors en même temps en
même temps on avait dit que si ça
suffisait pas l'emploi des seniors les
exonérations on avait une troisième
mesure qui était de faire contribuer les
personnes au plus haut revenus je sais
pas si les gens ont conscience ceux qui
nous écoutent mais quand sur votre pour
votre retraite vous payez une cotisation
de 6,9% qui est qui est plafonné au
plafond sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire
que vous gagnez alors il est à peu près
3800 euros le plafond que vous gagnez
3800 euros que vous gagnez 15000 euros
par mois vous payez 6,9% sur 3800 euros
et à côté de ça vous avez un 0,4% sur la
totalité du salaire on avait demandé que
les salaires supérieurs à 4000 euros
puisse faire un petit geste
supplémentaire progressif mais surtout
sur les cotisations et j'en finis sur ça
souvent me dit mais augmenter les
cotisations il y a l'emploi qui repart
c'est le coût de l'emploi qui est
pénalisé c'est vrai si on augmente de 30
40 euros par salarié c'est complètement
fou à la proposition de la CFTC qui est
de 5 euros je parlais avec une
entreprise qui a 80 salariés 80 salariés
c'était 6 millions de masse salariales
par an 5 euros pour 80 salariés ça fait
400 euros par mois ça fait 4800 par an
4800 euros par an vous croyez
franchement que l'entreprise de 80
salariés qui a 6,2 millions d'euros de
masse salariale est en danger pour 4800
euros 5 euros pour les entreprises c'est
encore 5 milliards qui rentrent dans les
caisses
la capitalisation c'est un gros mot pour
vous
oui je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
pas besoin d'un système parc à
l'utilisation sont très attachés à un
système de à notre système par
répartition donc peut-être qu'un jour il
faudra voir d'avoir il y a des pays dans
le monde alors non pas de tomber dans la
capitalisation mais il y a des il y a
des pays qui ont introduit une petite
dose et en particulier pour faire des
sur complémentaires ou des
complémentaires et peut-être qu'un jour
il faudra aller regarder vers ça mais
très honnêtement on est très attaché à
notre système de répartition aujourd'hui
il est quand même pas tant donc j'ai que
ça je vous rappelle que ces 3%
démographiquement en tout cas ça va pas
s'arranger avec ça va pas s'arranger
mais si nous réglons le problème du
chômage de notre pays sinon réglons le
problème des seniors si nous réglons
l'inégalité des salaires femmes hommes
encore une fois est-ce que un combat de
la semaine mais c'est un combat de la
CFTC on trouve les 12 milliards
également
qu'est-ce que
vous allez qu'est-ce que vous demandez
aujourd'hui à Elizabeth borne qu'est-ce
que vous demandez à Olivier du socle
qu'est-ce que vous lui demandez à
Emmanuel Macron on demande ce qui ne
seront pas prêt à accepter c'est-à-dire
de retirer la mesure d'âge et le report
de l'âge et de nos remettre autour de
votre pouvoir si le Sénat va pour si le
Parlement vote pour d'abord on espère
qu'on va être entendu et que le Sénat et
que le Parlement ne va pas le voter
encore faut-il qu'il est qui est un vote
et on rencontre les députés on fait
beaucoup de pression au niveau des
députés en ce moment et je peux vous
assurer que même dans la majorité
certains sont très embêtés de voter
cette loi et que d'ailleurs il y a
beaucoup d'amendements qui se jouent
entre 5 et 10 voix donc le vote n'est
pas acquis mais ce qu'on lui demande
clairement à ce gouvernement c'est il
retire le report de l'âge légal et on se
remet autour de la table pour trouver
d'autres moyens de financer le futur
déficit de 2025 ces fameux 12 milliards
d'euros
souvent on me dit mais dans les autres
pays on a déjà reculé mais la question
elle est pas ce que font les autres ou
il y a une seule question il nous manque
12 milliards on trouve les 12 milliards
autrement il y a pas besoin si on avait
zéro solution à proposer vous direz on
n'a pas de solution donc celle-là on
fait partie mais il y a d'autres
solutions pour les trouver la prochaine
donc mobilisation c'est d'abord février
donc le 16 février vous retrouvez tous à
Albi ou les numéros un se retrouvent
albihoué et après le 7 mars merci
beaucoup Cyril chavanier d'être venu et
de passer par les studios du Figaro
d'avoir répondu sans tabou sans des
questions qui étaient sans concession et
merci d'avoir répondu aux internautes
peut-être merci
symphonyx qui nous dit pourquoi ne pas
donner une une somme fixe pour tous ceux
qui n'ont pas tout leur trimestre par
exemple une somme de 1500 euros par mois
ce serait une idée qui vous plairait ça
c'est à dire que qui est pas de qui est
aucune personne qui soit en dessous de
1500 euros moi je suis il y a récepté si
on est très attaché à la valeur travail
donc je ne peux pas
en tout cas je ne suis pas favorable à
ce que des personnes qui ont une
carrière complète qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie et la même somme que des
personnes qui n'auraient pas travaillé
toute leur vie ou en tout cas par choix
aurait aurait parfois eu des trous assez
important donc ce qui est important
c'est d'avoir qui répond à cette autre
internaute mon épouse qui a tous ces
trimestres ne gagnent pas cette somme à
la retraite non mais voilà il y a
aujourd'hui vous avez un minimum
retraite qui est à qui est quasiment 900
euros enfin 870 euros c'est un minimum
pour vivre il faut absolument aussi mais
vous avez des gens aujourd'hui qui ont
des carrières complètes et qui sont qui
ont parfois que cinq ans ou 80 euros de
plus que des personnes qui n'ont jamais
travaillé c'est pas un bon signal sur la
valeur travail mais à la CFTC nous avons
une proposition depuis le départ à
partir du moment où nous avons cosmique
qui est dont la définition c'est un
salaire minimum pour vivre quand on est
actif à la retraite on devrait pour des
personnes qui ont travaillé évidemment
on devrait avoir ce salaire minimum pour
vivre donc 1350 euros et beaucoup
d'études d'ailleurs démontrent que le
salaire descend pour vivre dans notre
pays or Paris et on parle que de salaire
décent c'est 1350 euros donc si la CFTC
ne défend pas le salaire descend je
crois qu'elle a un problème avec ses
valeurs c'est peut-être une toute
dernière question
mais est-ce que
justement vous qui êtes attaché la
valeur travail vous ne craignez pas deux
choses la première c'est que dans cette
dans ces débats qui sont soulevés on va
y revenir d'ailleurs tout au long de
l'après-midi mais il n'y a pas quand
même une dévalorisation de la de la de
la valeur de travail on a entendu des
élus Sandrine Rousseau Paris droit à la
paresse notamment ça c'est une première
question puis après je vous en poserais
une dernière toute dernière
moi je partage pas du tout cette
idéologie donc voilà mais ça vous
surprendra pas le travail est une valeur
forte dans notre pays c'est par le
travail aussi qu'on peut faire
l'émancipation c'est par le travail
aussi qu'on a un lien social donc la
valeur travail est très importante donc
quand j'entends le droit à l'appareil
c'est pas notre conviction à la CFTC par
contre évidemment de l'autre côté on est
aussi très attaché à pouvoir concilier
la vie familiale et la vie
professionnelle vous savez qu'à la FTC
on n'est pas fan des gens qui enfin
d'obliger les personnes à travailler le
dimanche par exemple on est très
attentif à pouvoir garder des temps de
vie des temps de famille parce qu'après
on dit aussi que le lien se défait mais
quand on a plus ce temps social ce temps
familial forcément ça accentue ça et
d'ailleurs on l'a un peu retrouvé avec
le confinement où les gens se sont
rendus compte que c'était important ce
temps là donc ce sont c'est vraiment une
bonne conciliation mais ceux qui vont
dans l'excès et puis il faut donner aux
salariés le moyen de pouvoir travailler
dignement dans des bonnes conditions de
travail donc il y a un énorme travail
sur les conditions de travail sur sur le
fait de d'adapter les modes de
production mais aller vers une
revendication du droit à l'appareil non
le travail est important mais il faut
pouvoir gagner sa vie dignement avec son
travail il faut pouvoir améliorer les
conditions de travail pour que les
personnes aillent au travail de façon
heureuse et qui puisse surtout vivre de
leur travail
vous parliez tout à l'heure donc de
monter d'un cran à partir du 7 mars
est-ce que vous ne craignez pas on le
voit quand même avec des images
aujourd'hui donc avec même si vous
disiez que c'était prévu mais on voit
quand même quelques images aujourd'hui
qui sont quand même de tension plus
forte que ça ne l'était les jours lors
des précédentes jours de lors des
présences journaux de mobilisation
est-ce que vous ne craignez pas une
radicalisation et en particulier sous la
pression d'autres syndicats aujourd'hui
mobilisés contre la réforme des
retraites
je ne crains pas une radicalisation qui
est ce qui serait menée par d'autres
d'autres syndicats mais par contre oui
j'ai une forte crainte que ça se
durcisse ce qu'on entend aujourd'hui
dans nos cortèges même chez nos
adhérents c'est le fait que ils nous
prennent souvent en comparaison les
gilets jaunes en disant mais il y avait
dans les meilleurs cas 300 000 personnes
dans la rue et à partir du moment où ils
se sont mis à casser ils ont obtenu 10
milliards d'euros donc est-ce que nous
on met plus on met quatre fois un
million plus d'un million de personnes
dans la rue et on a l'impression qu'on
n'est pas écouté ce que le gouvernement
nous dit simplement voilà il manifeste
ils sont calmes ils sont gentils et ça
se passe bien et donc il y a beaucoup de
questions en disant mais est-ce que
aujourd'hui dans notre pays on ne peut
rien obtenir pacifiquement simplement en
mettant en montrant notre mécontentement
est-ce que dans ce pays pour obtenir
quelque chose il faut aller à casser
alors c'est évidemment pas du tout la
philosophie de mes adhérents mais ça
interroge et moi j'arrête le
gouvernement à force de pas nous écouter
de pas nous entendre ils vont entraîner
de plus en plus de personnes vers la
radicalité et ce sera pas du fait des
syndicats merci beaucoup Cyril
chaabanier cette fois-ci je vous libère
d'être venu dans les studios du Figaro
et d'être venu nous parler aussi
clairement on va merci justement montrer
des images de la manifestation le temps
de vous laisser
quitter les studios et on va revenir
dans une dans une petite minute avec un
économiste très intéressant très
iconoclaste même si il fait pas partie
des économies des econoclastes qui
s'appelle Raphaël Rossello et qui nous
dira que en fait la retraite c'est pas
forcément ça le problème on se retrouve
dans dans cinq ou dix minutes
et on va vous laisser avec les images du
cortège
pas changer de
flux et nous laisser les images merci à
tout de suite merci beaucoup
ce qu'il faut faire jouer
on revient en direct dans les studios du
Figaro images donc du cortège
parfois on a du mal à comprendre
pourquoi on trouve des drapeaux
palestiniens dans un cortège contre la
réforme des retraites celle-ci que il y
a quand même une extension du domaine
des revendications et qu'on est plus
tellement dans les questions sociales
mais on posera peut-être cette question
tout à l'heure à Arnaud Benedetti
politologue qui sera avec nous pour
l'instant on a le plaisir d'être avec
Raphaël Rossello qui est économiste et
banquier d'affaires d'écrire un livre
extrêmement intéressant qui s'appelle
demain la fin de l'insouciance c'est
chez Mareuil édition alors avant d'en
parler on va aller
à côté de la entre République et nation
retrouvait Timothée d'Hélène est-ce que
Timothée nous entend apparemment il y a
eu
euh quelques tensions c'est peu de le
dire derrière vous
sur ces images de Julien Leclerc tout à
l'heure nous étions à l'arrêt je vous le
disais avec un véhicule des
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris qui était en
train d'intervenir voilà le cortège qui
a été bloqué pendant une bonne dizaine
de minutes pour laisser les pompiers
évacuer cette cette voiture voilà qui a
donc cramé tout à l'heure c'était
environ 10 minutes le cortège vient
maintenant de reprendre dans une
ambiance évidemment assez assez
électrique même si la tension est en
train de de redescendre ça n'empêche pas
certains manifestants voilà de donner
des tringles bon on va les montrer euh à
l'écran voilà des tracks donc sur le
professeur sur le pardon Didier
l'allemand le le préfet de l'ancien
privé de police de Paris voilà en tous
les cas une ambiance assez tendue ici
vous le voyez et le cortège qui qui
vient donc de repartir en direction de
la place de la Nation nous sommes à peu
près à mi et parcours je vous cache pas
qu'on se fait
insulter de manière assez assez forte là
donc voilà je vais vous rendre l'antenne
voilà les gens n'apprécient pas que nous
montrions ce genre d'images mais on
montre aussi les images de lorsque ça se
passe bien et on va essayer de leur
demander s'ils ont des choses à dire
devant devant la caméra savoir pourquoi
ils sont là savoir évidemment quels sont
leurs revendications on va le leur
demander puis on va surtout avancer vers
cette place de la Nation ou le cortège
doit arriver il y a la fin de cette
manifestation
et effectivement pas de risque inutile
vous prenez soin de vous et on espère
qu'on pourra continuer à faire notre
travail de pouvoir montrer des choses
telles qu'elles se passent on les a
montré d'ailleurs sur tous les angles on
a donné la parole à tout le monde on
continue de donner la parole à tout le
monde et
bien effectivement chaque fois qu'on
s'oppose à le faire nous le dénonçons
fermement et ne nous laisserons pas
impressionner bonjour Raphaël Rousselot
bonjour Vincent vous êtes économiste et
donc je le disais vous publiez en ce
moment un livre passionnant et même pour
tout dire pour parler en langage
macronien mais c'est juste une image
disruptif en tous les cas qui met en
cause un certain nombre de totem d'abord
une première réaction vous avez regardé
ces images depuis le début de de
l'après-midi une réaction par rapport à
cette mobilisation qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire l'inquiétude pourquoi
c'est vrai qu'il y a quelques images de
tension mais ça se passe plutôt bien
l'inquiétude parce que
bon il y a une volonté politique et on
sait on sait pourquoi de vouloir de
vouloir faire passer
ce que j'appelle j'appellerai une
réformée
qui ne va pas régler le problème qui est
posé
et
alors j'utilise de façon péjorative le
mot de réformes parce que il y a ça rime
avec allumette et je voudrais pas que
pour faire passer un texte pour des
raisons politiciennes on ne prennent le
risque d'allumer un feu dont on ne sait
pas un si il est avéré et de comment il
pourrait se propager alors quelle est la
raison de ça c'est qui il est impératif
de sauver le système de retraite
donc là dessus il y a pas il y a pas de
débat et deuxièmement pour moi il est
impératif de sauver le système de
retraite par répartition
et quand je dis ça je sais que je suis
alors on va y revenir
par répartition
on a entendu un certain nombre on voit
un certain nombre de revendications on a
en sorte entendu un certain nombre de
témoignages on pose la question Timothée
d'Hélène qui est notre envoyé spécial
pose à chaque fois la question de savoir
pourquoi les gens manifestent ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il y a bien
évidemment une opposition chez ces
manifestants à la réforme d'Emmanuel
Macron à une opposition à au report de
l'âge légal de la retraite mais on
entend d'autres
revendications on attend d'autres
en tout cas d'autres raisons qui sont
avancées à commencer par celles de vivre
ce que disait tout à l'heure un des
premiers un des premiers manifestants
interrogés d'une vive descente
et pour vous
on va revenir sur la question de la
retraite La retraite par répartition
mais de quoi cette manifestation est
profondément le nom
moi je pense que bien au-delà bien
au-delà du problème de la de la retraite
et de l'âge de la retraite c'est un
rejet de la politique
actuellement dans sa globalité qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui vous permet de dire ça
alors ce qui me permet de dire ça c'est
j'ai pas j'ai pas sur un plan
scientifique je n'ai pas de fait avéré
donc ce que j'exprime ici en live sur
votre antenne ce sont des perceptions
c'est pas des intuitions c'est des
perceptions
j'aime à dire que je suis un banquier
d'affaires de l'économie réelle donc moi
je suis sur le terrain avec des
entrepreneurs et quel est votre quel est
votre perception et ma perception c'est
qu'il y avait depuis déjà des années un
climat d'incertitude et que ce climat
d'incertitude n'ayant pas posé les
problèmes effectivement que je dénonce
c'est transformé peu à peu en un climat
d'angoisse et quand il y a de l'angoisse
et que en plus on ajoute du ressentiment
à l'occasion d'une réforme
il y a il y a un rejet et qui s'appuie
en plus sur un autre point qui est de la
légitimité si vous entendez depuis des
mois notre président dire j'ai été élu
sur ce programme donc il faut que je le
fasse passer je crois qu'il confond deux
choses il y a la légalité de son vote
qui est évidente certaine et puis il y a
le problème de la légitimité et étant un
négociateur de de pacte d'actionnaires
qui correspond étrangement à une
collectivité à une collectivité humaine
c'est l'abus de minorité
c'est à dire j'ai le pouvoir légalement
c'est moi qui suis aux commandes d'une
organisation et donc même si je ne
représente qu'une minorité d'intérêt je
vais imposer à la majorité
ma pensée oui mais enfin il a obtenu la
majorité il avait affiché la couleur sur
la réforme mais je veux dire cet
ambiguïté nous on parle là dans un
studio
dans les beaux quartiers de Paris et on
fait de la sémantique mais au niveau du
vécu je fais un rappel d'effet
d'Emmanuel Macron a été élu largement à
la majorité avec la majorité que
beaucoup de ces prédécesseurs lui
auraient envie c'est certain mais c'est
certain mais moi-même
les masques ma famille politique on va
dire c'est LR centre d'accord
historiquement bien entendu j'ai voté
pour lui au deuxième tour et que
je comprends sa position je ne comprends
par contre pas considérant qu'il a tous
les outils de compréhension et du
problème de la retraite qui dépasse mais
très largement ce qui est sur le papier
aujourd'hui
qu'ils prennent le risque d'avoir ce que
nous sommes en train de regarder
pourtant vous dites
qu'il faut absolument sauver le système
par répartition alors si vous voulez
le système par être répartition comment
vous faites
c'est pas c'est pas simple alors c'est
pas simple parce que j'avais pas échappé
mais pourquoi c'est pas simple c'est que
en fait on essaie de sauver quelque
chose qui a été conçu il y a 60 ans 70
ans presque
à un moment où vous aviez deux moteurs
dans votre dans l'économie il y avait la
croissance démographique et la
croissance économique donc il y avait
tous les ingrédients pour que
effectivement on est à l'époque la
vision d'un système qui allait durer
éternellement
à partir du moment où on refuse de voir
qu'à partir des années 70 et surtout des
années 85 88 90 qu'il y a eu un
infléchissement de la croissance
économique qui pour moi a disparu depuis
un certain nombre d'années et deux de la
croissance démographique
mécaniquement le problème de la
répartition va de la retraite par la
partition par répartition mais même si
c'était par capitalisation on va y
revenir
en sachant que
je suis extrêmement surpris que l'on
oublie dans le débat de la rue et de
l'Assemblée ce qui est pour moi
l'élément clé de la retraite c'est le
taux de remplacement
qu'est-ce que j'entends par là c'est il
faut 40 ans 42 ans 43 ans en fonction de
d'accord il faut cotiser il faut cotiser
mais que ce soit une cotisation imposée
ou une cotisation
décidé dans le cadre d'une retraite
privée d'accord de toute façon il faut
cotiser et effectivement cotisé par an
on va dire sur une quarantaine d'années
me paraît un socle voilà raisonnable
réaliste
mais pour obtenir quoi aujourd'hui on
obtient à peu près 75% de son salaire de
départ
mais si effectivement le allez on leur
concède les 60 ans de Monsieur Mélenchon
mais que à 60 ans je n'ai que 40 % ou 45
% de mon dernier alors j'aurais répondu
à une idée politique qui était l'âge de
départ à la retraite sans regarder c'est
pas leur revendication de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui il veut que vous ayez
encore vos 75%
pour revenir à la solution pour sauver
le la retraite par partition il y a
quand même on a on n'a jamais trouvé
mieux que d'agir sur deux paramètres qui
étaient celui de la durée de cotisations
ou celui du report de l'âge légal à la
retraite de la retraite qui était Fillon
et verte mais lorsqu'on parce qu'on
écarte
et réellement c'est pour moi une énigme
que les politiques ne l'intégrent pas
c'est l'emploi il n'y a pas de système
pérenne si l'emploi n'est pas pérenne
alors on nous sort effectivement un taux
de chômage qui est l'utilisation
académique d'une définition qui nous est
donnée par le Bureau international du
travail mais enfin soyons raisonnables
il y a aujourd'hui des je pense des
millions de gens qui sont en sous-emploi
ce qu'on appelle les emplois précaires
bien sûr donc à partir du moment le
problème de la précarité de l'emploi
pose un problème sur le site parce que
c'est un problème de cotisation c'est à
dire que quand vous n'avez pas de gens
qui ont un vrai emploi rémunéré et
j'ajouterai dignement rémunéré et bien
ça veut dire que les cotisations de
nouveau
volontaire ou imposée sont insuffisantes
donc on est en train de jongler parce
qu'on ne regarde pas la problématique de
l'emploi en se disant ah non non mais de
toute façon politiquement tout va bien
j'ai un taux de chômage qui est au
zénith très bien parce que peut-être on
peut repréciser Raphaël Rousselot quand
on est au chômage dans le cotise pas
pour sa retraite mais vous cotisez dans
des proportions qui sont le taux le taux
de comment dirais-je de reversion qui
vous est donnée donc si vous êtes
effectivement dans une situation je
parle pas des premiers mois mais dès
lors que votre niveau de rémunération va
tomber à 50 40 peu importe avec une
forte décote de toute façon
chômage
vos la base je veux dire le socle de
cotisation va baisser donc pour moi il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas de solution au
problème de la retraite si on ne regarde
pas le problème de l'emploi on va
continuer à parler de toutes ces
questions là mais je vous propose bien
puisque nous sommes avec ces images qui
nous parviennent du cortège retrouver
Timothée délai mais Julien Leclerc qui
sont sur place entre nations et Voltaire
et ou plus exactement entre nations et
République nation et Voltaire ça c'était
plutôt une des images qui sont envoyées
par la FFP Timothée comment ça se passe
comment avoir le cortège est-ce que le
calme est un peu revenu autour de vous
oui Vincent le calme est revenu en fait
la situation est assez tendue on sent
que voilà il y a de la tension dans
l'air qu'à tout moment ça peut un petit
peu démarrer mais toujours de manière un
petit peu un petit peu ponctuel là le
cortège pour l'instant est revenu au
calme vous le voyez ici c'est le
Mouvement des Jeunes Communistes de
France voilà je vous dis ce que je vois
sur les drapeaux avec ce champ en
international qui qui est retentit et
voilà nous sommes à une centaine de
mètres de la place de la Nation vous la
voyez peut-être apparaître juste juste
derrière moi voilà il y a eu des
tensions évidemment on a vu cette cette
voiture incendiée tout à l'heure on voit
ici également voilà vous voyez ce
conteneur pour des bouteilles en verre
qui a été également renversé on a croisé
voilà pas mal de de bouteilles de verre
brisées au sol de de poubelles
incendiées voilà des tensions ici ou là
mais toujours ponctuelle la situation en
tous les cas ne dégénère pas ou pas à
l'endroit où nous nous trouvons en tous
les cas on va aller voir ce qui se passe
au niveau de la place de la Nation
beaucoup de drapeaux de la France
insoumise également je vous dis cela
parce que voilà vous le voyez d'ailleurs
cet homme avec ce drapeau de la France
insoumise qui passe juste derrière moi à
l'instant on a croisé beaucoup
aujourd'hui voilà et puis le cortège qui
continue d'avancer les syndicats eux se
trouvent bien loin derrière nous hein
vous l'imaginez ils ont toujours voilà
évidemment un peu de de retard sur la
tête de cortège c'est c'est comme ça que
le cortège se déroule voilà et les
banderoles et les les manifestants qui
continuent d'arriver avec ce flux
continu au niveau de la place de la
Nation vu effectivement
les le cortège de la Fédération
démocratique des lycéens la fidèle
vieille organisation enfin qui date de
la fin des années 80 donc pour nous elle
est plutôt ancienne merci beaucoup
les manifestations de 90 merci beaucoup
Timothée pour ces précisions et
continuer effectivement
à nous tenir au courant à suivre à
suivre le cortège et nous dire
effectivement quand les syndicats
également arrivent Raphaël dans tous les
cas c'est très intéressant vos propos
intéressent beaucoup d'autres
internautes ils réagissent beaucoup et
il y a plein de commentaires un petit
peu que je vous donnerai sur lesquels
j'aimerais bien vous faire
réagir
je reviens au système donc par par
répartition votre recette principale
c'est que c'est la réduction du chômage
finalement et la réduction de la
précarité pour pouvoir résoudre le
problème des retraites le problème
démographique quand même peut-être aussi
bien sûr
ce qui est intéressant et vous l'avez
déjà dit en plateau quand vous êtes venu
sur le plateau de point de vue c'est que
vous récusez que cette réforme
finalement si je vous suis vous l'avez
pas dit comme ça mais vous recez
finalement la formule macronienne que la
réforme des retraites et la mère de
toutes les batailles
alors
il est extraordinairement habile dans
son discours donc je demande pas de
faire l'analyse
d'Emmanuel Macron en tant que citoyen
ayant ayant voté pour lui je peux le
dire il est extrêmement habile dans son
discours mais le oui mais ceci étant
ceci étant
et j'adorerais
avoir une micro contribution à une sorte
d'état généraux du problème de la
Solidarité sociale qui fait je dirais la
beauté de notre pays et dans cette
beauté il y a quatre éléments il y a un
élément régalien c'est la justice la
police très bien mais il y en a trois
autres c'est l'éducation la santé la
vieillesse
sur ces trois pôles là nous avons grâce
je l'ai dit à de la croissance
démographique et de la croissance
économique il y a 60 ans nous avons été
en mesure de créer un système
extraordinaire exceptionnelle au niveau
de l'humanité
comment le sauver le sauver c'est
admettre que
de toute façon il y aura et là je ne
m'adresse que le problème de la
vieillesse de la retraite il y aura
toujours le problème d'un actif par
rapport à un retraité et ayant travaillé
et continuant d'ailleurs avec ce que
l'on appelle des fonds de pension et
avec les équipes de gestion de ces fonds
de pension essentiellement anglo-saxons
on a créé de mon point de vue à l'heure
qui est de croire que quand je mets de
l'argent dans un fond de pension ce fond
de pension dans 30-40 ou 50 ans va me
restituer
la somme que j'aurais mise de côté mais
non mais non c'est ce sont si je suis
protégé par General Electric j'en sais
rien là vous parlez le problème de la
réforme par capitalisation mais ce que
je veux dire je pense qu'il il est
essentiel de la retraite c'est que de
toute façon à un moment à la fin c'est
de toute façon un actif c'est le travail
d'un actif qui va permettre retraité
d'être réunionnais on va revenir
justement sur la question du travail des
actifs parce que c'est un point très
important vous touchez que tout le monde
a envie qu'il y ait du plein emploi tout
le monde a envie que il y a un plein
emploi total peut-être que certains noms
préfèrent avoir des emplois saisonniers
mais enfin bon tout le monde enfin tous
les cas aspire à ça problème c'est pas
quelque chose qui se produit enfin on
est dans l'air du chômage de masse
depuis 40 ans et on n'a pas trouvé la
recette comme avait dit François
Mitterrand on a tout essayé sur le
chômage donc
en tout cas votre recette pour
séduisante qu'elle paraît aujourd'hui il
paraît compliqué alors moi j'ai j'ai
je veux pas dire que ça va régler tous
les problèmes mais moi j'ai un vrai
sujet
le vrai sujet et là je suis sur mon
métier c'est le coup du capital je
m'explique
j'accompagne des boîtes de high tech de
metax etc qui ont effectivement pendant
un instant qui est de 5 ans 10 ans 15
ans une forte croissance
grâce à la forte croissance de ces
sociétés innovantes elles peuvent aller
chercher des fonds qui exigent qui
exigent des rendements de 15 20 25% par
an il y a pas de souci là-dessus mais
quand on me dit qu'il faut
réindustrialiser enfin c'est pas qu'on
me dit c'est que je le constate qu'il
faut rien industrialiser l'Europe et
notamment la France moi je pose la
question et je l'ai posé et à Bercy et
il y a plein de gens je dis OK et
comment je fais quand j'ai l'essentiel
du capital à disposition y compris à la
BPI qui me dit à la banque à la banque
pardon à la banque pour l'investissement
ah mais non non il faut parce que sinon
on va se faire recogner par par
Bruxelles enfin bref on va avoir des
problèmes il faut que les entreprises
qui sont candidats à ce que nous
finantions leur développement dégagent
du 10 du 12 du 15% et je dis mais
attendez si je suis dans la mécanique
si je suis dans les métiers
traditionnels et c'est pas
l'intelligence artificielle c'est pas le
progrès technologique qui va me
permettre non j'ai besoin d'avoir des
fonds qui soient
moins exigeant mais sur les rendements
sur les rendements mais attendez mais
qui pose un problème mais monstrueux
d'accord donc j'en suis parfaitement
conscient mais sur un plan politique et
je l'ai vécu en tant qu'entrepreneur au
Canada il y a 30 ans il y avait le Small
Business Act au Canada et vous aviez la
possibilité justement de déroger aux
attentes de du capital global parce que
vous alliez créer des emplois donc il y
a plein il y a des problèmes tarifaires
il y a des problèmes de protection liés
au carbone enfin bref mais
donnez-moi à moi artisan de du
financement des entreprises donnez-moi
des des attentes de fonds de rendement
de mes fonds propres
en harmonie avec le métier qui lui
requiert généralement de la main
d'oeuvre voilà ce n'est qu'un élément
mais et ça je l'entre vous dites pour
parler pour pour synthétiser c'est il
faut qu'il y ait du capital pour des
entreprises qui peuvent arriver à
l'équilibre économique qui peuvent
donner un rendement à ce capital mais
qui sera pas un rendement énorme et qui
permettent de faire d'employer
encore d'employés massivement du
personnel ce qui permettra de réduire à
la fois le chômage et de garantir le
système des retraites absolument voilà
c'est donc la recette de du docteur
Rossello en tous les cas le traitement
autre question puisque vous l'avez dit
vous êtes économiste et banquier
d'affaires et à destination de de PME
pourquoi vous êtes patient emballé parce
que ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a
frappé dans votre livre et dans la
conversation vous aviez déjà eu sur le
plateau de point de vue par la retraite
par capitalisation
parce que pour moi elle est comment
dirais-je alors je vous laisse parler
devant le micro c'est pas vous avez
comme beaucoup de beaucoup de Français
j'ai un plan d'assurance vie
quand je vais demander à purger mon plan
d'assurance vie à un grand assureur de
la place et qu'il va me payer il va soit
me donner un capital soit une rente
je prends l'idée de la rente
donc ça veut dire que c'est un revenu
qui vous est versé à intervalles
réguliers par exemple tous les mois
jusqu'à
ma mort
et à l'origine de cette rente
c'est cette idée que le capital que j'ai
acquis
va
voilà
générer
va générer un revenu non alors il y a le
revenu de l'intérêt légal enfin de
l'intérêt qui sera pratiqué à ce
moment-là ça c'est une chose mais il y a
surtout le fait que
cette compagnie d'assurance a investi
dans des entreprises et que c'est bien
le travail des actifs de ces entreprises
qui va générer ce qui va permettre à
cette compagnie d'assurance de me donner
une rente donc de toute façon on revient
dans le cas de la répartition ou de la
capitalisation il y a ce jour quelqu'un
qui travaille on va y avoir quelqu'un
qui travaille on va y revenir on va
place de la Nation retrouver Timothée
d'hellem s'il entend toujours bien mais
apparemment oui il va m'entendre oui je
le vois il m'entend
et qui se trouve avec un manifestant qui
est arrivé comme vous cher Timothée à
destination appare
ma destination est tout à fait sur cette
place de la Nation que vous voyez noir
de monde Vincent je suis avec un
manifestant qui a battu pavé aujourd'hui
toute la journée bonjour monsieur
c'était important pour vous d'être un
jour bonjour oui c'est très important de
venir ici surtout pour nous France
insoumise parce qu'on soutient
complètement à la fois à l'Assemblée et
dans la rue et puis partout on peut
on soutient le fait d'améliorer cette
réforme parce que nous on la voit
autrement la réforme c'est à dire
comment la voyait on la voit on la voit
ah ça y est excusez-moi excusez-moi
voilà écoutez on va peut-être raccrocher
le temps de
la taille va rapidement quand vous dites
alors déjà vous disiez nous la France
insoumise que voulait dire en fait vous
êtes vous êtes parti du mouvement la
France insoumise je fais partie du
mouvement dans le sens où je suis
animateur d'un groupe d'un groupe
d'action tout simplement il s'est
organisé comme ça la il y a des groupes
d'actions un peu partout en France moi
je suis dans les Yvelines et
direction c'est quoi c'est des
conférences à des groupes d'action c'est
des groupes que l'on créé un peu partout
en France pour faire les actions donc
quand on décide justement de
soutenir les les manifestations on vient
on vient tous on fait du on fait on fait
du des choses classiques on fait du
porte-à-porte du tractage etc pour
inciter les gens à venir à venir à la
manifestation alors vous disiez que vous
êtes contre cette cette réforme des
retraites qu'est-ce qui vous pose
problème concrètement sur dans cette
réforme ce qui nous pose problème c'est
que d'abord on n'est pas d'accord pour
allonger la le l'âge de départ à la
retraite on est nous on est on est pour
la réduction du temps de travail
d'accord pourquoi parce que c'est le
sens de l'histoire en fait on a fait des
progrès énormes dans tout ce qui est
dans tout ce qui est technique pour
remplacer en fait certains travaux etc
ce qui ce qui nous permet de baisser le
temps de travail à la fois le temps de
travail à la semaine le temps de travail
à l'année et le temps de travail sur la
vie voilà et ça permet quoi de faire ça
ça permet en fait de donner du travail à
tout le monde et de le partager alors je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable et
Emmanuel Macron le gouvernement il dit
cette réforme elle est essentielle pour
sauver le système de répartition l'un
des arguments c'est nous vivons plus
vieux donc nous devons travailler plus
vieux que répondez-vous à cet argument
alors nous bon d'ailleurs je viens de
vous expliquer ça n'a rien à voir avec
le sens de l'histoire c'est à dire c'est
ce que je viens de vous dire c'est de le
sens de l'histoire c'est la réduction du
temps de travail
c'est ça le sens de l'histoire et c'est
pas du tout parce que on vit plus vieux
qu'il faut travailler plus ça
en fait c'est pas vraiment une raison ça
la vraie la vraie raison c'est qu'il
nous dit que ça va nous coûter cher et
que ça risque de mettre le nôtre système
de répartition à zéro quoi mais
en fait c'est pas tout à fait vrai ça
parce qu'on a regardé
on va être déficitaire à des moments
donnés et puis à des moments donnés on
va être on va être tout à fait
bénéficiaire d'ailleurs on est
bénéficiaire actuellement voilà donc
quand on peut regarder aussi les
rapports du corps parce que lui ce qu'il
a pris c'est le pire le pire des
scénarios mais en fait c'est parce qu'il
va se passer du tout on a fait des
calculs si on augmente par exemple
le salaire des femmes ça nous fait une
manne pour pouvoir payer les retraites
par exemple
voilà il y a plein d'autres d'autres
manières de payer ce petit ce petit
déficit qu'on nous annonce parce que
c'est pas un gros déficit en fait c'est
tout petit alors sur le salaire des
femmes justement on m'entend on a
entendu encore aujourd'hui dans ce
cortège que les femmes seraient les
grandes perdantes de cette réforme des
retraites est-ce que c'est votre avis
également bien sûr que c'est mon avis
parce qu'elles ont tout à perdre
là-dessus parce que les femmes c'est
c'est elle qui ont des carrières les
plus les plus à trous donc avec la
nouvelle si on regarde avec la nouvelle
la nouvelle loi qui vont nous préparer
et ben elles seront perdantes parce
qu'elles ont pas leurs adultes du tout
elles vont on va voir des difficultés à
les atteindre donc elles seront
perdantes au niveau de leur pension et
elles vont être obligé de travailler
plus encore mais même plus que le que
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
elles ont tout à perdre vous me disiez
que c'est la troisième fois que vous
manifestez qu'on sait très forte des
retraites cette fois-ci
il y a une question maintenant c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il va se passer après on
entend parler d'un éventuel durcissement
du mouvement
vous en tant que en tant que manifestant
en temps également que si j'ai bien
compris adhérent de la France insoumise
quel est votre regard là dessus alors
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure je
sais pas je sais pas si bon comme on
nous on a une action à la fois à
l'Assemblée parce que maintenant on a on
a beaucoup de députés et à la fois dans
la rue avec les autres les autres
instances par exemple les syndicats donc
nous on soutient les syndicats partout
où ils font des actions donc quand
Philippe Martinez de la CGT dit
qu'il envisage un éventuel blocage du
pays au mois de mars vous dites allons-y
nous on dit tout ce qui permet
l'abrogation de la loi ou le retrait de
la loi pour le moment et la progression
si jamais elle passe et bien allons-y
d'ailleurs on a des exemples dans
l'histoire il y a déjà eu une loi qui a
été abrogée alors qu'elle a été signée
et le décret était signé par le
Président et quelques jours après
et ben elle a été abrogée et pourquoi
c'est essentiellement grâce aux grèves
aux vraies reconductibles qui ont été
menées à ce moment-là et sa coiffer
longtemps d'ailleurs voilà vous serez
présent jeudi prochain pour la prochaine
journée de mobilisation je compte venir
voilà Vincent pour l'interview de ce
manifeste en cours merci d'avoir bien
voulu répondre aux questions de Figaro
Live vous le voyez ici les manifestants
qui continuent d'arriver sur cette place
de la Nation une place de la Nation qui
est vraiment très pleine et évidemment
la question qu'on se pose toujours c'est
ce qu'il y a des tensions à ce qu'il a
des affrontements on se souvient de ces
images notamment au niveau de la place
Vauban pour l'instant en tous les cas
tout se déroule dans le calme vous le
voyez certains manifestants qui sont
d'ailleurs
assis tranquillement dans la pelouse
d'autres qui sont en train de discuter
voilà on va continuer de de regarder un
petit peu ce qui se passe ici et de
discuter avec les manifestants alors que
le cortège des syndicats continuent de
s'approcher de cette place de la Nation
évidemment l'ensemble du cortège n'est
pas encore arrivé sur place et on va
continuer à suivre ça avec vous l'autre
question qu'on se pose merci beaucoup
Timothée l'autre question qu'on se pose
c'est sur la mobilisation l'ampleur de
la mobilisation et à l'instant les
chiffres de la CGT qui revendiqu 500 000
manifestants à Paris lors de la dernière
journée de mobilisation au même moment
le syndicat avait recensé 400 000
manifestants donc ce serait 100 000
manifestants de plus selon les
estimations de la CGT j'ajoute que sur
ce plan-là la police elle compte 10 fois
moins de de manifestants en tous les cas
c'était 57000 selon la police pour le 31
janvier dernier peut-être avant de se
quitter Raphaël Rossello deux réactions
à ce qu'on est-ce qu'on vient de
l'entendre
d'abord peut-être une question sur le
sens de l'histoire c'était le terme
employé par ce militant de la France
insoumise qui employait effectivement
cette expression cher en marxiste dans
les années 70 notamment 60-70 le sens de
l'histoire c'est la réduction du temps
de travail ce n'était pas du tout la vie
d'ailleurs du patron de la CFTC tout à
l'heure qui était là
chez vous enfin
le cas qui a une grande considération
pour la valeur travail mais est-ce que
il pose pas une vraie question sur
justement cette question du travail et
c'est est-ce que c'est ça le sens de
l'histoire ah bah alors c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est plein plein de
d'intellectuels de chercheurs et autres
les 250 ans qui viennent de s'écouler
depuis la révolution industrielle sont
considérés de plus en plus sérieusement
comme un accident de l'histoire
c'est à dire que nous avons réussi en
Occident et l'Occident a entraîné un
petit peu à son détriment une grande
partie de la planète dans un modèle qui
nous a permis de sortir de la famille de
la misère récurrente de l'esclavagisme
de l'obscurantisme enfin de toutes les
vertus qui sont nées avec les lumières
ça c'est une certitude mais quand ce
militant
étant donné que personne
ni au niveau des gouvernants ni au
niveau des syndicats ne lui suggère
parce qu'il refuse le constat que je
fais qu'il y a eu mais pas maintenant il
y a 50 ans il y a 40 ans il y a eu une
inflexion
ça veut dire que les gains qui ont été
obtenus ils ont été obtenus parce qu'il
y avait une croissance
régulière de la production de richesse
donc effectivement lui il regarde dans
son rétroviseur à échéance des deux
trois générations qui l'ont précédé et
se dit mais je vois vraiment pas
pourquoi vous êtes des [__] les mecs
parce que mon arrière-grand-père mon
grand-père mon père ont eu tous ces
avantages et bien il faut que ça
continue donc tant que nous n'avons pas
diminué
de façon alors là universitaire média
entrepreneur syndicat et politique quand
on n'a pas déminé le
fait que nous sommes dans cette
inflexion
c'est que les on a connu depuis deux
siècles depuis la fin depuis la
révolution industrielle finalement une
époque un âge d'or etc est terminé que
de toute façon ce sera plus dur il
faudra travailler plus si on veut gagner
autant que de non gagner le prédécesseur
qui ont en travaillant moins voilà
c'est c'est pas de moi travailler ça va
être de plus travailler pour gagner
avoir les sports à gagner au moins
autant qu'en gagner des prédécesseurs
moi j'ai commencé cette interview en
disant il faut sauvegarder le système
d'accord bon mais
il va y avoir plusieurs curseurs il faut
poser les curseurs sur la table un autre
une autre réaction sera la dernière
Raphaël Rousselot
Vincent trouve une référence marxiste
pour la baisse d'or de travail non j'ai
trouvé une référence marxiste pour
l'emploi du terme le sens de l'histoire
vous savez que dans les années 60 70
dans les années 60 j'étais palais 70 je
commençais tout juste à l'être mais
enfin quand même on le sait c'était
l'horizon mon employait toujours
l'expression le sens de l'histoire et et
Raphaël Rossello qui est à peine moins
jeune que moi pourra vous le confirmer
la dernière question et c'était ce que
disait ce ce manifestant Raphaël
Rossello c'est qui dit finalement le
système des retraites il est parfois
bénéficiaire parfois déficitaire et que
il y a plusieurs hypothèses de
du rapport entre les cas de l'étude
faite par le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites qui est la référence pour
cette engager cette réforme et
finalement c'est l'hypothèse dit-il
l'hypothèse la pire qui a été retenue
par le gouvernement vrai ou faux
alors pour moi c'est pas la pire c'est
pas la pierre
il prend il prend deux
paramètres le premier c'est qu'il
considère que la croissance des gains de
productivité sera à 0,7 % ce qui est en
contradiction avec la tendance des 30 40
50 dernières années dans les pays
occidentaux
donc de toute façon ce chiffre-là est en
déclin donc vous pouvez pas le prendre
comme constante dans les dans les années
qui viennent et le deuxième élément
c'est justement ce taux de chômage qui
est non pas artificiellement c'est que
on a adopté un thermomètre qui n'est pas
le même que celui qui était utilisé au
moment des trentes glorieuses et de tout
ce qui s'est passé donc en réalité oui
les hypothèses ne sont pas les bonnes et
à partir du moment où elles ne sont pas
les bonnes on est en train de faire du
rafistolage dont je suis certain qu'à
échéance alors est-ce que ces trois
quatre cinq six ans PAF il va falloir
refaire quelque chose qui sera un
emplâtre sur une jambe de bois
je dis non
de grâce de grâce n'insistons pas dans
une voie qui de toute façon ne règlera
pas le problème or moi j'aimerais que
l'on règle le problème alors c'est ce
que vous expliquez notamment et avec
bien d'autres choses
notamment vous revenez sur cette notion
d'inflexion dans ce livre demain la fin
de l'associance point d'interrogation
c'est aux éditions voilà c'est là c'est
aux éditions séché Mareuil édition et
puis vous aviez écrit un livre également
qui s'appelle l'opportunité du covid 19
c'était pas le covid-19 qui représentait
une opportunité mais c'était les
opportunités qui étaient son nez de
cette crise que vous détaillez également
chez Mareuil édition c'est votre
précédent ouvrage merci beaucoup merci
sur ce qui se passe et ce qui se dit sur
les réseaux sociaux avec l'excellente
Véronique reissoult de l'Institut
backbone backbone Consulting qui
cette semaine scrute pour Le Figaro avec
odoxa les réseaux sociaux et l'opinion
mais auparavant on va faire un tour
place de la Nation retrouver Timothée
délaime le cortège continue d'arriver
Timothée
oui tout à fait Vincent le cortège qui
continue d'arriver depuis le boulevard
Voltaire le second cortège qui
empruntait le boulevard du Temple et le
voir Beaumarchais est arrivé il y a un
certain temps maintenant le cortège
principal continue d'arriver ici voilà
ça se passe vraiment dans dans le calme
vous voyez ici les certains manifestants
qui sont allés mettre le drapeau
français en haut des statuts d'autres
improvisent quelques quelques danses sur
la pelouse de cette place de la Nation
d'autres encore sont en train tout
simplement et bien de rejoindre des
cafés et des bars ah bah sinon pour
aller prendre un verre voilà une une
manifestation qui est en train tout
doucement de ce terminer dans le calme
sous le regard attentif des forces de
l'ordre on aperçoit là-bas de nombreux
quarts de CRS qui ont évidemment bouclé
la place afin d'éviter toute voiture
bélier notamment voilà on va là-bas les
CRS qui ont malgré tout leur casque
voilà qui ont sorti leur casque donc ils
sont prêts à intervenir en cas de de
besoin pour l'instant c'est vrai que les
choses se sont en train de stagner un
petit peu ici on sent que la
manifestation est en train de prendre
fin tout doucement alors que le cortège
continue lui de d'arriver ici sur cette
place de la Nation
Timothée et bien on va continuer à
suivre tranquillement la fin de cette
mobilisation apparemment en tous les cas
il y a moins d'image de
heure et de tension qui nous parviennent
mais on continue de suivre ça en tous
les cas sur les flux que nous recevons
et on le voit bien au niveau de
l'ambiance qui est autour de vous
d'ailleurs je vous poserai une question
parce que il y a quelque chose qui me
frappe dans ces manifestations depuis le
début c'est que il y a pas de prise de
parole de notamment de prise de parole
syndicale à la fin de la fin de ces
manifestations peut-être que ça facilite
d'ailleurs la dispersion on verra ça
bonjour Véronique reissoult quel plaisir
de vous retrouver
ça faisait tellement longtemps que voilà
enfin bon ça me je suis heureux d'avoir
une preuve de vie et les internautes du
Figaro aussi est-ce que la mobilisation
contre la réforme domine la conversation
sur les réseaux ou bien les concurrences
c'est par le match France - Irlande qui
se passe pas très bien pour la France et
l'accident de Pierre Palmade
alors bon concurrencer oui mais c'est
pas les mêmes sujets c'est pas forcément
les mêmes intérêts
non c'est un vrai sujet de rugby
vraiment vrai sujet ça se termine mal et
c'est pas forcément un formidable sujet
en revanche la réforme c'est dans le
temps on en parle tout le temps
constamment il y a eu beaucoup de
conversations aussi sur les réseaux hier
et avant-hier et toute la semaine pour
s'organiser pour samedi qui est
d'ailleurs on envoie le résultat
aujourd'hui on a une mobilisation qui
est particulièrement forte dans les
régions en province dans les villes je
lissais l'ensemble des villes qui
publient des des images assez
impressionnantes parce que c'est une
autre des caractéristiques quand même
des réseaux sociaux c'est que il y a les
gens filment partagent sur Twitter sur
Facebook sur Tik Tok et c'est une sorte
de caléidoscope de présence un peu
partout sur les réseaux et donc
ça donne une réalité d'une mobilisation
forte vous avez des grandes villes des
petites villes des villes moyennes vous
avez tous les âges toutes les
professions toutes les situations donc
ça donne l'impression que la France
entière est mobilisée et la force de ces
images en direct ça parle quand vous
avez à Guéret par exemple près de 4000
personnes ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
pour Brioude en Haute-Loire 800
manifestants sur une une population de
7000 habitants alors bien sûr c'est pas
forcément tous des habitants de Brioude
qui manifestent
sur les réseaux hier encore tout le
monde s'organisait rendez-vous à talent
chez profond c'est ça que ça démontre
très profond vous avez enfin vous avez
je vous dis dans la Creuse à
Saint-Étienne à Pau à Nevers à Nancy à
Grenoble enfin les images sont assez
étonnantes à Reims et à chaque fois on
voit bon enfant est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est des images pardon
effectivement il y a rien de plus simple
que de de se filmer ou de photographier
de près ça c'est quand même tous les
vidéastes vous les prendront bon il y a
pas il y a pas il y a plus besoin d'être
un professionnel d'ailleurs pour le
savoir
et de faire un effet masse ou bien
est-ce que de votre expérience de
spécialistes et d'experts des réseaux
sociaux vous percevez un mouvement
d'ampleur et hors norme un mouvement
d'ampleur vraiment oui bien sûr quand
vous filmez d'abord quand vous êtes dans
une manifestation vous avez l'impression
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens donc quand ce
sont des témoignages de gens qui sont
sur le terrain forcément c'est pas que
ils veulent amplifier c'est qu'ils ont
une perception qui est c'est important
les images bien sûr on peut les changer
on peut les modifier enfin partons du
principe que quand même tous les
Français qui ont filmé cet après-midi ne
sont pas des spécialistes des images
donc on a souvent des champs où on voit
bien la réalité et c'est surtout la
proportion par rapport aux populations
locales et c'est le nombre de
manifestations qui est un sujet et les
profils des gens qui sont en train de
manifester donc on peut dire que c'est
un mouvement d'ampleur après l'autre
sujet c'est quand on regardait ce qu'ils
échangeaient pourquoi ils vont
manifester pourquoi ils ont tellement
envie d'aller manifester je vais revenir
sur cette question là
mais déjà par rapport à la manifestation
va voir des images d'ailleurs de ce qui
se passe à Paris voilà merci beaucoup on
en laisse de nous les montrer comme ça
en direct un c'est l'arrivée place de la
Nation dans le 12e arrondissement de
Paris
question comment ça se mobilise sur les
réseaux par rapport à cette
manifestation par rapport à toutes ces
manifestations alors je vous l'avais dit
on fait part de ce qui se passe
il y a des comment justement ça se joint
si je puis dire à cette manifestation
alors ça ça te joint parce qu'en fait
c'est la somme de tous ces lives
qui sont partagés sur les réseaux et qui
donne un cahier de scope de plein plein
d'images avec à chaque fois le nom des
villes avec à chaque fois des
témoignages de personnes qui racontent
c'est fou il y a voilà beaucoup de gens
aussi qui expriment qui n'ont jamais
manifesté avant donc en fait ça donne
une ampleur par la somme de toutes ces
petites vignettes qui sont partagées un
peu partout après il y a une autre
réalité c'était les échanges et les
discussions qu'il y avait hier encore où
les gens ont envie de manifester en bas
de chez eux pour plein de raisons la
première c'est que Paris c'est parfois
loin c'est cher de venir à Paris donc
c'est une manifestation les gens n'ont
pas envie de dépenser de l'argent en soi
ensuite à Paris ils ont un peu peur de
manifester parce qu'ils ont peur de
prendre des amandes où ils ont peur
qu'il y ait des violences ils ont
l'impression que quand c'est en bas de
chez eux c'est plus bonne enfant et
c'est plus simple et puis c'est aussi
tout simplement plus simple concrètement
en termes de logistique que d'aller à
quelques kilomètres de chez vous plutôt
que à quelques centaines de kilomètres
mais par contre les gens étaient très
motivés pour participer et c'est pas que
contre la grève contre les retraites
c'est alors on va voir sur les motifs il
y a quelque chose de très intéressant
dans tout ce que vous racontez c'est que
finalement généralement quand on a une
manifestation nationale avec plusieurs
mobilisations en région ça c'est la
spécialité des syndicats et de la gauche
généralement finalement il y a que Paris
qui compte au final on dit il y a tant
de manifestants dans toute la France etc
c'est comme ça qui compte beaucoup et
mais en réalité avec le phénomène
réseaux sociaux cette dichotomie et
cette cette domination de parisienne et
et et et complètement tombe et il y a il
y a finalement ça fait phénomène quoi ça
fait phénomène alors ça fait déjà été un
petit peu le cas pendant les gilets
jaunes mais comme les les manifestations
avaient fini par évoluer ils essayaient
de se regrouper de façon plus massive
dans les grandes villes et en
particulier à Paris mais là c'est envoyé
bien même les consignes étaient restons
sur place et faisons des photos et
partageons-les et donc oui ça fait corps
et quand vous avez une page entière où
vous avez des vignettes de plus de 15
villes où on voit des manifestations et
on voit des des défilés et en plus
souvent avec des chorégraphies enfin une
très bonne enfant oui ça donne le
sentiment que la France entière et que
toutes les catégories françaises sont
dans la rue alors est-ce que c'est pas
un miroir déformant si forcément parce
que vous avez pas la totalité des gens
des Français qui sont dans la rue ce qui
n'est pas déformant c'est que quand on
va manifester en bas de chez soi un
samedi qu'on retrouve des gens et que on
a partagé cette motivation ben oui c'est
une réalité d'une préoccupation là où
c'est clairement c'est qu'effectivement
quand vous êtes je reprends l'exemple de
Guéret parce que c'est quand même une
petite ville dans la Creuse il y avait
quand même beaucoup de manifestants
préfecture certes je ne sais pas le
nombre d'habitants je vous avoue à la
base mais
il y avait je pense que Guéret c'est
comme fois c'est comme d'autres communes
comme Aubenas ce ne sont pas les
forcément des à l'origine ça a été des
préfets La Roche-sur-Yon ça a été des
préfectures qui ont été après la
Révolution française donc qui sont quand
même plus petites que les que les villes
importantes de ces sont pas des villes
où on a l'habitude de manifester et
c'est en cela que c'est très
représentatif vous avez pas enfin je
pense pas qu'elle Guéret il y a des
manifestations très régulièrement là
tout d'un coup vous allez trouver dans
la rue même si ça n'est pas toute la
population même si c'est un petit nombre
de personnes c'est quand même
extrêmement symbolique et significatif
quand même des régions qui sont plutôt à
gauche qui ont une tradition quand même
effectivement il y en a à droite aussi
franchement alors Nantes Lyon Brest
Marseille Montpellier
Édouard Philippe Lemaire le la question
précisément c'est que vous
vous souvenez et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant de voir c'est que ce n'est
pas une mobilisation simplement contre
la réforme des retraites et ça n'est pas
non plus une mobilisation contre
Emmanuel Macron simplement non plus et
son gouvernement c'est globalement une
envie de d'exprimer une forme de
mécontentement c'est aussi le sentiment
que maladie augmente que les choses sont
de plus en plus compliquées et de dire
mais c'est difficile et donc c'est c'est
un mélange plein de choses même si bien
sûr c'est un sujet retraite et sur
retraite c'est un sujet départ à la
retraite l'âge est un point de blocage
fort c'est pas la réforme elle-même qui
est remise en question pour une grande
majorité et on va retrouver tout à
l'instant Timothée délai
Timothée alors je vois les images
il me semblait que vous étiez avec une
manifestante ouh là là vous êtes même
avec une militante je dis ouh là là
parce que c'est une un beau drapeau du
Nouveau parti anticapitaliste le parti
d'Olivier Besancenot
absolument Vincent avec militante du
nouveau parti handicapitaliste qui me
confie à l'instant que donc vous êtes
professeur de d'anglais en collège
la manifestation pour vous aujourd'hui
vous étiez de des trois autres
manifestations également qu'est-ce que
vous reprochez à cette réforme bon la
prochaine ma première chose que je
reprends je suis en fait c'est qu'ils
veulent nous faire travailler plus
aujourd'hui en fait quand on voit que
les plus pauvres ils arrivent même pas à
toucher leur retraite je trouve que
c'est profondément dégueulasse en fait
on va pas encore refaire une autre
réforme pour nous faire travailler de
plus en plus c'est 64 60 têtes 67 ans
moi j'ai 30 ans imaginons dans 40 ans le
contenu nombre de réformes qu'on va
avoir aujourd'hui on refuse cette
réforme mais je pense qu'il y a plus que
juste cette réforme aujourd'hui tous ces
tout ce monde dans sa rue c'est pas que
la réforme des retraites quand on voit
depuis la covid les salaires les
licenciements l'inflation les prix qui
augmentent bah je pense qu'on voit un
vrai ras-le-bol de de la politique de
Macron mais franchement le gouvernement
général et tout ce système qui va avec
et là je pense qu'on voit qu'on voit
franchement il y a plein de joie dans la
rue aujourd'hui mais tous les autres
manifs et je trouve ça ça donne un bol
d'air frais quand tout le mécontentement
et toute la la franchement la dure vie
que les gens vivent aujourd'hui et donc
la réforme des retraites je pensais
c'est le bout de l'iceberg qui émerge
aujourd'hui mais il y a plein de choses
que les gens sont en colère contre c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui revient
beaucoup lorsqu'on interroge des
manifestants en fait vous ne manifestez
pas simplement contre la réforme des
retraites c'est la mesure symbolique
mais c'est un ensemble de ras-le-bol que
vous exprimez aujourd'hui mais c'est un
ras-le-bol parce que bon on peut prendre
la réforme des retraites on nous dit que
le système par répartition il y a pas
assez d'argent il y a un déficit
franchement je me rappelle plus des
chiffres Emmanuel Macron lui dit cette
réforme elle est essentielle si on veut
sauvé notre réforme notre système pardon
par répartition qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous moi je pense que cette
réforme elle est on peut dire que il y a
une réforme qui est essentielle il faut
plus d'argent il faut augmenter les
pensions mais il faut augmenter les
salaires si on augmente les salaires à
2000 euros comme on demande bah
peut-être il y aurait plus d'argent pour
les retraites et franchement quand on
dit qu'il y a pas d'argent pour moi
c'est un mensonge ce n'est pas vrai il y
a de l'argent qu'on augmente de 400
milliards le budget de l'armée on peut
pas dire qu'il y a pas de l'argent c'est
juste en priorise l'armée en priorise la
police versus les personnes la retraite
les salaires et les augmentations on
s'entend de moins en moins ici parce que
le cortège continue d'arriver sur cette
sur cette place de la Nation pour
l'instant je ne sais pas si vous
m'entendez encore je vais tenter de
poser une dernière question à cette
manifestante qui est là aujourd'hui
sur la suite du mouvement quelle forme
doit prendre selon vous ce mouvement à
l'avenir pour la forme qu'il faut que ça
prend il faut qu'on la durcisse on voit
que en fait quatre jours il y a de plus
en plus de monde il y a plus en plus de
colère mais qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas une
journée par semaine c'est pas deux jours
même dans une semaine là il faut qu'on
parte en reconductible il faut que tous
et tout ensemble qu'on se saisisse de la
grève de la RATP qui est pas appelé à
partir du 7 mars il y a le 8 mars cette
réforme elle touche majoritairement les
femmes et que on utilise ces deux jours
et qu'on dise on y va à partir de là en
2019 on a gagné contre la répartition la
retraite à points mais c'est parce qu'il
y avait une grève reconductible dans la
RATP dans toutes les vraies formes qu'on
a gagné toutes les avancées sociaux
qu'on a gagné dans ce pays et partout
c'est par la grève et par la grève
générale et reconductible et c'est ça
qu'on œuvre aujourd'hui vous pensez
qu'il faut bloquer le pays oui il faut
bloquer le pays mais c'est pas un
blocage un blocage de l'économie mais en
fait pourquoi ces plantes pas nous c'est
ceux qui gagnent de l'argent aujourd'hui
ceux qui font l'argent c'est sur notre
travail et donc en fait c'est ça qu'on
bloque aujourd'hui on bloque l'économie
parce que c'est notre force c'est la
force des travailleurs c'est la force
des travailleurs aujourd'hui pour dire
on arrête on veut plus d'argent quand on
voit que Bernard Arnault l'air total
tout ça les milliards qu'ils ont ils
dégagent de milliards et ben nous on
veut plus on veut un salaire avant 2000
€ en allant vers l'éventuelle blocage du
mouvement est-ce que vous n'avez pas
peur que cela finisse par lasser les
Français moi je pense que en fait ce
qu'il a la France pardon ouais bien sûr
moi je pense que ce qui là en fait les
Français majoritairement et pas que les
Français les personnes qui habitent ici
qui ont pas de papier en fait ce qui là
c'est de en fait de travailler de plus
en plus dur pour moi en moins de salaire
et de pas avoir une retraite c'est ça
qui laisse les Français et c'est vrai
que moi ce que je pense qu'il a c'est
les Français c'est faire une journée
par-ci une journée par là et qu'en fait
le gouvernement il arrive à à trouver
des solutions pour aller à contre la
grève mais aujourd'hui il faut qu'on y
aille tous et toutes ensemble et c'est
ça je pense ça donnera une
par Nicole qui dit il y a pas beaucoup
de monde autour de vous mais c'est
peut-être justement du fait que les gens
arrivent et
finalement Timothée nous a nous
abandonné donc c'est pas grave il
reviendra ben oui
il faut quand même il y a encore calme
direct à faire donc on verra après dans
tous les cas effectivement elle est bien
au frais dans le président merci
beaucoup à Timothée donc je pense Nicole
que vous avez peut-être la réponse à
votre question en tout cas votre
observation dans ce que vous disiez
peut-être qu'on va revoir les images oui
il y a moins de peut-être il y a pas
autant de monde mais parce que c'est la
fin et donc que les personnes s'en vont
parce que à la fin de cette
manifestation en tous les cas à Paris il
y a pas de prise de parole il y a pas de
leaders qui qui sont sur les estrade on
va revenir sur ce qu'on vient d'entendre
parce que Timothée disait c'est un point
de vue tranché d'un autre côté il y a
quelque chose qu'on entend quand même
depuis le début de l'après-midi à
travers les personnes qui sont venues
analyser qui sont pas des militantes du
Nouveau parti anticapitaliste et il y a
quelque chose quand même qui sert de
continuum et que l'on voit également
dans les forum du Figaro dans le chat du
Figaro qui est pas un chat GPT s'il y a
des vrais personnes qui parlent et qui
disent que c'est autour de pouvoir vivre
de son travail il y a vraiment un
malaise et derrière le discours militant
derrière le discours revendiqué derrière
les revendications il y avait quand même
cette ce message là dans chez cette
détente avait après des propos et des
solutions qui étaient très militantes
mais par contre oui
en tout cas très enfin voilà très en
ligne avec la réalité de son nouveau
parti en revanche les constats qu'elle
faisait
sont partagés par plein de français et
qui et qui sont effectivement parmi les
motivations des Français qui sont dans
la rue aujourd'hui et ceux qui ne sont
pas en dans la rue aussi parce qu'il
faut vous dire qu'il y a des gens qui
manifestent pas mais qui manifeste d'une
autre façon soit enseignant des
pétitions soit on s'exprimant sur les
réseaux soit en relayant des messages
sur les réseaux soit en s'exprimant sur
sur des boucles globalement vous avez
une forme ce que je vous disais de
mécontentements qui dépassent bien
largement le sujet de la réforme des
retraites d'autant que quand on regarde
de façon majoritaire les Français sont
conscients qu'il faut une réforme des
retraites les deux sujets qui passent
pas c'est tout d'abord l'âge pivot
là c'est l'âge de départ à l'âge légal
de départ pardon mais pourquoi ça quel
est pourquoi cette crise pottant ça
crisse parce qu'en fait
la réalité aujourd'hui du départ à la
retraite on est plus on est plus on est
plus
c'est une affaire de six mois parce que
aujourd'hui la plupart des gens quand
vous allez partir à la retraite dans 6
mois et qu'on vous rajoute 6 mois tout
d'un coup comme ça il y a le sentiment
de on aurait peut-être pu anticiper donc
les gens c'est pas les générations qui
partent aujourd'hui à la retraite qui
sont encore concernés il y en a
quelques-uns ça joue parce que c'est des
témoignages qu'on entend et donc ça
imprime vous avez un autre sujet qui est
les femmes c'est pas six mois ces deux
ans et donc ça imprime aussi vous avez
une réalité un peu moins pour les femmes
qui ont tout leur trimestre oui mais
c'est un peu plus dans les faits parce
que effectivement ce sont des sommes de
symboles donc en fait sur ces symboles
si vous répondez ah ça va c'est 8 mois
non c'est pas oh ça va c'est huit mois
c'est huit mois c'est
et puis l'autre chose c'est que comme on
a cette jeune femme l'a rappelé l'argent
magique on a entendu beaucoup de sommes
les gens ne comprennent pas forcément
les l'urgences là et le fait qu'on ne
puisse pas se poser sur d'autres
solutions qui sont souvent évoquées et
par les Français et qu'on entend peu sur
à l'assemblée qui sont des sujets sur
travailler booster dans une semaine ou
payer plus de cotisations enfin
globalement il y a la compréhension du
fait que nous devons réformer
l'incompréhension sur la formule
actuelle et vient se greffer à ça une
réalité de c'est quoi le travail c'est
quoi la valeur travail comment on est
payé comment est-ce que on doit
fonctionner donc tout avec en plus une
inflation qui fait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué pour les gens et donc tout ça
cumuler fait que les gens ont envie
d'exprimer une forme de mécontentement
et qui n'est pas forcément que à
l'encontre de Monsieur Macron
contrairement à cette jeune femme
comment
est-ce qu'on parle là sur les réseaux à
l'heure actuelle de on parle de réussite
pour cette journée de manifestation oui
mais ce qui était compliqué enfin voilà
si vous regardez les militants oui si
vous regardez les politiques de
l'opposition et les syndicalistes oui là
où c'est plus révélateur c'est de
regarder le nombre de partage justement
des images en province et tous les
commentaires où les gens disent c'est
incroyable quand même il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui sont
sur le terrain dans les petites et
moyennes villes donc c'est un succès
pour ça
un succès donc pour la mobilisation dans
ce qu'on appelle les petites villes dans
ce qu'on doit appeler autrefois la
France d'emba je suis sûr que ça va
inspirer Arnaud benediti qui va
intervenir juste juste après vous
comment sont traités
Elisabeth pardon Véronique
justement les dernières sorties
d'Élisabeth borne pardon de se la pile
dessus c'est le premier
sorties d'Élisabeth borne et d'Emmanuel
Macron alors c'est plus madame borne qui
incarne la réforme que Emmanuel Macron
paradoxalement pour le moment d'ailleurs
les codes de popularité sont et leur
progression diminution plus exactement
sera à cette image elle incarne cette
réforme après elle le fait qu'elle ne
cède pas
n'étonne pas elle est critiquée
critiquée sur le fait bien qu'elle a
quand même beaucoup changé et l'ensemble
du gouvernement sur les arguments qu'ils
mettaient en avant et dans les données
qu'on pouvait constater cette semaine il
y avait une incompréhension de plus en
plus importante des Français sur le vrai
contenu de la loi puisqu'on entend des
choses très contradictoires bien sûr
entre le gouvernement et les oppositions
mais même sur les oppositions
elles-mêmes ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
aux sorties de cette semaine madame
borne était cornée mais les parties
d'opposition aussi en fait la réalité
c'est le politique globalement qui n'est
plus très suivie
commençons justement traiter les débats
à l'Assemblée
en fait
on peut pas dire que si commenté que ça
j'étais étonné par exemple la polémique
hier de monsieur porte oui ça fait un
pic de 25000 messages jusqu'à
le député qui s'est affiché sur Twitter
en se vantant de jouer avec un au
football avec un ballon portant
l'effigie de Olivier du soft ce qui lui
a valu 15 jours d'explosion de
l'assemblée de l'Assemblée nationale
beaucoup de bruit à l'Assemblée mais les
Français sont pas sur Twitter donc si
les médias et l'assemblée on n'avaient
pas autant parlé les politiques n'en
avaient pas autant parler de Ré sans
doute pas vu ensuite pour eux ils
considèrent que les débats ne sont pas à
la hauteur de ce qu'ils veulent en
particulier et le ils attendent
que l'on commence à parler de l'âge donc
c'est leur impatience après ils sont
moins choqués que les politiques et les
médias leçons c'était pour eux voilà il
y a toujours eu une forme de bruit et de
spectacle à l'Assemblée c'est
particulièrement fort là
c'est surtout un sujet qui est suivi en
direct par les militants et par les
partisans Monsieur et Madame français
qui ne suit pas la politique au
quotidien ça les intéresse moins mais on
ne peut pas dire là encore c'est la même
chose que ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure mais ça ne renforce pas la
confiance qu'ils sont dans les
politiques c'est il y a un côté bon
voilà
comment réagit-on il y a 6 mois en
octobre un sondage montré que 59% des
non retraités un sondage holoxa bac
bonne Consulting publié par Le Figaro
n'avait pas confiance dans le système
des retraites mais qu'est-ce que sont
devenus ces défiants aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est en train de les perdre
entre autres pour la raison que je vous
évoquais comme les arguments et le
contenu de de cette loi non pas arrêté
de fluctuer tout le monde comprend pas
toujours ce qu'il y a derrière et
finissent par se dire en fait très bien
soutenir une réforme et réformée oui
mais quelle réforme donc c'est pas
fondamentalement que les Français ne
veulent pas réformer le système des
retraites c'est il ne comprennent plus
ce qu'il y a dans cette loi et ne
comprennent plus l'urgence et ne
comprennent plus parce qu'en plus on
annonce des chiffres en disant bah voilà
on a fait des cadeaux les Français ne
conservent pas comme des cadeaux mais il
y a eu des évolutions dans la loi qui
fait que finalement on économisera que
10 milliards et à côté vous avez
entendre qu'une société fait des supers
profits avec 20 milliards donc ça n'a
plus de sens l'ensemble de ces messages
donc vous les avez pas perdu juste ils
sont en train de se poser la question de
à quoi bon et surtout qu'est-ce que
cette réforme est-ce qu'on croit quand
même effectivement encore que le système
peut tenir en l'état
il y a quelques arguments qui ont plutôt
fait mouches c'est assez étonnant que ça
n'ait pas été plus suivi nous vivons de
plus en plus longtemps nous avons de
moins en moins d'enfants il y a une
réalité qui est l'équilibre ne peut pas
tenir ainsi après les solutions qui ont
été proposées ne séduisent pas et la
réalité c'est que il y a eu tellement de
données contradictoires que ben là
encore on a perdu tout le monde
en l'état actuel de votre point de vue
au regard de ce que vous observez sur
les réseaux sociaux le gouvernement
a-t-il pu s'intérêt à maintenir ou à
reculer
je me tiendrai bien leur donner ce
conseil mais
effectivement chez vous c'est ils sont
plutôt rémunérés donc
très sincèrement la journée du Salvat
est assez déterminante mais les Français
sont quand même très remontés mais c'est
un sujet de mécontentement tellement là
que que tout retirer maintenant serait
compliqué c'est sans doute quelques
adaptations qui vont être quand même
nécessaires quelques signes forts pour
dire oui on vous entend et on vous voit
comment réagit-on à l'idée
alors que on voit que des premiers
chiffres qui sont donnés également par
le fil data un record battu à Paris et à
93000 manifestants c'était 80000 le 31
janvier 87
lors de la seconde mobilisation et 57000
vendre mardi dernier donc effectivement
là c'est une mobilisation semble-t-il
jamais atteinte depuis le début de cette
séquence et depuis le début de cette
manifestation à Paris selon nos
estimations et ça n'est que Paris et ça
n'est que Paris et donc effectivement on
risque d'avoir un succès de mobilisation
si on observe ce qui se passait
également dans le reste dans le reste du
pays il faut avoir un petit peu c'est ce
que disait Arthur bijouta du fil Delta
aussi ça donnait dans les grandes
métropoles régionales apparemment
c'était plus fort à Toulouse mais moins
fort par exemple à Nice ou à Strasbourg
donc on va voir il y a aussi des une
petite ville qui vont pas être prises en
compte et qui n'étaient pas speneurs
donc l'un dans l'autre enfin voilà
l'ensemble de ces mobilisations je pense
était plus importante quand même que
vous avez finalement répondu à ma
question apparemment c'est plutôt une
réussite en tout cas sur une réussite
c'est plutôt la enfin voilà les gens ont
le sentiment que ils étaient nombreux
que ils sont pas entendus parce qu'il y
a une autre donnée dans les sondages que
nous avons réalisé pour vous depuis
quelques semaines qu'elle est française
se disent est-ce qu'ils vont bouger ou
pas ce qui est certain c'est que pour le
moment dans tous les Français dont nous
parlons qui sont dans la rue on met de
côté les syndicalistes et et les
militants ils pensent pas que le
gouvernement va reculer il ne pense pas
que le gouvernement c'est un atout pour
le gouvernement quelque part ça veut pas
dire qu'ils sont d'accord avec le fait
qu'il ne sert pas mais il ne pense pas
donc en fait
au gouvernement de tenir la carte de la
fermeté par celui de la cohérence oui
mais après ils aimeraient qu'il y ait
quelques inflexions ils aimeraient plus
de clarté mais il ne pense pas que ils
vont retirer voire même pour beaucoup il
pense que ça passera avec un 49-3 au
pire et donc voilà d'où le nombre de
slogans d'ailleurs que vous voyez dans
les manifestations autour du 49-3 avec
des jeux de mots parfois assez amusants
certes c'est ma dernière question
puisque la prochaine bon une prochaine
mobilisation donc jeudi on sera en
direct
également bien entendu pour vous faire
vivre ça mais il y en a une surtout le 7
mars avec un appel au blocage du pays
même des plus appels reliés même par les
plus modérés s'il y a une Chabanier tout
à l'heure le patron de la CFTC
est-ce que
comment ça réagit justement par rapport
à ces menaces de blocage de grève
retombe conductibles ce qu'il faut
croire à ce chiffre et qui paraît quand
même étonnant que finalement 70% des
Français seraient favorables au blocage
il y a plein de données qui ont changé
par rapport aux autres grèves et aux
autres manifestations qu'il y a eu dans
le temps la première c'est le
télétravail on ne le dit jamais assez
mais c'est une réalité qui a on
appréhende pas cette journée là de la
même façon
ensuite les Français quand c'est un
samedi comme cela s'est passé
aujourd'hui et bien la les commerces
continuent à travailler il y a pas de
violence ça se passe dans un climat qui
fait que on ne bloque pas totalement la
France donc ils vont plutôt soutenir
salle de jeudi c'est un autre sujet et
ensuite dans l'état dans l'esprit des
Français si on est bloqué ça ne sera pas
la faute des syndicalistes ça ne sera
pas la faute des Français ça sera la
faute du gouvernement donc c'est pour ça
que la situation est un peu de bascule
merci beaucoup Véronique d'avoir répondu
à toutes ces questions et nous avoir
donné le pouls la météo des réseaux
sociaux on suit bien sûr tous les toutes
les semaines les chiffres et les
résultats des sondages que vous faites
avec codoxa pour le pour Le Figaro et
bien sûr on renvoie vers le site de
backbone avec tous les index les suivis
c'est absolument passionnants on va
retrouver Timothée délai et Elisabeth
Pierson une autre journaliste du Figaro
qui
qui sont en direct avec nous et voilà
oui ils sont devant la caméra et donc
ils vont commencer à vous parler ils se
parlent entre eux mais ils vont
commencer à vous parler aussi Timothée
vous avez la parole
c'est en train de me prendre ok il me
lance
oui Vincent avec Isabelle Pirson du
service actuels du Figaro Elisabeth
bonsoir vous avez suivi comme nous ce
cortège parisien la CGT revendique 500
000 personnes aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'il y avait du monde dans les rues de
Paris vous qui avez suivi
le cortège lors des précédents de
manifestations est-ce que vous avez à
vue de nez à vue d'oeil comme ça c'est
difficile à dire mais vous diriez qu'il
y avait plus moins de monde alors à vue
d'oeil bien sûr on attend les chiffres
pour Paris à vue d'oeil il a foule était
quand même nettement moins dense que les
dernières fois je me souviens notamment
de la toute première mobilisation qui
partait qui empruntait le même chemin
donc de République à Nation et où la
foule était tellement dense que on avait
du mal à se mouvoir à aller d'un
trottoir à l'autre là c'était beaucoup
plus clairsemé ce qui peut être trompeur
c'est qu'il y avait deux itinéraires il
y a eu un itinéraire bis qui est passé
par le boulevard De Beaumarchais donc
peut-être que c'est lié à ça mais en
parlant avec deux ou trois autres
manifestants
était très étonné de voir que le samedi
n'a pas forcément généré plus de
mobilisation à vue d'oeil en tout cas
quel était l'atmosphère générale que
vous de votre côté vous avez vous avez
remarqué c'est vrai que nous on était
avec Julien Leclerc on est resté sur ce
boulevard Voltaire vous vous êtes allé
également au niveau du boulevard
Beaumarchais qu'est-ce que vous avez vu
est-ce que l'ambiance était plutôt calme
est-ce qu'il y a eu des scènes de
tension comme nous avons pu le constater
sur le boulevard Voltaire même si cela
restait assez disparate qu'est-ce que
vous avez vu de votre côté alors le
l'itinéraire bis boulevard De
Beaumarchais il était complètement calme
seulement des syndicats voilà ambiance
très bon enfant de la musique
en fait ce qu'on voit depuis le début
c'est que les manifestants qui qui
créent les tensions sont un petit
groupuscule qui est toujours plutôt à
l'avant du cortège là c'est ce qu'on
sait ce qui s'est passé encore cette
fois-ci on les reconnaît aisément et on
voit qu'ils veulent en découdre et ils
sont vraiment une grande minorité enfin
une toute petite minorité et tout le
reste du cortège les cortèges syndicaux
sont très calmes et très très joyeux et
le fait que la manifestation se passait
un samedi on a vu c'est vrai beaucoup
plus de familles des enfants notamment
et ça c'est intéressant de voir une ou
deux familles avec qui j'ai discuté
était là pour la première fois même de
leur vie manifester pour la première
fois de leur vie avec les enfants tout
excité et voilà l'ambiance était
d'autant plus familiale par ce côté-là
vous me disiez juste avant que nous ne
soyons à l'antenne que vous avez
également croisé des élus et en
particulier des élus de la France
insoumise oui tout à fait il y a
toujours un petit groupe de
d'élus et d'élus de la France insoumise
qui sont sur le côté à acclamer et à
encourager les manifestants donc à ma
petite pano mano Aubry tout celles qu'on
connaît avec Clémentine Autain etc et là
cette fois-ci elles avaient elles
avaient une petite un petit groupe
d'enfants devant elle qui scandale leur
slogan et on voit bien que la la nuque à
chercher à communiquer sur la présence
de ses enfants et à dire voyez c'est les
générations qui manifestent pour leur
réforme des traites parce que ça les
concerne on a bien vu que les le côté
enfant était au cœur de la de la
communication d'ailleurs les syndicats
disaient aussi au micro les enfants ils
invitaient les enfants à aller à l'avant
de du cortège pour bien les voir pour
bien les mettre en évidence donc voilà
ils étaient clairement au cœur de la
communication vous êtes arrivés un petit
peu avant nous sur cette place de la
Nation vous confirmez comme nous que la
manifestation est en train petit à petit
de se terminer dans une ambiance
finalement assez calme oui je pense
sauf problème majeur mais je pense que
ça va se terminer assez calmement là les
policiers ont très bien géré les les je
pourrais de tout à l'heure à l'arrivée à
Nation à mon avis ça va ça va se
distiller tranquillement merci beaucoup
Elisabeth person du service actuels du
Figaro voilà Vincent pour ce qu'on
pouvait vous dire sur ce récapitulatif
d'Elisabeth de cette journée vous
l'entendez peut-être des manifestants
qui commencent à chanter on est là on
est là voilà c'est un de ces champs que
l'on entend régulièrement lors de ces
manifestations alors que la nuit
commence à tomber sur cette place de la
Nation c'est un champ de ralliement même
du mouvement des gilets jaunes
et qu'on entendait effectivement
beaucoup lors de cette mobilisation
merci beaucoup Timothée on vous retrouve
dans un quart d'heure 20 minutes pour
faire la le point et la conclusion de
cette journée mais on a des nouveaux
chiffres qui nous parviennent bonsoir
Arnaud Benedetti dit bonsoir en fait
encore vous dire bonjour à aller dans un
quart d'heure on se dira bonsoir à la
fin de ce duplex 93.000 manifestants à
Paris selon la police un record depuis
le début de la mobilisation c'est ce que
on affiche en tous les cas sur le live
texte qui est en dessous de ce player
visiblement avec tous les indicateurs
on vous avez des éléments pour répondre
à ma question est-ce une réussite
l'objectif de toute façon l'objectif des
syndicats c'était de choisir un week-end
pour justement amplifier les
mobilisations et manifestement tous les
chiffres qui remontent depuis ce matin
et cet après-midi notamment montre que
un peu partout les mobilisations
semblent hausse à Paris vous venez de le
rappeler puisque c'est les chiffres
manifestement de la police que vous avez
l'estimations qu'on a des estimations de
la police mais les estimations pas
encore celle de la police
ça vient effectivement notamment de la
préfecture mais voilà c'est donc on est
on est par rapport au 19 janvier 765
000 pardon au niveau national à cette
heure là ce qui est plus que mardi
dernier donc ce qui est plus évidemment
que mardi dernier mais ça c'était
prévisible le plus important c'est que
ça soit plus que finalement les deux
journées précédentes et notamment la
journée du 19 janvier qui j'allais dire
l'étape inaugural du mouvement donc tous
les chiffres qui remontent qu'il
s'agissent des chiffres parisiens des
chiffres des grandes métropoles de
province ou des chiffres et c'est ça
peut-être qu'il faudra analyser de près
des villes moyennes ou même parfois des
sous-préfectures et des petites villes
montrent que il y a eu une mobilisation
en hausse assez intense et qui fait que
les syndicats se soir peuvent considérer
que ils ont en partie réussi leur pari
de la mobilisation et qui plus est une
mobilisation qui pour l'instant en tout
cas semble s'être déroulée d'après les
images que nous avons à Paris plutôt
dans le calme alors pour être très
précis donc effectivement c'est les
93.000 manifestants à Paris selon la
police c'est bien un chiffre qui vient
de la préfecture
on n'a pas encore à l'heure où on se
parle dépasser le fameux million qui
était
qui est l'objectif encore de Laurent
Berger il faudra sans doute attendre
encore un peu pour savoir si cet
objectif a été pleinement on verra on
verra dans la soirée plus précisément ce
qui est le plus important je pense enfin
il y a deux facteurs qui me paraissent
importants d'abord il y a le fait que
pour l'instant le front syndical reste
unique et que le France syndical
si vous voulez finalement c'est un
phénomène qui depuis 10 ans n'était pas
arrivé et que clairement pour l'instant
la CFDT reste arrimé et même déterminé
dans le mouvement les déclarations de
Monsieur berger ne font pas
véritablement
preuve de beaucoup d'ambiguïté c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire et montre une
une détermination à vouloir poursuivre
le mouvement dans les dans les semaines
qui viennent alors après il y aura
peut-être vraisemblablement
éventuellement s'il y a des j'allais
dire des des
différences qui s'expriment entre
syndicats ça s'appuie tout sur les
modalités d'action puisque sur
l'objectif mais apparemment ce que l'on
croit comprendre en tout
cet après-midi c'est que on réfléchit à
une journée d'action commune le 7 mars
prochain et avec la possibilité de de
mode de blocage dans un certain nombre
d'administrations notamment donc on a on
a une certaine façon un mouvement qui
prépare l'opinion publique a
éventuellement des modes d'action plus
plus difficiles
c'est en tout cas ce qui essaye
manifestement aujourd'hui de de monter
le mouvement syndical la question
l'autre question qu'il faut se poser
c'est c'est le soutien d'opinion
publique et manifestement depuis
maintenant le début de ce mouvement le
soutien de l'opinion publique et est
important et fort il y a une hostilité
marquée à cette réforme de la retraite
et alors l'autre aspect sur lequel je
voudrais insister qui me paraît
extrêmement important c'est quand même
la mobilisation dans les petites villes
et dans les villes moyennes qui n'est
pas sans rappeler si vous voulez la
sociologie de ce que déjà connu il y a 4
ans au moment du mouvement des gilets
jaunes il y a là quelque part quelque
chose qui en effet est assez frappant
depuis le début du mouvement pas
spécifiquement aujourd'hui depuis le 19
janvier on voit que dans un certain
nombre de villes moyennes de
sous-préfecture ou de préfecture de
département il y a des mobilisations qui
et sont très importantes et que l'on a
pas vu depuis très longtemps dans ces
dans ces villes et dans ces petites
villes est-ce que
est-ce que vous pensez que finalement
les syndicats vont réussir à faire ce
qu'elles n'ont pas ce qu'ils n'ont pas
réussi à faire avec
au moment du mouvement des gilets jaunes
c'est-à-dire de entre guillemets de
capter en tout cas de de Ré attirer
c'est c'est manifestants c'est ces
gilets jaunes et les et de les enrôler
finalement dans leur dans leur dans leur
combat dans leur mouvance d'abord le
mouvement des gilets jaunes c'était un
mouvement qui s'est fait en dehors des
syndicats il faut le rappeler un
mouvement c'est un mouvement sans les
syndicats mais dans les mouvements des
gilets jaunes si vous voulez il y a eu
plusieurs phases il y a la première
phase qui était la grosse phase de
mobilisation celle du de novembre et
décembre 2018 c'était véritablement là
pour le coup la France périphérique des
gens qui ne s'étaient parfois jamais
engagés en politique qui manifestait un
ras-le-bol par rapport évidemment à la
hausse de la taxe carbone mais au fait
qu'un certain nombre de territoires qui
étaient ce qu'on appelle les territoires
périphériques
voyez finalement une quelque chose de
désaménagement de leur territoire
s'accentuer depuis maintenant des
décennies est-ce que ces catégories
j'allais dire social qui était parfois
des des artisans des commerçants aussi
au tout début sont susceptibles de
s'agréger au mouvement ça je ne sais pas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'en tout cas ce
qu'on vous constate c'est que les
territoires ou les gilets jaunes ont été
très actifs au début sont toujours en
tout cas mobilisés dans ce mouvement et
que de ce point de vue les syndicats en
disant un combustible qui est un
combustible au delà de l'hostilité à la
réforme des retraites qui est le
combustible de la situation économique
et des tensions inflationnistes qui
peuvent évidemment amener des gens à
s'agréger à ce mouvement alors c'est la
question finalement est-ce que
on ne s'oriente pas vers un basculement
des causes ça part pour l'instant de la
du refus de la réforme de la
du système d'air retraites mais est-ce
que
on risque pas d'avoir enfin dans tous
les cas est-ce que ça s'orient pas vers
un basculement vers justement une
dénonciation de la vie chère de
l'inflation des problématiques de
pouvoir d'achat on entendait quand même
beaucoup cet après-midi de gens dire
mais moi je veux vivre de mon travail
d'une vie décente oui si vous voulez
c'est que en fait que la réforme des
retraites devient finalement je veux
dire une cause racine mais un prétexte à
une mobilisation qui soit beaucoup plus
large c'est à dire qu'il y a une
possibilité en effet d'une
synchronisation nous ne l'avons dans les
pages du Figaro il y a 15 jours avec
Stéphane Rozet on a produit un papier où
on disait qu'il y a une fenêtre
d'opportunité pour qu'il y ait une
synchronisation d'un certain nombre de
colères une convergence oui appelons une
convergence des luttes en tout cas je
sais pas c'est une convergence de lutte
mais c'est en tout cas une
synchronisation d'un certain nombre de
mécontentements diffus de catégories
sociales qui d'ailleurs parfois n'ont
pas toujours les mêmes intérêts mais qui
en tout cas
expriment le mal le même les mêmes
préoccupations les mêmes inquiétudes le
même mal être par rapport à leur vie à
quotidienne donc ce risque il est réel
contenu encore une fois de la situation
économique et la retraite la réforme des
retraites constituent ce point de vue là
un combustible supplémentaire pour
j'allais dire le le le mécontentement le
mécontentement général
il est regardez d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant exactement à Renan de nous
montrer cette cette banderole très
intéressante en outre-mer la
chloro-écone et la chlordécone pardon et
effectivement on voit bien qu'il y a des
références à d'autres à d'autres
à d'autres causes effectivement une
extension du domaine de sur la
dénonciation du du colonialisme à la
française mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que bon les syndicats
révolutionnaires et la gauche la gauche
radicale a toujours été
friande d'avoir plusieurs
d'amalgamer plusieurs causes on voyait
des drapeaux palestiniens le droit au
logement etc mais là c'est quelque chose
qui si je vous écoute va plus loin
au-delà entre les cas
de la simple convergence
c'est difficile de le dire mais en tout
cas il y a le risque le risque est réel
le risque est réel pour toutes les
raisons que l'on que l'on vient de que
l'on vient d'invoquer l'arrêter c'est
que si vous voulez l'ensemble des des
organisations à la fois syndicale mais
aussi politique qui soutiennent
actuellement les mobilisations contre
les retraites ne poursuivent pas toutes
les mêmes objectifs les mêmes les mêmes
buts pour Monsieur berger et là CFDT
c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui il faut
revoir la copie du gouvernement mais ça
ne va pas ça ne va pas au-delà mais par
exemple si l'on prend la France
insoumise il est clair que pour la
France insoumise il s'agit en effet
d'essayer de faire en sorte que l'on
puisse amalgamer un certain nombre de
colères pour d'une certaine manière
créer les conditions d'un troisième tour
social et éventuellement politique dans
dans la rue
actuellement ce qui
je pense fait tenir le mouvement fait
tenir notamment l'unité syndicale c'est
véritablement l'opposition commune au
texte que actuellement défend le
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
alors la vérité c'est que c'est que on
arrive dans une situation à terme on
arrive dans une situation de blocage
c'est-à-dire que si les mobilisations
restent aussi fortes et si le
gouvernement déroule son calendrier
parlementaire la question est de savoir
qu'est-ce qui va se passer après alors
c'est précisément la question qui se
pose d'abord une question au rédacteur
en chef de la revue parlementaire que
vous êtes où en étant des débats à
l'Assemblée je ne parle pas on va
revenir après sur la manière dont il se
passe mais là on en est à quoi au niveau
des examens d'articles on n'a pas
beaucoup avancé si vous voulez
véritablement aujourd'hui le véritable
le véritable sujet ce sera l'article 7
du texte justement sur le report de
l'âge qui porte sur le report sur le
report sur le report de l'âge on a vu
que
hier il y a eu une séance qui a été
particulièrement éruptive avec notamment
le vote par le Bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale d'une sanction d'exclusion
temporaire de 15 jours contre un député
de la France insoumise Monsieur Thomas
purple les débats avancent très
lentement avec un nombre d'abonnement
important qui n'est pas le plus grand
nombre d'abondements il faut le il faut
le dire qui a été déposé lors de séances
ces dernières années à l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle que quand même en
2006 lors de la privatisation de Gaz de
France on a déposé l'opposition à
déposer 130 000 amendements je crois que
même ils ont le majorité avait utilisé
le 49-3 même bien sûr et le et le et le
et lors du lors de la discussion
précédente sur un précédent texte sur
les retraites avoir la crise sanitaire
en 2020 il y a eu près de 40000
amendements qui avaient été déposés par
les oppositions donc si vous voulez on
n'est pas dans un record si vous voulez
de dépôt d'amendement mais on est quand
même dans une assemblée nationale qui
est particulièrement irruptive et
pourquoi elle est particulièrement irrup
parce que cette Assemblée nationale
peut-être pour la première fois depuis
30 ans ressemble véritablement au
rapport de force qui existe dans le pays
et pour autant dans le texte avance très
lentement et il est pas du tout sûr que
on arrive finalement à pouvoir adopter
le texte à l'Assemblée nationale dans le
délai des 20 jours que finalement permet
l'article 47 heures de la Constitution
c'est-à-dire un délai de discussion
extrêmement extrêmement finalement
contraint est-ce que l'Assemblée
nationale est plus représentative du
pays ça effectivement personne vous le
contestera par contre est-ce que la
façon dont les débats se passent à
l'assemblée des invectives se passent
les menaces les intimidations les SMS
envoyaient des députés des députés RN ou
bien les insultes telles que on les
raconte ce matin dans Le Figaro ou Louis
Boyard et Emmanuel Bompard vont
intimider un député MoDem qui dénonçait
le fait que Boyard avait
nommé tous les députés qui avait qui
avait voté en faveur en gros d'un
article qui allait dans le sens de la
réforme sans parler donc du député
Thomas port qui
[Musique]
a été exclu pour une quinzaine de jours
pour avoir pour pour avoir joué
au foot avec un ballon qui avait la
forme de la tête de Olivier du sol
est-ce que quand même c'est ça que
souhaite les Français est-ce que c'est
cette
stérilisation des débats c'est un fait
alors c'est pas la première fois que
l'Assemblée nationale sous la République
et quelle qu'elle soit et
particulièrement éruptive j'invite tous
ceux qui s'intéressent à la vie
parlementaire à consulter le journal des
Débats par exemple
des du mois de mars
1947 ou du mois de février 1948 au
moment des grandes grèves
insurrectionnelles et on verra que Jules
moque est soumis à une opposition du
groupe communiste qui est d'une rare
violence aussi il faut il faut il faut
jamais l'oublier même sous la Cinquième
République on a connu des débats encore
récemment qui était parfois extrêmement
convulsif ce qui est sûr c'est que il y
a vraisemment aussi peut-être une
transformation de la communication
politique à travers les réseaux sociaux
c'est qu'on voit que le débat ne
s'arrête pas hors de l'enceinte il
continue hors de l'enseigne notamment à
travers les réseaux sociaux et
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux qui
jouent un rôle très un rôle très
important j'allais dire presque dans le
monde nous a montré dans l'histérisation
du débat c'est à dire que ça ne s'arrête
jamais en l'occurrence et d'ailleurs ce
qui est intéressant en fin de compte
avec ce qui s'est passé avec le député
de la France insoumise Thomas porte
c'est qu'il est sanctionné finalement
sur un poste qui est un poste Twitter et
lors d'une mobilisation lors d'une
manifestation je crois d'inspecteur du
travail où il est présent donc c'est à
dire pour un comportement qui est hors
de l'enceinte parlementaire c'est pas à
l'intérieur de la scène parlementaire
c'est hors de l'enseigne parlementaire
donc si vous voulez c'est ça qui Vresse
en aujourd'hui pour toi en effet il y a
un risque c'est-à-dire que les Français
qui ont envoyé une Assemblée nationale
qui le ressemble
il y a un vieux fou qui parlementaire
aussi qui existait en France la France
n'est pas seulement un pays régis il
faut jamais louper c'est aussi un pays
qui peut très rapidement basculer dans
l'anti parlementarisme on l'a vécu sous
la Troisième République on a même vécu
sous la 4e République et il est évident
que le spectacle qui parfois est donné
en séance par un certain nombre de
députés ne constitue pas l'expression
d'une démocratie particulièrement d'une
démocratie parlementaire
particulièrement mature et le risque en
effet c'est que à un moment donné
l'opinion publique se retourne mais la
réalité c'est que il y a si vous voulez
une différence aujourd'hui entre ce qui
se passe dans la rue ou pour l'instant
encore une fois je parle très prudemment
on a des mobilisations sociales qui se
passent plutôt dans le calme par rapport
à d'autres mouvements qu'on a connu
récemment et une Assemblée nationale qui
elle par contre en l'occurrence est
particulièrement éruptive avec des
comportements qui en effet parfois
peuvent choquer alors précisément est-ce
que le débat n'est pas comme le dit ce
matin Guillaume notre infrard Guillaume
Bigot chez Europe 1 et cnews de
meilleure tenue dans la rue qu'au
Parlement
ah oui aujourd'hui clairement c'est à
dire que ce qui est assez frappant
depuis encore une fois le début de de
ces mobilisations c'est que les
manifestations se passent dans le calme
avec des services en effet du côté des
services de j'allais dire de
d'encadrement de la part des syndicats
qui
je crois font leur travail tout à fait
de manière très professionnelle et de la
même manière on voit bien que du côté de
la préfecture de police notamment à
Paris le changement doctrine en materne
en matière de maintien de l'ordre opéré
le retour en fait le changement le
retour de la doctrine et le retour de la
doctrine d'avant permet finalement de
pouvoir mieux maîtriser les les cortèges
et les mobilisations donc en effet il y
a quelque part un contraste entre ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans dans la rue
avec des syndicats qui font preuve d'une
certaine maturité à la fois dans
l'organisation des manifestations mais
aussi dans la dans la dans la stratégie
qui sont en train actuellement de
décliner dans leur j'allais dire
opposition à la réforme
des retraites et puis une scène
politique qui elle déborde de partout
avec des incidents de séance qui
viennent vraisemblablement en tout cas
largement ennuir à l'image de
l'assemblée de l'Assemblée nationale que
doit faire le gouvernement selon vous
Arnaud ce qu'il faut qu'il soit plus
souple et ce qui doit camper sur sa
position ou doit évoluer en tous les cas
s'assouplir sur deux ou trois points
c'est à dire c'est qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de marge de manœuvre parce que
à partir du moment où vous avez un
gouvernement qui dit que le l'âge de
départ en retraite
n'est pas négociable et que les
syndicats également considèrent que
c'est pas négociable les marges de
manœuvre et toutes j'allais dire toute
centrale syndicale confondues les marges
de manœuvres sont extrêmement réduites
le vrai sujet c'est de savoir si
l'opinion publique va continuer à
soutenir le mouvement dans la durée et
si l'opinion publique continuerait à
soutenir le mouvement si le mouvement en
venait à se durcir et c'est ce qui est
là
c'est ce qui est prévu le 7 mars
prochain est-ce qu'il faut croire à
cette idée que 60 % entre 4 c'est pas
une idée c'est une réalité 60% des
Français disent qu'ils sont prêts à
soutenir le blocage est-ce qu'ils seront
prêts à le faire y compris le 7 mars oui
moi je crois que si vous voulez la
stratégie des syndicats depuis le début
de ce mouvement est une stratégie qui
est assez habile c'est-à-dire que on on
travaille par gradation on fait monter
la mobilisation crescendo on utilise des
modes d'action qui sont des modes
d'action qui pour l'instant n'ont pas
véritablement bloqué le pays même s'il y
a eu des mouvements de grève dans les
transports mais que on prépare disons
psychologiquement l'opinion publique par
des mobilisations qui sont assez
responsables et qui sont assez massives
et apparemment plus massives en tout cas
ces derniers temps qu'au tout début on
prépare l'opinion publique à des
blocages et l'opinion publique
manifestement aujourd'hui quand on
regarde les études d'opinion n'est pas
host assez blocages on n'est pas dans la
situation où le blocage a lieu parce que
là il peut y avoir un moment donné une
une il peut y avoir un renversement je
voulais juste dire un point
rappelez-vous en 1995 en 1995 au début
du mouvement contre la réforme des
régimes spéciaux l'opinion publique
n'est pas favorable au mouvement
le mouvement est minoritaire il va le 2
il va devenir progressivement majorité
dans l'opinion publique et il va devenir
progressivement majoritaire dans
l'opinion publique malgré les blocages
on a parlé de rappelez-vous de greffe à
procuration à l'époque est-ce qu'on a
dans cette situation que la grève par
procuration était surtout soutenue par
ceux qui étaient les moins touchés par
les blocages moi plus à l'époque
en province qu'à Paris qui avait été
vraiment paralysé et certains s'en
souviennent encore est-ce
963000 manifestants dans toute la France
selon le mystère d'intérieur donc on
n'est pas au million mais c'est en tout
cas en hausse par rapport au
757000 manifestants de mardi dernier
est-ce une pour Laurent Berger
c'est une revanche en tout cas ça valide
une partie de sa stratégie c'est à dire
je crois qu'il impose quand même le
tempo des manifestations pour l'instant
donc il est disons celui qui inspire
j'allais dire la démarche
c'est une revanche par rapport en effet
j'allais dire l'intransigeance du
gouvernement et
l'intransigence qui devient compte tel
oui c'est une c'est une c'est
l'attestation que aujourd'hui il y a une
mobilisation qui est importante en
France et que la CFDT y joue un rôle
essentiel en l'occurrence et cette façon
Laurent Berger n'a pas tellement le
choix il faut quand même se souvenir que
les la plupart aujourd'hui des
grandes des grandes unités
professionnelles de la de la de la CFDT
de toute façon a été opposé initialement
à cette réforme donc j'allais dire il
est leur chef il les suit aussi il faut
jamais oublier cela il a mandat pour les
suivre si on fait
quelques quelques questions politique
pour conclure finalement au plan
politique est-ce que la France insoumise
et la gauche sortent grandit de cette
semaine de débat
extrêmement compliqué de le dire ce qui
est sûr c'est que à gauche tous n'ont
pas la même la même la même stratégie
mais là aussi indéniablement c'est quand
même elle est fille qui importe son
tempo à la nups donc ils en sortent en
force donc ils en sortent en tout cas
renforcés dans leur stratégie de
leadership à gauche ils ont préempté à
gauche la place du de l'opposition le
plus des opposants les plus combatifs et
les plus déterminés mais si vous voulez
ils sont dans un segment de l'opinion
publique
certes qu'il les soutient mais ce
segment est loin d'être majoritaire et
parmi tous ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
aussi
à tous ceux qui sont hostiles à la
réforme de retraite ne sont pas tous des
électeurs et des électrices de la France
insoumise et il ne faut pas non plus
considérer que c'est la France insoumise
loin de là qui mobilise aujourd'hui dans
la rue même si du côté du gouvernement
on l'a vu à travers les déclarations de
Darmanin il y a maintenant une dizaine
de jours lorsqu'il l'accusait du
ministre de l'Intérieur lorsqu'il
diffusé la France insoumise de
bordéliser le pays et la tentation en
effet d'essayer d'assimiler l'ensemble
du mouvement à la seule France insoumise
non aujourd'hui on peut dire clairement
la victoire c'est plutôt la victoire des
syndicats et la victoire des syndicats
parce qu'ils sont unis et parce qu'ils
arrivent à déplacer des gens dans la rue
à gauche c'est une autre affaire est-ce
que les républicains comment justement
sortent les républicains de cette de
cette séquence enfin qu'il est pas
encore terminé
c'est compliqué parce que d'abord il y a
la position officielle des républicains
il y a la position officielle des
dirigeants des républicains de Monsieur
Ciotti des présidents de groupe
parlementaires et puis on voit qu'il y a
un certain nombre de républicains qui
aujourd'hui
sont plutôt sur la sur la réserve quant
à ce quant à ce lien notamment Aurélien
notamment Aurélien Pradier
le problème c'est de voir encore une
fois comment le mouvement social va
évoluer il est évident que si vous
voulez l'Assemblée nationale de toute
façon quelque soit n'est pas une
enceinte qui est totalement étanche par
rapport à ce qui se passe dans la rue
donc si la mobilisation venait à grossir
dans les mois de faire les semaines qui
viennent quelle sera la réaction des
députés républicains on le verra bien en
tout cas pour l'instant les députés
républicains quand même soutiennent la
raiforme qu'est-ce que ça aura quand
même impact ensuite sur leur électorat
c'est difficile de lire en tout cas leur
électorat est plutôt favorable la
réforme quand on est quand on regarde
les études les études d'opinion qui sont
qui sont effectués
la vraie question c'est de savoir après
comment ils vont gérer d'autres textes
si ce texte est évidemment adopté par
l'Assemblée et par le Parlement je pense
notamment au texte concernant
l'immigration qui d'ailleurs va arriver
au Sénat dans dans peu de temps le
rassemblement national le rassemblement
national a fait le choix d'une
opposition qui est une opposition
déterminée mais qui se veut j'allais
dire respectable et on le voit c'est à
dire il joue le jeu des institutions
sans excès dans les travées on a vu
d'ailleurs que Marine Le Pen est une des
toutes premières à avoir condamné le
poste du député de la France insoumise
monsieur porte qu'ils ont voté la
sanction la sourde lors du lors
de fortnite ça veut dire aussi que je
dis ils sont ils essayent en tout cas de
tenir une ligne qui se veut une ligne de
respectabilité enfin tout simplement de
crédibiliser leur image j'allais dire de
partie de gouvernement qu'ils veulent
devenir donc du côté du rassemblement
national de toute façon aujourd'hui il
capit sur la colère et capitalise sur le
mécontentement
sans véritablement créer des allergies
par leur par leur comportement et c'est
la stratégie en tout cas qui qui est
opérée par Marine Le Pen et par Monsieur
Bardella je termine on va j'aurai une
dernière question mon cher Arnaud pour
vous mais avant on va conclure place de
la République place de la Nation pardon
avec
Timothée délène
Timothée le cortège est arrivé à Nation
est-ce qu'il y a encore des arrivées là
où vous trouvez
non Vincent le cortège qui est
définitivement arrivé sur cette place de
la Nation le cortège syndical qui met
toujours un petit peu plus de temps à
arriver vous le voyez je me trouve ici
au début de ce boulevard Voltaire et
donc c'est dizaines de quart de CRS qui
sont ici pour marquer la fin du cortège
voilà ça fait une bonne heure maintenant
que nous sommes arrivés avec Julien
Leclerc sur cette place de la Nation les
syndicats sont eux arrivés il y a
peut-être 20 minutes à peu près ici vous
voyez c'est CRS qui sont habillés avec
leurs calots ce qui veut dire qu'ils
n'ont pas eu besoin de mettre leur
casque et ce qui veut donc dire que les
choses la manifestation en tout cas se
termine dans le calme ici sur cette
place de la Nation c'est vrai que on a
pu on a l'habitude on a pu voir en tout
cas lors des précédentes manifestations
des bruits de pétards des prix de
mortier des invectives avec les forces
de l'ordre aujourd'hui nous constatons
que ça n'est pas le cas en tout cas pour
ce qui est de cette fin de manifestation
il y a ces traditionnelles grillades
cette odeur de grillade il y a des
champs voilà des chants anticapitalistes
voilà alors que l'éclairage public
d'ailleurs s'allume à l'instant même
parce que la nuit évidemment est en
train de tomber et que le froid est en
train d'arriver sur cette place de la
Nation et les manifestants qui comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure continue
d'évacuer les lieux d'ailleurs cela se
voit à vue d'oeil de moins en moins de
monde ici parce que la manifestation
tout simplement est en train de se
terminer dans le calme
du coup Timothée
merci pour toutes ces précisions merci
d'avoir suivi la manifestation le
cortège parfois dans la tension avec
Julien Leclerc qu'on salue aussi merci
beaucoup aux équipes de figarolive de
d'avoir été mobilisés à celle du Figaro
merci à Timothée donc Julien Renan les
Blaise reine Marie degré du loup
Florence et Lizard Mathieu Mathis
fleuret et François Carpentier a la à
l'édition et odesk du du Figaro et de
figure live et bien sûr à tous ceux qui
ont témoigné sur ce plan plateau a
commencé par vous chers internautes
chers Arnaud la question la dernière
question qui est-ce que il faut encore
guetter et qu'allez-vous guetter
les prochains mois d'action des
syndicats déjà dans un premier temps
apparemment en tout cas il y a une
journée qui est attendue importante le 7
mars avec manifestement si j'ai bien
compris un déplacement à Albi alors ça
c'est de prévu dès jeudi les jeudis de
jeudi
ça veut dire que quelque part les
syndicats jouent aussi la province
c'est-à-dire que ça ne se joue pas qu'à
Paris ça se joue aussi en province parce
qu'ils sont en train de s'apercevoir que
la province constitue un gisier de
mobilisation extrêmement important
de mobilisation pardon mais donc ça
c'est important je crois que c'est un
élément important puis ensuite il y a la
suite de la discussion parlementaire
est-ce que finalement on ira jusqu'au
bout de la discussion
le le de du projet de loi moi j'en doute
au regard finalement des des incidents
de séances ça veut dire que le projet
partirait exactement c'est là ensuite le
vrai la vraie question c'est de savoir
entre la mobilisation dans la rue et la
temporalité parlementaire qu'est-ce
qu'il emportera c'est j'allais dire un
sujet qui en tout cas et c'est une
question qui reste ouverte allez les
lumières sont allumées les lumières
s'allument sur la place de la Nation
c'est pas encore la sobriété énergétique
et le corps tout le cortège se termine
c'est sur ces images qu'on va vous
laisser je vous donne les derniers
chiffres à 963000 manifestants dans la
France dans toute la France selon le
ministère de l'intérieur c'est mieux que
mardi dernier 757
000 manifestants ce jour-là en tous les
cas on vous laisse sur ces images merci
de nous avoir suivi sur pour le live
vidéo le live texte lui il continue il
est en dessous de ce player et vous
pouvez continuer à le suivre à le lire
avec toutes les informations des
journalistes du Figaro qui sont les
informations les plus affûtées que vous
pourrait avoir merci beaucoup on se
retrouve demain en live en vidéo pour le
Grand Jury à partir de de midi et puis
également toute la vidéo la vidéo
continue sur le sur le Figaro et on se
retrouve pour toutes les émissions
des lundis sur le Figaro live merci de
nous avoir suivi on garde les images à
très vite sur le site du Figaro